THE JOINT SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE SENATE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
AND THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE'S SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING. AND THE CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AS WELL
AS PANELISTS WHO HAVE BEEN ASKED
TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC ISSUES
REFERRED. TO WITH REGARD TO
MASSAGE THERAPY. FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BE ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE FINISHED ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT
YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS.
THE JOINT COMMITTEE. HELLO THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THE
SENATE GALLERY TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING.
REQUIREMENTS HELLO. AND WE'LL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER. AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR SIX
SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING PUBLIC COMMENT
MAY BE PROVIDED ON EACH PROGRAM
UPON THE CONCLUSION OF
QUESTIONS. FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST. MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING HEARING
ON PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
THIS REGARD. I WILL BE
MAINTAINING DECORUM DURING THIS
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION THIS MUTED. TODAY IS
THE THIRD IN OUR SERIES OF
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARINGS
THIS YEAR THESE HEARINGS ALLOW
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS. OF REGULATORY
PROGRAMS AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CHANGES IN THE LAW. OR
IN THE PROGRAM OPERATION OR
FUNCTION. ARE NECESSARY. WE
BUILT WE WILL BE REVIEWING
SPECIFIC ISSUES REGARDING THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING AND
THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL. THESE PROGRAMS WERE THE
SUBJECT OF HEARINGS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. TODAY'S
DISCUSSIONS ARE A FOLLOW UP TO
THOSE HEARINGS AND WILL PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR FURTHER
EVALUATION OF THE REGULATION OF
NURSES AND MASSAGE THERAPISTS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO IT THE SYSTEM
THIS REVIEW AND EVALUATION OF
EACH AGENCY COMMISSION STAFF
PREPARED BACKGROUND PAPERS WHICH
IDENTIFY ISSUES AND MAKE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EACH
PROGRAM. THE PAPERS HAVE BEEN
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND MADE AVAILABLE TO
INTERESTED PARTIES. DURING THIS
PROCESS TODAY EACH PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
PROGRAM FUNCTIONS. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEES WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE ANY OTHER
ISSUES OR QUESTIONS WHICH THEY
MAY HAVE. WE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS. AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR EACH PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. AT THIS POINT I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE MY
DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC BERMAN CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. TO MAKE
ANY OPENING REMARKS HE DESIRES
TO MAKE SIR THANK YOU JERRY
ROTH- I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
SENATE FOR HOSTING US TODAY WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES. ARE
CALLING FOR JOINING US TODAY
LOOK FOR THE CONVERSATION THANKS
MUCH THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING. BEFORE WE BEGIN
WITH OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO PARTICIPATE.
TO CALL IN NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE. 585-844-2914 ONE
EIGHT FIVE. WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE
USE THE ACCESS CODE. FOUR SIX
SIX THREE NINE SIX EIGHT. WE
WILL NOW HEAR FROM THE LAURA
STREET HE- PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING AND
LORETTA MEL B. THE BOARD'S
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WELCOME.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING I AM DIVORCED YOYO AND I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING. IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO
SPEAK WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
WITH ME TODAY IS OUR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER LORETTA MELBY. WHO SINCE
ASSUMING THIS ROLE IN FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY AND SINCE OUR LAST
SUNSET HEARING HAS LED B. R. N.
THROUGH THE FOLLOWING MAJOR
IMPROVEMENTS AND EFFICIENCIES.
IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- COLLABORATION WITH THE CA
BRN LAUNCH THE APPLICATION
STATUS AND DETAILS TOOL ON THE
BEER AND WEBSITE. THIS NEW TOOL
PROVIDES APPLICANTS AND
LICENSEES WITH DETAILED
INFORMATION AND THE PROGRESSION
OF THEIR INITIAL AND RENEWAL
APPLICATIONS INCLUDING ANY ITEMS
THAT ARE DEFICIENT. TO FURTHER
IMPROVE CUSTOMER SERVICE THE B.
R. N. ALSO REMOVED THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE SUBMISSION
OF A PASSPORT LIKE PHOTO. AS
WELL AS THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
SUBMISSION OF DUPLICATE
TRANSCRIPTS AND OTHER
DOCUMENTATION FOR REPEAT
EXAMINATION APPLICATIONS. BOTH
OF WHICH HELP TO REDUCE THE
DEFICIENCIES WITHIN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS THUS
IMPROVING PROCESSING TIME FRAMES
. IN THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO REDUCE DUPLICATION AND
RESTRUCTURE CONTINUING APPROVAL
VISITS ALSO KNOWN AS C.
EIGHTIES. FOR NURSING PROGRAMS
APPEARANCE WHICH IS IMPEDED IN
ITS FIRST JOINT C. A. B. WITH
THE ACCREDITATION COMMISSION FOR
EDUCATION IN NURSING ALSO KNOWN
AS A C. E. M. THIS JOINT EFFORT
IDENTIFIED SIMILARITIES. BUT
CONFIRM THE VAST DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN AND ACCREDITORS PROCESS
UTILIZING AN EVALUATION APPROACH
AND THE ROLE OF THE REGULATOR
WHO SERVES AS CONSULTANT. THE B.
R. N. HAS A LINE OF TEACHERS C.
EIGHTY. WITH A PREDATION VISITS
AND WILL LEVERAGE THE
ACCREDITORS REVIEW TO REDUCE
DUPLICATION AND INCREASE
EFFICIENCY WHERE POSSIBLE. ALSO
THIS PAST FALL IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE CA AND A CONTRACTED IT
VENDOR THE BEER AND DEVELOP A
NEW SECURE PORTAL AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA APPROVED PRE
LICENSURE NURSING PROGRAM. THIS
NEW PROCESS ELIMINATES THE NEED
FOR SUBMISSION OF INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL TRANSCRIPTS. AND
EXPEDITES THE CALIFORNIA
EXAMINATION APPROVAL PROCESS
WHICH ALLOWS STUDENTS TO
SCHEDULE THEIR INFLUX SOON- THAN
IN THE PAST. THIS IS SIGNIFICANT
. BECAUSE IN GENERAL THE EARLIER
A GRADUATE TAKES THE INFLUX
AFTER COMPLETING A NURSING
PROGRAM THE HIGHER THE
LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESSFULLY
PASSING THE EXAM AND ENTERING
THE WORK FORCE I POINT.
ADDITIONALLY IN NOVEMBER THE
BOARD APPROVED A NEW STRATEGIC
PLAN. FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THIS
STRATEGIC PLAN IS POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE AND INCLUDES OUR NEW
MISSION. TO PROTECT THE HEALTH.
FIFTY AND WELL BEING OF THE
PUBLIC. THROUGH THE FAIR AND
CONSISTENT APPLICATION OF THE
STATUTES AND REGULATIONS
GOVERNING NURSING PRACTICES AND
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA. FINALLY
OUR MOST RECENT EFFICIENCY HEARD
THIS MONTH WHEN IN COLLABORATION
WITH N. C. S. B. N. B. R. N.
IMPLEMENTED MERCIES. TO PROVIDE
THE LICENSE VERIFICATION SERVICE
FOR OUR ENDS LICENSED IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS ALIGNS THE B.
R. AND WITH OTHER STATES AND
TERRITORIES USING NURSES FOR
THEIR LICENSE VERIFICATION. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. AS YOU CAN
SEE THE BOARD HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENTS. AND
EFFICIENCIES OVER THIS PAST YEAR
. WE CONTINUE TO SEEK FEEDBACK
FROM STAKEHOLDERS TO BUILD A
FOUNDATION THAT WILL BE
SUSTAINABLE AND NIMBLE OVER THE
COURSE OF TIME. THANKS AGAIN AND
LORETTA AND I ARE AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR HILL
MISS MOBLIE ANY ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS. NOW I THINK SHE SUMMED
IT UP PERFECTLY THANK YOU. OKAY-
BERMAN ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
TEAR FF I'M HAPPY THAT- LIKE
COLLEAGUES- GO FIRST AND I'LL
SEE IF I HAVE ANY QUESTIONS WANT
TO EVER GET THE CHANCE RICHARD
THANK YOU A SEMI MEMBER OR ONE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
ROTH SO DURING COVERT WE SAW A
MAN. AT LEAST REGIONALLY NURSING
SHORTAGES AND I THINK ONE OF THE
IMPEDIMENTS TO GETTING. THE
NURSES OUT INTO PRACTICE IS- THE
LACK OF CLINICAL SLOTS AND SO-
PRIOR TO A. B. A TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT. I WAS WHICH I WAS
A CO AUTHOR OF. OF BEER AND
REGULATIONS ONLY ALLOWED. A
NURSING SCHOOLS TO UTILIZE 25%
OF- CLINICAL SIMULATION AS A
SUBSTITUTE FOR- FOR CLINICAL
HOURS SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY
THIS IS THE CASE AND- ARE YOU
TAKING STEPS TO CONSIDER MOVING
UP TO. A 50% LIKE MANY OTHER
STATES THAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THIS IS- LORENA FOR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AND I'D LIKE
TO ANSWER THAT THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN- WE ARE DOING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS AND WE ACTUALLY
STARTED WITH READING LOOKING AT
OUR REGULATION BACK REGULATION
IN ALIGNMENT- FIGHT SELF IS NOT
AFFECTED AND- I'M THE FIRST ONE
TO ACTUALLY SAY THAT. SO WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THAT REGULATION
WHICH IS FOURTEEN SIXTY THREE
SIXTEEN C. C. R. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX STARTED WITH A NURSE RIGHT
HERE AT THE BEGINNING BUT ALL
WORK THROUGH THOSE- IT SAYS THAT
YOU NEED EIGHTEEN SEMESTER UNITS
IN NURSING CLINICAL- AND THEN
THOSE SEMESTER UNITS ARE BASED
ON THE WEEK AND SO THERE'S NOT A
STANDARD OUR NUMBER SO SOME
SCHOOLS CHOOSE THREE OUT OF
THREE UNIX IN PEDIATRICS SO 50%
OF THAT WOULD BE A GOOD AND A
HALF SOME SCHOOLS HAVE UNIT
HAPPEN PEDIATRICS AND STUPID YOU
PERCENT OF THAT WOULD BE A POINT
SEVEN FIVE CREDIT. SO WE DON'T
HAVE A BASELINE SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE END C-SPAN SIMULATION
STUDY THAT WE'VE THEY'VE BEEN
KIND OF PUSHING OUT FOR PROBABLY
TEN YEARS NOW THE FIRST THING IT
SAYS IS TO ESTABLISH A DIRECT
PATIENT CARE CLINICAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT'S WHAT OUR
BOARD VOTED IN NOVEMBER TO DO SO
IN NOVEMBER IN. A BOARD MEETING
I EXPLAINED. IS THAT WE HAVE
WITH. WITH THAT MINIMUM DIRECT
PATIENT CARE THAT ALLOWS FOR THE
SCHOOLS TO DO AS MUCH SIMULATION
AS THEY CAN SUPPORT. IF THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT IT
IF THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SUPPORT THE FACULTY TO TEACH IT.
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO DO AS
MUCH STIMULATION AS THEY WANT AS
LONG AS THEY MEET THE MINIMUM
DIRECT PATIENT CARE REQUIREMENTS
. CALIFORNIA PLANS TO ALIGN WITH
STATES LIKE WASHINGTON OREGON
AND WASHINGTON. AND OTHERS WERE
THEY HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM A
SIMULATION PERCENTAGE AND
LAUGHTER THAT TO THEIR DEANS AND
DIRECTORS TO ESTABLISH WHAT
WORKS BEST FOR THEM ACCORDING TO
THEIR DEMOGRAPHIC THAT THEY
SERVE. AND THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY HAVE SO CALIFORNIA. UNTIL
WE STARTED TALKING ABOUT AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT I'VE
NEVER HAD ANYTHING IN THEIR
STATUTE REGARDING SIMULATION OR
EVEN IN THE REGULATIONS
REGARDING SIMULATION. WE HAD
NEVER HAD ANY AUTHORITY OVER
THAT- WE ONLY HAD A BIRDIE THAT
TALK TO THE DIRECT PATIENT CARE
REQUIREMENTS. SO WE WILL
CONTINUE THAT PROCESS WE WILL
SET A STANDARD DRINK. MINIMUM
POWER REQUIREMENTS THIS YEAR IN
REGULATION UNLESS YOU GUYS WANT
TO ADD THAT AS PART OF OUR
SUNSET BILL- AND WE WILL FOLLOW
THAT AND ALLOW OUR DEANS AND
DIRECTORS TO HAVE CARTE BLANCHE
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO WITH STIMULATION. WHAT
KIND OF RESOURCES THEY HAVE TO
SUPPORT THAT AND WAS LONG AS A
SERVICE TO DEMOGRAPHIC THE
CABBIE OUGHT TO THAT IS WE DO
APPROVE THE CURRICULUM. SO WE DO
KNOW WHAT THE CLINICAL
OBJECTIVES ARE IN PART OF OUR
OVERSIGHT IS TO ENSURE THAT
WHATEVER THEY DO OUTSIDE OF THE
DIRECT PATIENT CARE. MANAGES TO
PREPARE THOSE STUDENTS TO BE
SAFE AND COMPETENT NURSES AFTER
GRADUATION AND. MEETS THOSE
CLINICAL PROJECT. OKAY YOU THAT
SIR. SO WITH THE MINIMUM AND-
DIRECT PATIENT CARE HOURS- THAT
YOUR THAT YOU WERE LOOKING AT-
THIS YEAR DO YOU THINK THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE AN INCREASE
IN THE USE OF SIMULATION AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY WE'VE- WE'VE-
LOOKED AT DATA. AND THAT THERE
IS. A CLINICAL SIMULATION HAS
COME A REALLY LONG WAY AND IT
SHOWED THE DATA SHOWS THAT IT
INCREASES CRITICAL THINKING AND
DECISION MAKING. AND AIDS IN A
CROSS CULTURAL CARE SO DO YOU
SEE IT YOU KNOW IT'S HARD FOR ME
WHEN YOU SAY WE'VE TO SET OUR
SETTING A MINIMUM STANDARD FOR
DIRECT PATIENT CARE. DOES THAT
MEAN DO YOU SEE. A AN INCREASE
IN SIMULATION. I MEAN IS THAT
ALL THE CABBIE OUTS THAT YOU
HAVE PUT FORWARD. YEAH THERE ARE
SCHOOLS THAT DO SIMULATION
REALLY WELL THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY HAVE THE STAFF
THEY HAVE THE FACILITIES THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO EVERYTHING THOSE
SCHOOLS WILL INCREASE IN
SIMULATION BUT THE OTHER THING
THAT THIS DOES WHICH IS KIND OF
AN INTENSIVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WHICH IS ACTUALLY
NOT A CONSEQUENCE AT ALL. IS
BECAUSE IT ESTABLISHES A MINIMUM
DIRECT PATIENT CARE AND THE
SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE LIKE ONE OF
THE EXAMPLES WE USED IS WE HAD A
SCHOOL THAT HAD TWENTY FOUR
UNITS THAT THEY WANTED TO USE IN
CLINIC- SINCE THE EIGHTEEN UNITS
THAT WERE REQUIRED. WHAT SIX
ADDITIONAL UNITS OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY BUT EACH ONE OF THEIR
STUDENTS NEEDED TO OBTAIN IN
ORDER TO GRADUATE THAT MEANT A
LARGER STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND
THAT MEANT MORE CLINICAL IN
ACTION. SO WHEN WE SET THIS
MINIMUM STANDARD IT'S BEEN A
WHOLE STUDENTS OUT OF THAT
COMMUNITY DECREASE THE CLINICAL
IMPACTION AND ALLOW FOR SCHOOLS
TO HAVE AS MUCH CLINICAL-
STIMULATION THAT THEY CHOOSE TO
HAVE. YOUR REGARDLESS OF THE B.
R. N. SO THAT THEY CAN EIGHTEEN
FACULTY LOADS THEY CAN INCREASE
THEIR SIMULATION THAT WILL BE UP
TO THEM BECAUSE THERE IS A VAST
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SIMULATIONS
WE HAVE SOME. THAT ARE
COMPUTERIZED HIM THERE ARE SOME
THAT ARE HIGH FIDELITY STEM
SUMMER EVEN DOING VIRTUAL
REALITY SO AS LONG AS THEY MEET
THE GRADUATE OUTCOMES IN THE
CLINICAL OUTCOMES I THINK OUR
PROGRAMS WERE ABSOLUTELY STEP UP
AND USE THAT AND IT WILL
ACTUALLY WORK TO. EFFECTIVELY
DECREASING CLINICAL IMPACTION
AND YOU'RE RIGHT- HI WHEN I WAS
IN MY DOCTOR'S PREPAY ONLY
COMPLETED ONE YEAR HAVEN'T
PLAYED IT YET ONE OF MY
ORIGINAL- POINTS OF LOOKING AT
WAS SIMULATION AND I ACTUALLY
SERVED- UNDER KT WAXMAN IN BY
JUST GOING TO ALL OF OUR CLASSES
HE WAS. REALLY ON THE FOREFRONT
OF DEVELOPING SIMULATION SO I
HAVE A HUGE TRUST OF SIMULATION
AND I. TRULY BELIEVE THAT IT IS
A GREAT ADS TO THE PATIENT. SO
WE ARE NEED KIND OF STAY THERE
THEIR OWN BROWN WE SET THE SCENE
FOR MEN DIRECT. CARE AND LET THE
SCHOOLS WITH THEIR DEANS AND
DIRECTORS PARTNERING WITH THEIR
SIMULATION EXPERTS DEVELOP
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEM. THANK YOU
AND THEN- ONE OTHER THING ON THE
NOTE OF FLEXIBILITY RIGHT. B. R.
AND REGULATIONS REQUIRE
CONCURRENCE BETWEEN- THEORY AND
CLINICALS. AND HAS THERE BEEN
SOME THOUGHT ABOUT ALLOWING- THE
THEORY TO BE TAKEN FIRST BEFORE
YOU DO CLINICALS JUST. SO YOU
DON'T DEAL WITH- BOTTLENECKS IN-
AND- PUTTING PATIENTS OUT ART OR
A PUTTING IT AHEAD. MOVING
THROUGH THE SYSTEM I SHOULD SAY
. SO I GUESS I'LL ANSWER THAT IN
A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS THOUGH
SO THE FIRST ONE IS THEY HAVE
COMPLETE AUTONOMY WITHIN THEIR
CURRENT SEMESTER RIGHT NOW TO DO
THAT CLINICAL INFERI SCHEDULING.
SO IF THEY HAVE A SIXTEEN WEEK
SEMESTER AND THEY WANT TO FOCUS
THE FIRST EIGHT WEEKS ON THIRD.
AND THEN GO THE FINAL EIGHT
WEEKS INTO SIMULATION THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY ACCEPTABLE CURRENTLY
WITHIN OUR REGULATIONS AND
SOMETHING THAT WE ENCOURAGE WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH SCHEDULING
DIFFICULTIES THERE ARE SOME
PROGRAMS THAT ACTUALLY DO A TWO
DAY INTENSIVE BOOT CAMP THE
FIRST COUPLE DAYS OF THE
SEMESTER AND THEN THEY GO INTO
CLINICALS IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT
AND ROTATE PEOPLE THROUGH ON A
GROUP LIKE BASIS. WE ARE IN
COMPLETE SUPPORT WITH THAT SO
THAT FLEXIBILITY IS THERE AND IS
ENCOURAGED WE ALSO HAVE- A KEY
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT ARE WE AND
RICHER AND HE SEES THAT WORK
WITH THESE PROGRAMS SPECIFICALLY
AND IF THEY DO COME ACROSS A
TIME WHERE THEY SAY HEY I HAVE
FIVE STUDENTS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO FINISH THEIR CLINICALS
WITHIN THE SEMESTER. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO WORK WITH THEM TO
WRAP THAT UP THE NEC'S WORK WITH
THEM THE PROGRAM GIVES THEM AN
INCOMPLETE THAT ALLOW SOME
FOURTEEN ADDITIONAL DAYS POST
THIS SEMESTER TO CLEAR UP THOSE
HOURS THEY CLEAR THOSE HOURS
AFTER THEY MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SEMESTER. THE THING IS THE OLD.
WHICH TO ME. THOSE HOURS INTO
THE NEXT THE MASTER THAT I
TALKED ABOUT IN OUR SENSE OF
HEARING NUMBER TWO LAST YEAR IN
MAY. THAT IS TRULY AN ALLERGY I
USED AT THAT POINT THE BAD PAID
A MONTH BECAUSE YOU HAVE
CLINICAL HOURS YOU HAVE TO BE IN
THAT NEXT SEMESTER. SO YOU END
UP BEHIND THE EIGHT BALL GOING
INTO THAT NEXT SEMESTER.
INUNDATING THE CLINICAL SITES
THAT YOU'RE ALREADY USING FOR
THAT NEXT SEMESTER TO SCHEDULE
YOUR CLINICALS ARE NEEDED BAD.
AND JUST LIKE TRYING TO MAKE UP
THE REMAINING CLINICAL HOURS
FROM THE SEMESTER BEFORE. THAT
YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO COMPLETE. SO
THAT FROM A SCHEDULING BASIS AND
IT IMPACTED THE COMMUNITY IS
REALLY NOT AN EFFECTIVE PROCESS
. WHY WE ALSO HAVE EVIDENCE AS
TO WHY IT IS IMPERATIVE TO DO
THEORY AND CLINICAL CONCURRENT
WHEN YOU'RE I THE CLASSROOM AND
YOU'RE TEACHING A SUBJECT CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT- HOLD PERSON
STEPPED AWAY ARE YOU TALK ABOUT-
TWO TROLLEY OF HELLO AND YOU
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO SEE
THAT IN THE CLINICAL SETTING OR
PRACTICE THAT IN A SIMULATION-
YOU KIND YOU KIND OF LOSE IT AND
SO YOU NEED TO HAVE THAT THEORY
WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON GO TO THE CLINICAL
SETTING. LET YOUR CLINICAL
PARTNER SAY HEY MY STUDENTS ARE
LEARNING ABOUT CARDIAC RIGHT NOW
CAN YOU GIVE ME ANY CARDIAC
PATIENTS WE WANT OBSERVE WE WANT
TO PARTICIPATE THEY SEE THINGS
IN REAL LIFE BECAUSE AS WE KNOW
EVERY PERSON IS DIFFERENT BIG
OUR EXPERIENCE THAT THEY BRING
THOSE QUESTIONS BACK TO THE
THEORY INSTRUCT THE NEXT WEEK
AND SAY THIS IS WHAT I SAW ON
CLINICAL THAT'S NOT WHAT I HEARD
IN THEORY MAKE HAT MAKES SENSE
FOR ME AND THEY USE THAT ON A
SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP FOR
FEEDBACK AND SO IT IS
IMPERATIVE. THAT THEY HAVE THOSE
REALLY CLOSE TOGETHER AND THAT
IS WHY WE HAVE THIS CONCURRENCY
REQUIREMENTS IT'S REALLY TO AID
AND THEN BEING ABLE TO LEARN
THAT CONTACT CONTACT SEE IT IN
ACTION BRING QUESTIONS BACK AND
REALLY HAVE THAT EMBEDDED IN
THEIR KNOWLEDGE THEIR NOT HAVING
TO GUESS WHEN THEY'RE TAKING
CARE OF A PATIENT LATER ON THAT
THEY MIGHT NOT. HAVE SEEN IT
EXPOSED TO. SO I GUESS I'D HAVE
ONE WAY QUESTION ALONG THOSE
HAVE YOU SEEN DATA THAT IT'S
MORE EFFECTIVE TO DO THAT WAY.
TO DO IT THAT WAY BECAUSE
CERTAINLY THERE ARE OTHER
HEALING ARTS LIKE A MEDICINE AND
PHYSICAL THERAPY WHICH REQUIRE-
THE THEORY BE TAUGHT. BEFORE THE
CLINICAL. YEAH THERE IS DATA
THAT THERE IS THERE'S- THERE'S-
A LOT OF DATA RIGHT BEFORE- THE
COLD OUTBREAK THAT REALLY KIND
OF TALKED ABOUT THE THEORY
PRACTICE GAP AND THEY TALKED
ABOUT HOW EDUCATION AKADEMI ARE
PREPARING THE STUDENTS FOR
PRACTICE YET WHEN THE PRACTICE
SETTING REACHES THEM OUR HIRES
THEM THEY'RE NOT READY. AND SO
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT-
INCREASINGNEW GRAD PROGRAMS WAY
BACK WAY WAY BACK WHEN I BECAME
A NURSE TWENTY SOME YEARS AGO WE
WERE DOING SIX WEEK- NEW GRAD
PROGRAMS. BAND WHEN I WAS A
CLINICAL EDUCATOR AT THE BEDSIDE
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT INCREASING
THE SIX MONTHS ENDING MAYBE EVEN
A YEAR TO REALLY GET OUR NURSES
SUPPORTED BECAUSE THERE'S SO
MUCH TO JUST STICKS OUT THERE.
THAT TALK ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
ACCIDENTS THAT WE HAVE OF NURSES
ENTER PRACTICE WITHIN TWO YEARS
SO WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
WORK FORCE SHORTAGE YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE HIGH POINT OF
NURSES. IT'S MORE THAN JUST
PUTTING THEM THROUGH SCHOOL AND
GETTING THEM TO PASS THE AND
PLAQUES IT'S PUTTING THEM
THROUGH SCHOOL GETTING THE PASS
AND PLAQUE. AND COLLECTS MAKING
SURE THEY'RE SUPPORTED SO THAT
WHEN THEY'RE TWO YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD YOU DECIDE TO STAY IN
NURSING. THEY DECIDED TO STAY
AND TAKE CARE OF THE REASONS
THAT THEY WERE PREPARED TO DO
THE WORST JUST SERVICE THAT WE
DO IS PREPARE THESE STUDENTS IN
ADEQUATELY. PUT THEM INTO THE
WORK FORCE DO NOT SUPPORT THEM
AND WITH THEIR JOB ASPIRATION IS
BAD WITH THEIR LIFE GOALS BAND
FOR ALL OF THEIR YEARS THEY
DECIDEYOU KNOW WHAT NO THIS IS
NOT RIGHT FOR ME. AND THAT'S
WHERE WE REALLY NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT SO YEAH THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY EVIDENCE THAT SHOWS
THAT TIS WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE
IT STARTED WAY WAY WAY BACK WHEN
WE WERE DOING DIPLOMA PROGRAMS
AND THEY WOULD GO TO SCHOOL IN
THE MORNING. AND THEY WOULD GO
INTO THE CLINICAL PRACTICE THAT
EVENING AND BY THE TIME THEY
GRADUATED SCHOOL THEY WERE
RUNNING THE NURSING FLOOR
BECAUSE THEY WERE EACH SEEING
EVERYTHING PARTICIPATING IN
EVERYTHING. IN THE NURSING
STUDENTS KNOW THAT WITHIN THAT
FIRST YEAR THEY'RE DOING A TON
OF ON THE JOB TRAINING BECAUSE
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS THEY
NEEDED TO SEE IT IN PRACTICE.
THEY NEEDED TO BE HANDS ON THEY
NEEDED TO TOUCH THE PATIENT THEY
NEED TO DISPEL PATIENTS SEE THE
PATIENT WATCH THE BLANKS BE ABLE
TO USE. ALL OF THEIR ASSESSMENT
ABILITIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. IRWIN MAYBE I COULD
JUST- ASK CLARIFY QUESTION
BEFORE I GO TO. THE DOCTOR PAN
EXCELLENT QUESTIONS- MA'AM YOU
USE THE NUMBER- OR THE PHRASE
MINIMUM DIRECT PATIENT CARE WHAT
IS THE NUMBER THAT'S ATTACHED TO
THAT. THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A NEW
ACTIVITY WE DID IT RELYING ON
THEM THIS LAST NOVEMBER AND
THEY'RE PLANNING ON HAVING THEIR
FIRST MEETING THIS APRIL TO
REALLY LOOK AT THAT DATA. BUT
OREGON AT WASHINGTON DC THEY'RE
GIVING US A RANGE FROM AND
C-SPAN THEY SAID ANYWHERE FROM
FIVE HUNDRED AND ONE TO SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY WE LOOKED AT
HAWAII'S DATA HAWAII STATUS AS
ONE THOUSAND- HOWEVER WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE SIMULATION REPORT
THAT NCS. PUT OUT BASS SAID
MINIMUM DIRECT PATIENT CARE OF
SIX HUNDRED. AND SO WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
ST BERNARD'S STATUS. A
SIMULATION STUDY THAT THEY'D
STARTED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN REACT
AGAIN IN TWENTY NINETEEN THEY'RE
RECOMMENDING SIX HUNDRED HOURS
AS B. DIRECT PATIENT CARE THAT
IS AFFECTED YOU 550% UP. SO WE
CAN LOOK ANYWHERE BETWEEN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED INDIAN
ALIGNMENT WITH ALL THE OTHER
WORDS VERSES THAT ARE GOING IN
THIS DIRECTION. AND WHAT DOES
WHAT DOES THAT REPRESENT IN
TERMS OF THE TYPE. OF ISSUE OR
TWO ABOUT HOURS RIGHT. YEAH WE
ARE TALK ABOUT OURS AND I HE IS
AN EXAM. CURRENT CURRENTLY WHEN
WE DO 75% IF IT'S AN EIGHTEEN
UNIT THE MASTER PORTAL CLINICALS
AND IT LASTS FOR EIGHTY SIXTEEN
WEEKS BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S THE
BACK CALCULATION THAT'S IN OUR
REGULATIONS AND I'M TELLING YOU
IT'S A PROBLEM- BASED ON THE
WEEKS OF THE SEMESTER SO IF YOU
HAVE AN- EIGHTEEN WEEK SEMESTER.
YOU HAVE MORE HOURS AND SIXTEEN
WEEK SEMESTER YOU HAVE LESS
HOURS AND SO BASED ON AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR NEXT SEMESTER
CALCULATION BACK IS SIXTEEN
WEEKS WHICH IS THE TYPICAL BILL
THAT. YOU'RE LOOKING AT SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR HOURS AND
THAT'S WITH THE SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. WE THEN IT GOES LOWER
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FIRST
NURSING COURSE THAT IS TEACHING
BASIC SKILLS WE ALLOW 1100% TO
BE DONE IN A SIMULATION LAB. SO
WE'RE RIGHT THERE- AND I THINK
THAT WE CAN MOVE THAT. THAT
EASILY SAID BETWEEN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIVE HUNDRED BASED
ON THE DATA AND I EXPECT THAT I
CAN EITHER PULL THAT FOR YOU
GUYS IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
GETTING THAT INTO THE SUNSET
REPORT WHICH I WOULD SUPPORT
GREATLY BECAUSE THAT WOULD.
ALLOW US TO IMPLEMENT
IMMEDIATELY BURST IS GOING TO
READ TO YOUR PROCESS TO UPDATE
OUR REGULATIONS WHICH WE WOULD
GET TO BUT IT WOULD HAVE A
DELAYED EFFECT SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I CAN HOLD A-
EVIDENCE FOR AND GIVE THAT TO
YOU AND PROVIDE THAT TO YOU I'D
BE HAPPY TO DO THAT. WELL I'M
JUST WHEN YOU SAY SCHOOLS ARE
FREE TO DO AS MUCH CLINICAL.
SIMULATION AS THEY- C. FIT TO DO
. CAN HANDLE OR TO DO I'M JUST
TRY TO FIGURE OUT. THE VAL OF
THAT DEPENDS ON. WHAT PERCENTAGE
MINIMUM DIRECT PATIENT CARE IS
OF THE TOTAL HOURS IN THE
PROGRAM SO. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED HOURS WHAT
PERCENTAGE. DOES THAT REPRESENT
OF THE TOTAL TEACHING HOURS IN
THE NURSING PROGRAM. IS THAT A
FAIR QUESTION IF. IS ALL RIGHT
WELL LET ME LET ME JUST SO IS IT
SIX HUNDRED HOURS OUT OF A
THOUSAND WHICH ALLOWS THE
TRAINING PROGRAM TO. UTILIZE
CLINICAL SIMULATION FOR FOUR
HUNDRED HOURS IS IT SIX HUNDRED
HOURS YEAH. SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLAR
PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS FOR ONE
HUNDRED HOURS OF CLINICAL
SIMULATION I WAS TRYING TO GET A
FEEL FOR WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE AND- YOU REMEMBER
YOUR DATE DEALING WITH THE
GERIATRIC SET WHEN YOU DEAL WITH
ME SO. WELL THAT'S GREAT BECAUSE
I'M TRAINED IN GERIATRICS AS
WELL SO WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO
THIS. SO CENTER OUT THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION WHAT THE NCS AND
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL STATE
BOARDS OF NURSING STUDY SHOWS IS
SIX HUNDRED IS THAT DIRECT
PATIENT CARE ANYTHING TO FIFTY
PERCENT. AND STILL BE EVIDENCE
SAYS THE MINIMUM STANDARD WOULD
BE THREE HUNDRED HOURS AND THEN
PROGRAMS CAN DO IT. JUST NOT
THREE HUNDRED ON TOP OF THAT.
AND THAT WOULD BE ADEQUATELY
PREPARED NURSING STUDENT FOUR B.
THE FIELD. SO FOR THAT I SHOW
THAT 50% CAN BE MAYBE CLINICAL
SIMULATION IF YOU'RE ABLE TO DO
IT. IT COULD BE SIMULATION BUT
REMEMBER OUR REGULATIONS RIGHT
NOW ONLY SPEAK TO THE DIRECT
PATIENT CARE IT SAYS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE FIRST COURSE
THAT CAN BE A HUNDRED PERCENT.
THE REMAINING COURSES MUST HAVE
MISSED MUCH IN DIRECT PATIENT
CARE THAT ALLOWS THE SCHOOL TO
DO OBSERVATION. CASE STUDIES-
VOLUNTEER WORK AND ADD TO IT
INCLUDING SIMULATION IF THEY
HAVE THE MEANS TO DO THAT. TO
REALLY HAVE THOSE STUDENTS BE
ABLE TO MEET. EIGHT CLINICAL
OUTCOMES SO PULLING AWAY FROM A
PERCENTAGE IS REALLY THE- THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO IN THE WAY THAT
OUR BOARD VOTED. TO GO AT THE
END OF NOVEMBER THIS LAST YEAR
IS TO ESTABLISH THAT DIRECT
PATIENT CARE AND STAY SILENT
LIKE WE ALWAYS HAVE. ON HOW THEY
MEET THE REST OF THE CLINICAL
OBJECTIVES WITH THE ABILITY THAT
THEY HAVE THAT IS SCHOOL
SPECIFIC. AND I KNOW THIS IS NOT
WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE HEARD FOR THE
PAST TEN YEARS YOU'VE HEARD THE
FIGHT 450% FIFTY PERCENT. BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ANY RESEARCH
DATA RESEARCH DRIVEN DATA. YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A BASELINE BEFORE
YOU CAN GO 250% YET THE BASELINE
. BUT OUR PERCENTAGE THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING IS NEVER ESTABLISH A
BASELINE. SO WE NEED TO U. S.
STOCK THAT BASELINE AND THEN OUR
SCHOOL CAN THEIR- IS RUN. IT
FIFTY SO PRE LIFE NURSING FROM
THAT WE A- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
. AND INDEED APPROVED CURRICULA
. AND IT'S SPECIFIC TO THE
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT THE SERVER AND
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE.
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO OFFER THIS
IS THEIR SCHOOL WELL YOU KNOW.
WE'LL GET TO THAT I'M SURE
LATER. LET ME- I'LL LEAVE THE
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ON THE-
SIMULATION TO MY COLLEAGUE HERE
ON THE FLOOR WHO IS CERTAINLY
MORE MORE EXPERIENCED IN THE
CLINICAL SIDE THAN I AM LET ME
MOVE QUICKLY TO ONE CLARIFYING.
QUESTION ON THE SUBJECT OF
CONCURRENCY THEORY VERSUS
CLINICAL. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
ADVANTAGES OF HAVING CONCURRENT
I THINK I DO THEORY AND CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE THE QUESTION IS
SHOULD THE SHOULD THE PROGRAM SO
TO SPEAK ALLOW FOR FLEXIBILITY
AT THE SCHOOL LEVEL TO DEAL WITH
INDIVIDUAL. SITUATIONS AND I WAS
TAKEN IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER-
WITH THE COMMENT. FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
WHICH IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S
STILL MY UNDERSTANDING LARGEST.
THAT CASE HIGHER EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM IN THE US. AND THE
COMMENT POINTED OUT. WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
NOTED THAT IN THE CASE OF
PHYSICIANS AND PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS AND- PHYSICIANS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS WHICH
PROGRAM DO NOT NECESSARILY
REQUIRED EVERY INSTANCE
CONCURRENCY. AND THE QUOTE IN
THE BACKGROUND REPORT IS
FLEXIBILITY IN THE REQUIREMENT
COULD ALLOW PROGRAMS TO MAXIMIZE
THE USE OF AVAILABLE PLACEMENTS
BY FRONT LOADING THEORY CONTENT
AND IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING WITH
CORRESPONDING CLINICAL.
PRACTICUM AND MY QUESTION IS
SHOULDN'T WE- CONTINUE TO EXPAND
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS AREA GIVEN
THE- EVER INCREASING NEED FOR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT OUR- EXPANSION
OF CLINICAL FACILITIES AND
TRAINING SLOTS IS PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO KEEP UP. WHETHER
BECAUSE OF ECONOMICS- BECAUSE
FRANKLY OF. THE CHANGING WAY WE
DELIVER HEALTHCARE SERVICES IN
THIS COUNTRY. I'M TRYING TO COME
OFF MUTE HERE MYSELF THANK YOU-
SO A COUPLE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE KIND OF HAVE TO LOOK AT
IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS WORK ONE
D. AS WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANTS YOU LOOK
AT THE MEDICAL PROGRAMS THEY
HAVE A ONE YEAR INTERNSHIP AND
EXPRESSED. EXTERNSHIP INTERNSHIP
SORRY AND A RESIDENCY AFTER
THEIR COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAM
WHERE THEY ARE AT THE FACILITY
THAT THEY'RE DOING TRAINING. AND
THERE WE HAVE A MENTOR THERE ARE
SIGNS YOU AT PHYSICIAN NETWORKS
WITH THEM THE ENTIRE TIME AS- A
ONE YEAR FIRST YEAR RESIDENCY IS
SECOND YEAR RESIDENCY THEY DO
THIS AS AFTER THEY'VE COMPLETED
THE CORE PART OF THEIR
CURRICULUM. AND THAT'S NOT THE
WAY THAT NURSING EDUCATION IS
SET UP WE DON'T HAVE THAT WHEN
NURSES GRADUATE THEY GO INTO A
TRANSITION PROGRAM LIKE I SAID
WAS ABOUT SIX WEEKS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE IMPACT THAT'S ON OUR
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES RIGHT NOW.
THEY WHEN COLEMAN HIT AND THEY
LOST THEIR EDUCATORS THE BOULDER
EDUCATORS IN THE STAFF THOSE
EDUCATORS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR- NEW GRADUATE
PROGRAMS. THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
THERE TO SERVE THEM ANYMORE IT'S
SO YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS AN INNATE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE MEDICAL EDUCATION
AND THE NURSING EDUCATION BUT
THEY'RE NOT SET UP TO BE
SIMILAR. NOW WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE FLEXIBILITY TO THE NURSING
PROGRAMS IF WE DROP BACK TO A
DIRECT PATIENT CARE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT WHAT HAPPENS IS IT
MAKES IT LESS HOURS THAT HAVE TO
BE COMPLETE COMPLETED ON A
SEMESTER BASIS. SO BAD EVEN
AFFECTS THAT SCHEDULING FIASCO
BECAUSE THEY WON'T HAVE AN
EXCESSIVE NUMBER OF HOURS TO DO
ON A SEMESTER SEMESTER BASIS
WHICH THEN DOESN'T REQUIRED TO
HAVE THAT ABILITY TO PULL THEM
INTO NEXT SEMESTER BECAUSE. IN
FACT WE DECREASED THAT. WOULD
THEN ACTS IF. AT ADDRESS. THE
CLINICAL IMPACT ATTACKING THAT
AREA SO IF WE- THREE. OF A
CLINICAL. THAT'S A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR HOURS BAG IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR A SIXTEEN WEEK
SEMESTER. IN ORDER FOR THAT
STUDENT TO DO IT AND THAT'S WHAT
THEIR CURRENT REGULATIONS RIGHT
BUT SEE WE HAVE A SCHOOL THAT
SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN THREE
THREE UNITS IS GOOD BUT I THINK
I SHOULD DO FOUR AND A HALF
UNITS. WELL WHEN THEY DECIDE
THAT APPARENTLY AND DO THAT ON
THEIR OWN THEY NOW ARE REQUIRING
THEIR STUDENTS WITH OUR B. R.
AND DIRECTION THE COMPLETE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN HOURS IN A
CLINICAL SETTING WHICH AND
THAT'S SEVENTY TWO MORE HOURS IN
THE BORDERS REQUIRING. SO IF WE
SET A MINIMUM DIRECT PATIENT
CARE THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE
MINIMUM DIRECT PATIENT CARE
HOURS TO HAVE TO HAVE THAT
CONCURRENCY FLEXIBILITY TO GO
INTO THE NEXT SEMESTER ND
THEY'RE NOT INTO IT IT'S BEEN
STACKING THE DECK AGAINST THEM
BECAUSE IF YOU CARRY OVER
SEVENTY TWO HOURS FROM THE NEXT
FROM THE PREVIOUS SEMESTER OF
DIRECT PATIENT CARE HOURS. THAT
NEEDED TO BE COMPLETED IN THE
NEXT SEMESTER ANYWAY ADD THAT ON
TOP OF THEIR. HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR HOURS. WELL NOW YOU HAVE TO
ENTER SIXTEEN HAVE BEEN AND
THAT'S- WHAT. YOU'RE NOT EVEN
GONNA BE ABLE TO DO THAT SO THE
NEXT SEMESTER GONNA DUMP IN
PROBABLY EIGHTY SIX MORE HOURS
INTO THAT SEMESTER AND COMPILE
THAT ON TO THE NEXT ONE. SO I
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEED I TRULY DO
I WAS A PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
YEARS I HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
SCHEDULING MY STUDENTS I WAS
EVEN THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT
COORDINATOR CAUGHT MY SCHOOL
BEFORE IT BECAME THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR. CLINICALS ARE HARD AND
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO LOOK AT
SOLVING THIS A DIFFERENT ROUTE
AND THAT IS WHERE WE STAB US IN
MINIMUM. DIRECT PATIENT CARE
REQUIREMENTS WE ALREADY HAVE
THAT IN OUR REGULATIONS RIGHT
NOW IN SIXTEEN C. C. R. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. THAT IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE NATIONAL
STANDARDS FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS THAT SAY YOU HAVE
TO COMPLETE. FIVE HUNDRED HOURS
OF SUPERVISED DIRECT PATIENT
CARE AND THEN OUR NURSE
PRACTITIONER PROGRAMS ARE ABLE
TO DO STANDARDIZED PATIENTS OR
ABOVE. WHAT AND SIMULATIONS OVER
TO BOB WHAT OUR MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT IS TO PREPARE THEIR
STUDENTS THIS PUTS US INTO A
LINE MET WITH THOSE NATIONAL
STANDARDS BEING ABLE TO DO THAT
SIMILARLY TO WHAT WE ALREADY DO
FOR AND KEEP PROGRAMS. SO IT
TRULY ADDRESSES ALL OF THOSE
AREAS THAT YOU HAVE BROUGHT UP
AS A CONCERN BECAUSE THOSE ARE
CONCERNS AS WELL. WELL LISTEN
THE CHANGES THAT THE BOARD IS
PUT IN PLACE MAY VERY WELL DEAL
WITH THIS I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS. YOU KNOW MY CONCERN IS THE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE TO DROP OUT
OF NURSING PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF
THE CONCURRENCY REQUIREMENT. FOR
ONE REASON OR ANOTHER SO. THE
QUESTION IS DOES THE BOARD
MONITOR THE NUMBER OF DRUG
PROGRAM DROPOUTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CONCURRENCY. REQUIREMENTS
WHICH I HOPE THE ANSWER IS YES.
AND IF IT NOT I HOPE YOU WILL BE
BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO SEE HELLO
AND SEE THE EFFECT OF THE
CHANGES THAT YOU PUT IN PLACE.
ON THE ISSUES THAT THE SCHOOLS
SEEM TO BE COMPLAINING ABOUT
THOSE THAT COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
CONCURRENCY REQUIREMENTS.
APPARENTLY INCLUDING. THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY SO.
SOMEBODY SEES A PROBLEM I'M
HOPING THAT YOUR CHANGES HAVE
ADDRESSED IT BUT IF NOT I'D LIKE
SOME STATISTICS SO WE KNOW. THE
SCOPE OF THE REMAINING PRO PRO-
PROBLEM. THE NEXT TIME WE GATHER
AT THE RIVER TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. DELAY
LOVE THAT IDEA DO YOU KEEP
STATISTICS ON THE NUMBER OF
PROGRAMMATIC DROPOUTS THAT OCCUR
BECAUSE OF THE- CONCERT
CONCURRENCY REQUIREMENTS AT THE
SCHOOL LEVEL. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
REGULATORY AUTHORITY OVER
ATTRITION. RATES AT ALL- WITH
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL STATE
BOARDS OF NURSING AID ASK US TO
MONITOR ATTRITION WE DO AND IT
IS SHARED ON OUR BOARD'S WEBSITE
WHAT THAT IS. THE DIFFERENCE
THAT WE DO THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN
TITLE FOR FUNDING WHICH IS THE
NATIONAL LEVELS THEY DO TIME AND
A HALF FOR COMPLETION SO GIVE IT
TO YOUR PROGRAM. THEIR TUITION
NUMBERS FOR FUNDING IS BASED ON
A TIME AND A HALF SO THEY ALLOW
FOR THREE YEARS TO COMPLETE IT.
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
GOES ABOVE THAT AND WHAT WE DO
IS WE TRACK ON TIME COMPLETION
SO IF YOU HAVE A TWO YEAR
PROGRAM. WE WANT TO NOTE THAT
STUDENT ABYAN SEE SIGNED UP HERE
THEY COMPLETED TWO YEARS LATER
100% ON TIME WHICH IS WHAT THAT
ATTRITION NUMBER YES. WE
COLLECTED THAT DATA. IT IS ON
OUR- IN ORDER TO GET DATA THAT
SAYS WHY. DOES SCHOOLS WOULD
HAVE TO DO AN EXIT INTERVIEW
WITH EACH ONE OF THOSE STUDENTS.
TO FIND OUT WHY THE TRULY
DROPPED OUT WHEN. I CAN'T
POSSIBLY BE THE CASE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE. CLINICAL PLACEMENT
MONITORS IN NURSING SCHOOLS AND
BECAUSE OF THE CONCURRENCY
REQUIREMENTS. THOSE PLACEMENT
DIRECTORS WOULD KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT
AVAILABLE. AND WHETHER THE
STUDENT CAN. PARTICIPATE IN A
CLINICAL SLOT. CONCURRENT WITH
THE PARTICULAR PROGRAM AND IF
THE STUDENT CAN'T THEN THE
STUDENT. CAN'T COMPLETE THAT
COURSE SO THERE MUST BE DATA.
SOMEWHERE HE ASKED. CAN AND I
HEAR YOU ON THAT I YOU ON AND I
WOULD LOVE TO SAY ABSOLUTELY YES
. IF IT IS A SCHEDULING ISSUE IF
IT IS TRULY JUST BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO PROGRESS. BAD
DATA WAS ONLY AVAILABLE DURING
KOBE. WE'RE NOW NOT IN THE MIDST
OF KOBE HAT DATA WAS NOT
COLLECTED BEFORE BY THE PROGRAMS
IT WAS NOT REPORTED. WE DO HAVE
SOME DATA WITHIN OUR OUR- UCSF
CONTRACT REPORT AND IF THEY DO
SAY THAT THEY ARE DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING CLINICAL SPACES. THEY
ALSO HAVE THE SAME DATA THAT
SAYS EVEN WITH THE 25% THAT THEY
CAN USE IN SIMULATION. THEY'RE
NOT USING IT THEY'RE USING 15%
ARE USING 18% SO IT'S A MUCH
MORE COMPLEX ISSUE THAN JUST A
CUT AND DRY ANSWER. SO IF A
STUDENT IS NOT ABLE TO PROGRESS
SPECIFICALLY JUST FOR CLINICAL
REASONS THEN THAT IS DATA THAT
THE SCHOOL HOUSE TO TELLER AND
HE SEES. AND WHEN THEY COME INTO
ANY ISSUE LIKE THAT PRIOR TO
KOBE THEY REACHED OUT TO THE
NEC'S THE NEC'S MADE A PLAN WITH
THEM AND THEY GOT THEM TO
CONTINUE. WHAT TYPICALLY WE SEE
IS THAT IT'S A PERSONAL ISSUE
IT'S- MONETARY HARDSHIP- IT'S-
PREGNANCY YOU'RE A MEDICAL LEAVE
OF ABSENCE- THERE SOME OTHER
REASON THAT REQUIRES STUDENTS
NOT TO CONTINUE. AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THAT THEY COULDN'T
GET SCHEDULE OUR DIRECTORS ARE
AMAZINGLY AND THAT. AND THEY
WILL FIND PLACEMENTS THEY CALL
UP THEIR FRIENDS THEY CALL US WE
START LOOKING FOR THEM REACHING
OUT TO AREA HOSPITALS AREA
CLINICS AND SAYING HEY. CAN YOU
GET THE STUDENT AND THEY HAVE
TWELVE HOURS LEFT TO DO. BUT
THAT AGAIN IS IMPORTANT TO US
AND THAT'S WHY WE STARTED
LOOKING AT THESE AND I BROUGHT
IT FORWARD TO OUR BOARD IN
NOVEMBER. WAS DAMAGED IN MINIMUM
PRACTICE YOU CARE BECAUSE IT
DECREASES THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT THAT STUDENT HAS TO BE IN A
CLINICAL OVER AND ABOVE. WHAT WE
REQUIRE WHEN WE HAVE A OVER IN
THAT SAYS. I WANT TO GO ABOVE TO
BE IS FOR. A REQUIRED FOUR. IN
A- CLINICAL SETTING AND WE WERE
ONLY REQUIRED EIGHTEEN WHEN YOU
HAVE EIGHTEEN UNITS WHICH IS OUR
MINIMUM STANDARD TODAY AT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR HOURS.
WHEN THE SCHOOL SAYS I THINK
TWENTY FOUR UNITS IS BETTER
THAT'S ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO HOURS SO IF WE DO A
MINIMUM DIRECT PATIENT CARE THEY
CAN KEEP THE ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO HOURS THAT
THEY THINK IS BETTER. BUT THAT
MEANS ONLY FIVE HUNDRED AND THAT
IF THEY HAVE TWENTY FOUR UNITS
IS IN DIRECT PATIENT CARE OR
FIVE HUNDRED THAT'D BE IT
EIGHTEEN UNITS IS IN DIRECT
PATIENT CARE. AND THAT ALLOWS
FOR ALL OF THOSE ADDITIONAL
UNITS THE INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL SAYS
I THINK IS BETTER. CAN BE DONE
IN A CERTAIN WAY. AND BACKED.
YOU RAISE. ALMOST A HUNDRED
PERCENT. AND CONCURRENCY ISSUE
THAT CLINICAL IMPACTION ISSUE.
AND TRULY. PUTS LESS OF A BURDEN
ON THE COMMUNITY IN THE AREA
SCHOOLS AROUND THE WORLD SO IT'S
QUITE POSSIBLE THAT THE CHANGES
YOU PUT IN PLACE OF. ELIMINATED
THE ISSUE OR PERHAPS I JUST
MISUNDERSTOOD WHAT PEOPLE WERE
TALKING TO US ABOUT- DURING LAST
YEAR'S OF SUNSET HEARING BUT IN
ANY EVENT IF IT NO LONGER
REMAINS A PROBLEM THEN. IT NO
LONGER REMAINS A PROBLEM AND-
YOU CAN. TALK TO US ABOUT YOUR
NEW PROGRAM THE NEXT TIME AS I
SAID WE GATHER AT THE RIVER TO
HAVE ONE OF THESE. A SUNSET
CONVERSATIONS- I DIDN'T MEAN TO
DOMINATE THAT SERIES OF
QUESTIONS DR PANDA APOLOGIZE TO
YOU PLEASE PROCEED. WELL THE
THANK YOU THIS THAT. THAT'S A
FASCINATING CONVERSATION I'VE AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS A RESIDENCY
PROGRAM DIRECTOR. AND ACTUALLY
SERVED ON THE NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION BOARD- AND. IN
MEDICAL EDUCATION SO. THE THESE
ARE ISSUES THERE IS WITH X. WELL
MAYBE I'LL JUST- FOLLOW UP ON
SOME OF THAT AND THEN I HAD SOME
OTHER QUESTIONS ACTUALLY WANT TO
ASK AS WELL- SO. BECAUSE THE B.
R. AND DOES HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER-
ESSENTIALLY NURSING EDUCATION
PROGRAMS INCLUDING NURSING
TRAINING WITH- CAN CAN YOU SPEAK
TO ME DO YOU. WELL SO DO YOU
REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO ACTUALLY
SHOOT SURE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE ADEQUATE CLINICAL TRAINING
SLOT THE NEEDS SO I KNOW MEDICAL
EDUCATION YOU CAN'T GET A CREDIT
IS UNLESS YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THE
CLINICAL SLOTS LINED UP IN
ADVANCE YOU CAN'T HAVE STUDENTS
NOT HAVE CLINICAL SLOTS THAT YOU
DON'T GO HUNTING AROUND FOR THEM
AFTER THEY SIGN UP YOU HAVE TO
ALREADY HAVE THE GRIEVANCE IN
PLACE THE EMMA USE AND SO FORTH.
IS THAT DIFFERENT NURSING I MEAN
SO WE CAN START A NURSING SCHOOL
AND THEN DIED NOT PEOPLE BUT I
GUESS- NOT BE ASSURED THEY HAVE
THE CLINICAL SLOTS THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION THE SCHOOL HAS A RATE
RANGE FOR THAT IN ADVANCE. SO
ALL OF US AN EXAMPLE WHAT
HAPPENED WITH KOBE. WE HAVE AS
THE BEER AND WE HAVEN'T ALREADY
OVER ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OF YOUR- OVER OUR
HEALTH. FACILITIES SO THEY WILL
HAVE CONTRACTS IN PLACE MOST OF
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE SEVERAL
CONTRACTS IN PLACE. FOR MALL
RIGHT. AND THEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS AND THEY'RE REMOVED FROM
THAT CLINICAL SITE JUST LIKE
THEY HAPPEN WITH COLEMAN OKAY
SOMETHING HAPPENED. THEY WERE
REMOVED FROM THAT SITE. AND SO
IF THE JOINT COMMISSION COMES
THROUGH THEY'LL CALL UP THE
SCHOOL EIGHT I CAN'T HAVE
STUDENTS THIS WEEK. AND OR
THEY'LL SAY- WERE REMODELING.
THAT MAKE LABOR AND DELIVERY
UNIT WE CAN'T HAVE STUDENTS IN
PLACE WILL HAVE AN EIGHT MONTH
PROJECT. AND WE'LL HAVE YOU GUYS
BACK NEXT YEAR AFTER EIGHT
MONTHS AND SO THERE WILL BE A
SEMESTER. THAT THERE THAT
CLINICAL FACILITY THAT THEY USED
TO USE IS NOW NOT THERE OKAY BUT
STILL. WE DO- ADEQUATELY
CLINICAL RESEARCH CLINICAL
ADEQUATE CLINICAL FACILITIES.
FOR EACH OF OUR PROGRAMS. BUT WE
CAN'T GUARANTEE THEY'RE GOING TO
BE THERE OKAY. TIRED TIME. EIGHT
SECONDS OKAY WELL I DON'T IT IN
THE LOCKER AND ASK ABOUT THIS
BUT- IT I THINK IT'S HELPFUL TO
KNOW. NO WE YOU KNOW WE DON'T
SEE ANY IT'S ALSO IT'S LIKE.
OBVIOUSLY OBVIOUSLY- WELL WE
EXPECT THE WELL THOSE OF US IN
INTO MEDICINE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
KNEW THAT PANDEMICS COMING WE
CAN SAY EXACTLY WHEN SO
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW AND COVERED
HEAD IT WAS QUOTE UNQUOTE
UNEXPECTED IN A WAY OF LIKE WE'D
INSTANTLY SCHEDULE THAT- I
THINK. SOMEONE REMODELING THEIR
L. AND D. DELIVERY THEY SHOULD
KNOW IN ADVANCE AND SO THAT
SHOULD HOPEFULLY BE BUILT INTO A
CONTRACT THAT THEY'RE CERTAIN
NOTIFICATIONS SO FORTH SO THAT
SCHOOL CAN PLAN. AND FOR SCHOOL
AND AGAIN IN IN IN MEDICINE TOO
RIGHT WE HAVE MEDICAL SCHOOLS
AND RESIDENCY PROGRAMS THERE'S A
RESPONSIBLE INSTITUTION AND THEY
HAVE CONTRACTS AND THE USE WITH
OTHER ONES. RIGHT THAT SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THIS CLINICAL
POSITIONS AVAILABLE SO THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TRAINEES GOING AROUND
TRYING TO HUNT AROUND FOR THAT.
REALIZING THAT BECAUSE OF IT YOU
DON'T CHANGE A LOT OF THINGS- I
ATE SO. BACK I DO THINK THAT-
AND I REALIZE THAT MAYBE YOU
CAN'T TRACK DIRECTLY BUT YOU DO
HAVE REGULATORY AUTHORITY ARE
YOU HAVE SOME OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY OVER THE INSTITUTIONS
I THINK IS- THE CHAIR HAD SAID-
MAYBE THOSE INSTITUTIONS SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDING- SOME.
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PIPELINE
THROUGH THE SCHOOLS HOW YOU
START HOW MAY COMING OUT AND THE
REASONS PEOPLE DROP OUT IN THE
PROCESS. RIGHT SO IS IT BECAUSE-
THEY COULDN'T FIND A CLINICAL
SLOT VERSES THEY HAD MANY OF THE
OTHER ISSUES YOU HAVE OUTLINED
SO HOPEFULLY THAT IS DATA THE
BOARD CAN GET THROUGH THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE. IN SOME WAYS- DIRECT
AUTHORITY OVER IN TERMS OF THEIR
APPROVAL SO. HOPEFULLY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN TRACK- I
REALIZE THAT THE DATA PERHAPS
WASN'T BEING CHECKED BEFORE
CODED BUT- PERHAPS THAT'S
SOMETHING THE FORD. AND I I'LL I
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT. CLINICAL
SITES- CHALLENGER TRAGICAL SITES
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S ISOLATED
NURSING PROFESSION ALONE I KNOW
IT'S A ISSUE IN THE MEDICINE
SIDE UP FOR MEDICAL STUDENTS.
RESIDENTS. ITSELF FOR OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS AS SO
THE THIS IS A THERE A LARGE
TOWN. THAT WE NEED TO THINK. IN
TERMS OF THE- OBLIGATION AND-
AND WHAT WE EXPECT OF OUR
HEALTHCARE INSTITUTIONS PROVIDE
CLINICAL TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR TRAINEES- AS WELL SELVES-
JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT- AND ALSO
PREVIEWED THE DISCUSSION ABOUT-
SIMULATION I WILL I WILL JUST
MAKE ME WANT CALM ABOUT
SIMULATION. WE HAVE SOME REALLY
AMAZING SIMULATIONS NOW. BUT
WELL YES IT CAN TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT IT'S NOT LIKE FLYING A
PLANE AND ACTUALLY HAVING ACTUAL
INTERACTIONS WITH PATIENTS EVEN
WITH VERY LITTLE REALISTIC
SIMULATIONS. YOU DO NEED TO HAVE
DIRECT PATIENT INTERACTION- IT
DUFFY SUBSTITUTES FOR THAT SO
I'M NOT OPPOSED TO SIMULATION
HAVING MORE SIMULATION BUT THERE
ARE LIMITS TO HOW FAR
STIMULATION CAN GO. ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO YOU KNOW THAT
PERSONAL INTERACTION OF SOCIAL
INTERACTION. RIGHT YOU CAN LEARN
THE PHYSIOLOGY ALL THAT OTHER
STUFF ON A ON A SIMULATOR BUT
IT'S- IT. SIMULATOR
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T TELL YOU A
REAL LIFE STORY ABOUT SOMEONE'S
LIFE AND SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
AFFECTED THEM THAT. TAKING CARE
OF AN ACTUAL PATIENTS ACCOUNT SO
I'M JUST GONNA PUT THAT OUT
THERE- I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
THAT'S- HUGE YOU. KNOW AS PART
OF YOUR ASSESSMENT AND THAT'S
KIND OF A DISGUSTING TOPIC. BUT
IT JUST GOES ON HANDS ON IT
GETTING THAT SENSE WHEN YOU WALK
IN THE ROOM HE WATCHED. THEM
GUARD YOU KNOW ALL OF THAT. YOU
GET THAT MESSAGE. OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO- SO I'M GONNA GET TO SOME
QUESTIONS. OTHER QUESTIONS- SO
FIRST OF ALL- IN. OUR IN OUR
BACKGROUND PAPER- DON'T. AND
AGAIN YOUR- ABOUT PROGRESS THE-
B. R. AND HAS MADE- I DID WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON A COUPLE OF
ISSUES THAT ARE RELATED TO
AUDITS SO- ISSUE NUMBER SIX
THERE'S A WHISTLE BLOWER ON IT.
IT WAS NOT IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER RECOMMENDATION THREE I WAS
KIND OF STILL FLOATING OUT THERE
AND THINK THE BEER AND CLAIMS
THE FINISH THEY FULLY
IMPLEMENTED THERE'S SOME BACK
AND FORTH WITH THE- IDEA OF THE-
AUDITOR WHETHER IT ACTUALLY IT'S
BEEN FULLY IMPLEMENTED- CAN YOU
JUST STATE. WHAT IS WHAT'S THE
CURRENT SITUATION WITH
IMPLEMENTATION OF RECOMMENDATION
THREE RELATED TO THE WHISTLE
BLOWER ON IT OF I THINK TWENTY
SIXTEEN. SO THAT'S THAT TWO
SEPARATE- THINGS THERE SO I
EXPLAINED THAT. ON THE WHISTLE
BLOWER ON IT THERE WAS THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS THOSE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED AND IT IS REFLECTED
ON THE CSA WEBSITE.
RECOMMENDATION THREE YEP MANSION
BACK. TO THE AUDIT THAT OCCURRED
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND-
SPECIFICALLY TALKING ABOUT
NUMBER SEVEN. B. WILL NOT. SHOW
THAT IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED
BECAUSE OF THE FRAUD THAT WAS
COMPLETED. SO WE'RE
UNDERSTANDING THAT EVEN THOUGH
WE FULLY IMPLEMENTED ALL THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
WHISTLEBLOWER AUDIT. THAT CSA
WILL NOT UPDATE NUMBER SEVEN TO
SHOW THAT THAT WAS IMPLEMENTED
UNTIL THEY DO AN ADDITIONAL. ON
IT OKAY AND THERE'S ON. DO YOU
KNOW THAT ON GO RIGHT NOW OR
WHAT WHAT'S OF THE AND I GUESS
WE HAVE TO HAVE TO BUT YES. YEAH
WE'VE BEEN KIND. WHEN AUDITOR
WILL BECOME INTO DO WHATEVER.
AUDIT OKAY THEN ALL OURSELVES
WITH DCA. AND DCA FOUNDER THAT
WE ARE IN COMPLIANCE FOR WE'RE
WAITING FOR THE FOLLOW UP OKAY.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
AUDITORS OKAY THANK YOU YES AND
THEN THE OTHER ONE. WE HAVE
ISSUE TWENTY ONE WAS IT. AGAIN
REALLY TO AUDITOR G. LACK ON
RECOMMENDATION I THINK. ISSUE
NUMBER. TWENTY TWO AS WELL- AND-
SO THIS IS ABOUT THE- OVERSIGHT
THE FEW LICENSURE- PROGRAMS AND-
FEELING. SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
AGAIN THE- AND IT'S ACTUALLY AN
ISSUE TWENTY THREE ACTUALLY IF
YOU'RE TWENTY THREE DUPLICATION
PROGRAM REVIEW AS WELL AND- SO
THEY TALKED ABOUT- SO THE
pON IT. IN THE INITIAL
PRESENTATION- BUT YET AGAIN
TRYING TO REDUCE THE OVERHEAD-
AND ON ON THE PROGRAMS AND YOU
KNOW THEY DID GOING TO THE- THE-
THEY'LL NATIONAL INTERNATIONAL
NURSING CREDITORS AND THEN THE
OTHER B. R. N. AND- SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THE- MORE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO
REDUCE THE DUPLICATION SO WE CAN
AGAIN REDUCE THE BURDEN ON OUR
PROGRAMS. AND THEN ALSO THE
OTHER ONE IS ISSUE TWENTY FOUR
WHICH ISN'T RELATED TO THE AUDIT
BUT- THERE'S ALSO MADE MENTION
THAT DVR AND HAS VERY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS REQUIREMENTS ARE
FACULTY THAT HAVE ALSO MADE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR SOME THE
PROGRAMS- IN TERMS OF- THAT THE
YOU KNOW BUILDING A FACULTY
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO SPECIFIC AND-
WHETHER THERE'S- SOME THOUGHT
ABOUT- IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW HOW
HOW SPECIFIC DO WE NEED TO BE IN
TERMS OF THE FACULTY
REQUIREMENTS- SO THAT SCHOOLS
CAN GET TO YOU KNOW BE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE FULL FACT AGAIN
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZING WE HAVE TO
MAINTAIN A CERTAIN LEVEL QUALITY
AND EXPERTISE IN THE FACT THAT.
SO CAN YOU JUST TOUCH ON THE
OVERLAP THE JOY- PRODIGY LIKE
AUDIT AND- REDUCING DUPLICATE
SERVICES AND THEN ALSO THE
BURDEN AT THE NATIONALLY ON THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR FACULTY RECORD. THE QUALIFICATIONS. I GOT THAT
YES I WILL DO THAT FOR YOU SO.
THE FIRST ONE IS. THE A CREDIT.
FOR GROUP ALL. SO SOMETHING
YOU'RE FAMILIAR. TO PANIC SHORT
IS THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- PROVES THAT. THAT
FACILITIES AND THEN THE JOINT
COMMISSION WILL COME IN TO DO AN
ACCREDITATION ARE NOT. COMING TO
DO A CREDIT CHECK THAT'S
IDENTICAL IT'S REALLY WHAT WE
DO. SO THE BOARD WILL COME IN
AND DO AN APPROVAL AND THEN A
STANDARD SEE SEE ANY RETURN
NATIONAL ACCREDITING AGENCIES
WILL COME IN AND DO AN
ACCREDITATION VISIT ON TOP OF
THAT. IT'S GREAT FOR MARKETING
IT REALLY HELPS ATTRACT STUDENTS
AND IT HELPS ATTRACT FACULTY
WHICH IS FANTASTIC FOR THAT
SCHOOL. NOT REQUIREMENT THOUGH
TO EDUCATE. SO WE ACTUALLY HEARD
YOU GUYS LOUD AND CLEAR THE
SUNSET AND- LAST YEAR AND WE
STARTED- JOINT MEETINGS WITH THE
DEANS AND DIRECTORS TO TALK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN COME INTO
ALIGNMENT. AND DO THE STICK. I
MET WITH ACCREDITING AGENCIES
SEE SEE ANY ACE AND- I MET WITH
NCSP AND WE TALKED ABOUT HOW
OTHER BOARDS OF NURSING OR DO A
JOINT VISITS. AND SO WE DID OUR
VERY FIRST JOINT VISITS IN
SEPTEMBER IN SAN DIEGO CITY
COLLEGE AND IT WAS. IMPORTANT SO
IMPORTANT I WENT AHEAD AND
JOINED IN THE- DID THE BEST. I
WANTED TO SEE FIRST HAND WE HAVE
SENSE THEN- YOU CAN USE THAT AND
WE'VE DONE I BELIEVE FOR MORE
VISITS BETTER JOINTS WE HAVE A
WIND NOW ALL OF OUR CONTINUING
APPROVAL VISITS. WITH YOUR
CREDITORS WE WILL GO SIDE BY
SIDE ADDITIONALLY THEY GIVE A
REPORT TO THE CREDITING AGENCIES
WE- SAID WE WILL ACCEPT THAT
SAME REPORT. EXCEPT IN THE AREAS
THAT IT DOESN'T TOUCH OUR
REGULATIONS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE STILL
MEETING. AND THEY WILL DO AN
ADDENDUM TO ADD UP AND- OFFER
THAT TO US. AND SO GREAT
FEEDBACK SO FAR ON DOING THAT
TOGETHER AND I'M HAPPY TO SEE
THAT MOVIE FOR IT'S BEEN A LONG
TIME COMING AND TALKING WITH THE
PROGRAM DIRECTORS AND SHE SAID.
I CAN NOW RETIRE YOUR KNOWING
THAT MY LIFE'S WORK IS DONE WE
FINALLY GOT THIS HAPPENING AT
THE B. R. AT. THE NEXT ONE THAT
YOU WANT ME TO READ. WHAT THE
FACULTY APPROVE. YEP AND- I YOU
GUYS KNOW THAT HAVE A TEACHING.
BOARD HERE IN. CALIFORNIA THAT
WE USE AND THEY OFFER A PRE
LUMINARY TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND
THAT A PERMANENT TEACHING
CREDENTIAL. AND THAT'S IDENTICAL
TO WHAT OUR BOARD DOES WE HAVE A
PERSON COME AND THEY ENTER INTO
EDUCATION BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
TRAINED AS NURSES. TRADERS
FESPACO. SO THEY COME N AND
THEY GET BEYOND APPROVAL AND
THEY BECOME ESSENTIALLY A FREE
WOMEN ARE CREDENTIALED. TEACHER
THAT IS SIMILAR TO WHAT WE CALL
AN ASSISTANT INSTRUCTOR THEY DO
THAT FOR ONE YEAR. AND THEN THEY
ARE ABLE TO MOVE ON TO BE AN
INSTRUCTOR WHICH INSTRUCTOR
GROUP ALL IDENTICAL TO THAT
PERMANENT PRODUCTION THAT THE
TEACHER CREDENTIALING BOARD
DOES. AND SO WE STAY IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THAT. WEIGHT IS
DIFFERENT AND WHAT THE CREDITORS
DO IS THEY DO A ONE TIME
APPROVAL. AND THEY APPROVE YOU
AS AN INSTRUCTOR AND HE CAN
TEACH WHATEVER YOU WANT. WELL
NCSP AND THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
STATE WORD NURSING HAS RESEARCH
ON THAT AND THEY TALK ABOUT
HAVING RECENCY AND SUBJECT
MATTER CURRENCY. YOU WOULD NOT
WANT SOMEBODY WHO IS A PSYCH
NURSE TO TEACH OBSTETRICS. BABY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO TEACH THAT
CONTENT LIKEWISE YOU WOULD NOT
WANT SOMEBODY THAT IS A
PEDIATRIC NURSE. TO SITE AND SO
YOU NEED TO HAVE THOSE CONTENT
AREAS THAT THEY ARE RECENT AND
EQUIVALENT TO THAT OF A BEDSIDE
NURSE. SO WE DO THAT APPROVAL
PROCESS. ADDITIONALLY
ACCREDITORS REQUIRE A MASTER'S
DEGREE. OR A TERMINAL DEGREE IN
ORDER TO TEACH THAT'S NOT IN
ALIGNMENT WITH OUR TEACHING
CREDENTIAL WHERE DOES. YOU CAN
ENTER IN WITH A BACHELOR'S WITH
A MASTERS AND GET THAT
EXPERIENCE REALLY HELPED THAT
PIPELINE. BUT TEACHERS WE HAVE A
FACULTY SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHAT OUR BOARD DOES IS WE ARE
ALLOW FOR SO DEGREE COMPARED. TO
IN AND- IN A CALL SETTING WHERE
THEY CAN- MAY. WHERE THEY CAN
HELP DRESSING CHANGES. WE HAVE A
CALL BACK MEMBER PRESS. WE ALSO
THE ABILITY WHERE THEY CAN ENTER
WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE- AS AN
ASSISTANT INSTRUCTOR THEY CAN DO
A COMPLETE CLINICAL ROTATION
THAT'S WHAT THEIR EXPERTISE IS
THAT THE BAD SIDE. AND THEY
REPORT BACK TO YOU A FACULTY
MEMBER THAT HAS A MASTER'S
DEGREE INSTRUCTOR PREPARED
NURSE. AND THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT MANAGING ON THAT COURSE
THEY GET THE GRADES THEY MAKE
THAT CURRICULUM PLAN. THEY MAKE
SURE THAT IT MEETS THE GRADUATE
OBJECTIVES ETCETERA SO THE BOARD
ACTUALLY HAS MORE ENTRY POINTS
INTO BEING A FACULTY MEMBER TO
ADDRESS THE FACULTY SHORTAGE.
THEN THE ACCREDITOR AGENCY DOES
AND WE ARE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL STATE BOARDS OF
NURSING THAT SAYS YOU NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE CONTENT SPECIFIC.
BECAUSE YOU WOULD NOT WANT A
PSYCHIATRIC NURSE TO TEACH
SOMEBODY HOW TO DELIVER A BABY
AND I WILL BE SELLING WHERE IT
ALIGNMENT WITH THE NATIONAL
HEALTH. NURSING OKAY AT
APPRECIATE FIRST FIRST OF ALL-
AT THE PRESIDIO CONGRATULATIONS
ON ALIGNING ACCREDITATION
APPROVAL DURING THE SAME VISIT
TO SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
RAN A PROGRAM AND HAD TO GET
CREDITED I KNOW HOW MUCH THAT
INVOLVES SO. WHEN THAT CAN
HAPPEN THAT CERTAINLY MAKES
THINGS A LOT MORE EFFICIENT AND
SMOKE. SOME OF THEIR- I THINK ON
THE FACULTY SIDE I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BUT I GUESS
AGAINST SOMEONE WHO'S A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATOR YOU KNOW
MEDICAL EDUCATOR- AND I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT THE
CONTENT STUFF AS WELL BUT- FOR
EXAMPLE YOU SAID WELL YOU DON'T
HAVE PEDIATRIC NURSE TEACHING
PSYCHIATRY. YOU KNOW MENTAL
HEALTH ACCEPTS ACTUALLY DOES A
LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
PEDIATRICS. RIGHT SO AND THEN
YOU'RE YOU AND YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE GOING TO NURSING
SCHOOL SO IF THEY WERE ACTUALLY
GONNA BE A PSYCH NURSE IN THE
FUTURE THEY WOULD HAVE CONTINUED
MORE EDUCATION SO. I GUESS IT
AND YES. PEDIATRIC NURSE PRIOR
WHEN HAVE AS MUCH NON ABOUT
CERTAINLY SO SIDE. ISSUES RIGHT
CERTAINLY NOT ADULTS. ISSUES
BUT- I GUESS GIVE THE SHE- I
WANNA BE SURE WE'RE NOT OVER
GOING OVER CREDENTIAL ISM I
GUESS OF WHERE PLAYERS ARE LIKE
OKAY YEAH WE WERE TRYING TO
TRAIN SOMEONE TO BE IN OUR END
RIGHT- YOU KNOW THAT THAT AND
SO. AND THEN WHO'S THEN GOING TO
ACTUALLY FUTURE FIELD
DIFFERENTIATE POTENTIALLY THE
FUTURE OF THE INSIDE THE SUB
SPECIALIZED BUT THE MAN AT WHAT
THEY NEED TO KNOW AND AGAIN YOUR
PRIME RATE A PSYCH NURSE FIVE IS
GOOD TEACH- B. BUT I'M NOT PSYCH
NURSE SO I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE
WITH THE SECOND OF MAY CORRECT
ME. BUT I DO THINK THAT. FOR
SOME OF THESE FIELDS LIKE
CERTAINLY A YOU KNOW A FAMILY
NURSE PRACTITIONER OR A- A
PEDIATRIC NURSE ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO TEACH SOME BASICS OF MENTAL
HEALTH RIGHT NOW THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THE DANCE STUFF AND
YOU NEED TO. SO I. WE'RE TRYING
TO BE OUT HOW TO BUILD BROAD
PIPELINE. IN IF ONE OF THE-
NARROW CHOKE POINTS AS WE CAN'T
GET ENOUGH FACULTY YURI HAVE
CHALLENGES WITH NO PAY AND OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS. I WAS ON THE
SHOW WERE NOT PUT IN REGULATIONS
OR STANDARDS IN PLACE THAT-
WOULD. RESTRICT THE CAPACITY OF
SCHOOLS WHILE STILL MAINTAINING
OF COURSE CERTAINLY THE HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION WE DON'T WANT
TO COMPROMISE THAT. BUT- SO I
JUST GONNA PUT THAT OUT THERE.
CERTAINLY THAT'S AN ISSUE BUT I
THINK HOPEFULLY AND AGAIN.
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE
GRADATION BODIES AS WELL- BILL
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
FLEXIBILITIES IN MY BUILDING AND
WHAT THE TRUE IMPACT WOULD HAVE
I'M SURE YOU DO. IT WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE ON THEIR EDUCATION
RIGHT AND SO I JUST WANNA TO YOU
KNOW. HAVE A THINK ABOUT THAT.
YEAH ONE OTHER THING THAT WE
ACTUALLY JUST DID WERE MOVING
TOWARDS IT THIS MONTH IS
SUPPOSED TO BE IMPLEMENTED SO.
I'M GONNA PUT MY CARD FOR THE X.
WE ARE DOING A ONE TIME FACULTY
APPROVAL. THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WE'VE DONE ASKED AND THAT
WAS BASED ON FEEDBACK FROM OUR
DIRECTORS. SO WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE PAST IF YOU TAUGHT. AT-
GETTING A STATE UNIV. YOU WERE.
BUT THEY IF YOU WANT TO. STATE
UNIV. YOU WOULD HAVE TO GET
ANOTHER WE ARE ABLE WE'RE
ELIMINATING. AND IT'S A- ONE
TIME APPROVAL AND THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BE ADDED TO OUR BREEZE
LICENSE LOOK UP. SAME IS EXACTLY
CORRECTLY. BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH AND EVERYTHING GOES
SMOOTHLY. SO THAT WILL HELP TO
DECREASE THAT BUREAUCRACY OKAY
THAT'S WONDERFUL WONDERFUL HERE-
ANOTHER PART OF EDUCATION I
ALWAYS ASK MY CONTINUING
EDUCATION- NOW I UNDERSTAND.
YOU'RE FROM MY READ THE
BACKGROUND PAPER YOU'RE ONLY
DOING C. AUDITED THERE'S
COMPLAINTS WHICH IS DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER BOARDS WHICH
ACTUALLY. DID DOES A C. E. YOU
KNOW THEY DO A SAMPLE TO REVIEW-
AND- AND OF COURSE THERE'S NO
REPORT ON COMPLIANCE RATE SO I
MEAN- SO. I MEAN. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS THAT WHY ARE WE
DOING TO MONITOR C. E. AND THEN
ALSO IN ADDITION. BECAUSE
THEY'RE BORED OVER ALSO PROVES
THE C. E. ITSELF- AND I THINK
THERE HAVE BEEN ISSUES IN THE
PAST ABOUT. SOME OF THE YOU
KNOW. QUALITY OF THE C. E. R. X.
A CALL IS NOT THE RIGHT WORD
BUT- I GUESS. AND I'VE ASKED IN
THE PAST- DO YOU HAVE STANDARDS
FOR CONFLICT OF INTEREST WHEN IT
COMES TO TEACHING C. COURSES BE
SURE THERE'S A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST OF THE PERSON WHO'S
TEACHING ARE SPONSORING THE C.
E. IN TERMS OF PROVIDING EARLY.
DISCLOSURE OF POTENTIAL
CONFLICTS AS WELL SO- FIRST OF
ALL C. E. AUDITS. AND ALSO-
COMPLIANCE WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
CONTINUE EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
AND THEN. S. GIVING APPROVAL
ROLE- CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
REGARDING CONTINUING EDUCATION.
OKAY I THINK I GOT ALL THAT. THE
FIRST ONE IS. I'MNOT SURE IF IT
WAS NOT CLEAR IN OUR SUNSET
BACKGROUND- PAPER BUT WE DO.
RANDOM AUDITS WE ABSOLUTELY DO
NOT OKAY ALL. RIGHT SO. THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT. AND IF WE NEED
TO. GIVE YOU STATS ABSOLUTELY
WILL I CAN YOU THE WE DO THE
AUDIT AND ONLY A SMALL PERCENT
IS ACTUALLY REFERRED TO
ENFORCEMENT YOU. HAVE A FOLLOW
UP BECAUSE IT WASN'TCORRECT. IT
IS CLEAR SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
2% GOVERNMENT FORCE MINT.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWO POINT
SIX ORDERED FORSMAN. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN ONE POINT NINE WENT TO
ENFORCEMENT DOWN TO UNDER
PERCENT NOW GOING TO ENFORCE
OKAY. THOUGH ADDITIONALLY WITH
THAT- I'VE LOOKED INTO EVERY
SYSTEM OUR BRIEF SYSTEM ON
LICENSE RENEWAL. ASKED BY A
LICENSEE TO SUBMIT THAT COPY OF
THE CERTIFICATE OF COMPLETION
FROM THERE SEE YEARS. THAT'S NOT
A HARD STOP BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE REGULATORY AUTHORITIES
SAYS YOU MUST IN ORDER TO RENEW.
WE SAY YOU ATTEST TO IT AND YOU
KEEP THOSE RECORDS FOR FOUR
YEARS. AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO A LOT OF YOU TO SEE IF THAT
HAPPENS- I AM LOOKING AT BRING
YOU TOWARDS THE BOARD A
REGULATORY PROPOSAL. THEN MAKE
THAT A HARD STOP INCREASE TO
HAVE OUR LICENSEES THE NET OF
CERTIFICATES. THAT ACTUALLY
WOULD BENEFIT US B. HONEST. AND
OUR STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE OF OUR
LICENSEES WHAT WE FIND IS AFTER
FOUR YEARS THEY'RE NOT KEEPING
THEIR CERTIFICATE. WE CAN BE THE
REPOSITORY OF FOR THEM TO HAVE
THOSE CERTIFICATES ON. EVERY
SYSTEM THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT FINDING THEM LATER- WHEN
THEY'RE FOCUSED ON SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. WHAT THAT ALSO DOES
FOR US IT ALLOWS US TO JUST DO A
RANDOM MY AUDIT BY PULLING THE
RECORDS GROWN RESISTANT. VERSUS
HAVING TO CONTACT THE LICENSEE
AND SAY HEY SEND TO ME YOUR
SEATS SO THAT'S A REGULATORY
UPDATE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT A
FUTURE IMPLEMENTATION I HAVE TO
BRING IT FROM OUR BOARD AND SEE
WHERE WE MOVE RIGHT ON THAT. ON
YOUR FINAL QUESTION I FORGOT.
WHAT IT DOES ACTUALLY HAVE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST BECAUSE IF
YOU APPROVE C. E. DO YOU HAVE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST POLICY
BASICALLY SAYING THAT YOU. A
DISCLOSURE OF ANY CONFLICTS ARE
ALSO NOT HAVING DIRECT CONFLICTS. WITH THE MATURE YOUR T. CHANGE
THE YOUR FINANCIAL. IN IT. SO
YOU'RE NOT SENSE ADVERTISE. THE
STUFF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. YEAH
WE END IT SAID LAST YEAR THE
SONS THIS WAS THE DAY QUESTION
AND WE DID HAVE A TALK WITH THE-
WE STILL. HOWEVER BECAUSE HAVE
S. THAT QUESTION TO OTHER ABOARD
DO YOU SEE A HALF OFF THE RADAR
AND THEY ARE LOOKING AT
DEVELOPING A GENERALIZED TOPIC
DEBATES RESTATEMENTS ALL OF THE
BOARDS OF GIRLS WE WILL ALIGN
WITH THEM WHEN THAT COMES OUT.
OKAY SO THAT THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
AND IN IN MANY WAYS I APPRECIATE
THAT THE BOARD THAT THE VC
ITSELF BECAUSE IT'S THE SAME
QUESTION ACROSS THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. AND THEN A FINAL
QUESTION AND APPRECIATE AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR ASKED
LET ME ASK ME QUESTIONS- THE-
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT. COMMON
CALICO. FOR IS THAT WE'VE HAD
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS- PROMOTE.
MISINFORMATION DISINFORMATION
THAT'S UNDERMINED THE PUBLIC
HEALTH- DATS- AND OF COURSE
NURSES ARE VERY TRUSTED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SO CERTAINLY THIS
IS NOT AN ISSUE JUST WITH
NURSING WE'VE ASKED THIS
QUESTION OF. MEDICINE THE
MEDICAL BOARD. OTHER BOARDS AS
WELL. I DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU IF.
SO FIRST OF ALL. IS THIS AN
ISSUE THE BORED LOOKING AT-
NURSES WHO ARE ACTIVELY
PROMOTING MISINFORMATION
DISINFORMATION ABOUT WHETHER
KOBE JACKSON NATIONS AND OTHER
THINGS AND YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO ADDRESS
THAT- BASICALLY AGAIN AS A
PROTECTOR. OF THE HEALTH OF THE
PUBLIC. TO ADDRESS A LICENSEE'S
WHO ARE ENGAGED IN. SUCH
ACTIVITY PARTICULARLY THAT'S FOR
THEIR OWN FINANCIAL PERSONAL
FINANCIAL WHAT IS FINANCIAL OR
OTHER PERSONAL GAIN. AND
PROMOTING- MISINFORMATION OR
DISINFORMATION UNDERMINES PUBLIC
HEALTH. YEAH WE ALWAYS HOPE THAT
OUR NURSES WILL DO THAT BUT WE
DO HAVE THE- TEN. PUT THEM
THROUGH OUR ENFORCEMENT UNIT.
UNIT AND IT DO YOU DISCIPLINARY
ACTION ON THAT AND WE TAKE EVERY
ONE OF THESE COMPLAINTS
ABSOLUTELY SERIOUS. AND SO WHEN
WE GET A COMPLAINT WE DO AN
INDIVIDUALIZED- INVESTIGATION
AND WE- DIRECTED THROUGH THE
SYSTEM AS NEEDED BASED ON THE
EVIDENCE THAT WE FIND- IT'S NOT
JUST CALL WITH SPECIFIC WE HAVE
NURSES THEY GET MISINFORMATION
AND- FOR OTHER THINGS OTHER THAN
COAL AND WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN ABLE
TO TAKE ACTION ON THOSE. WILL
CONTINUE TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
. AND AGAIN I KNOW YOU CAN'T
TALK MY SPECIFIC CASE BUT CAN
YOU. YEAH CAN YOU INDICATE TO ME
ROUGHLY HOW MANY CASES ARE
CURRENTLY. OKAY FOR YOU TO GIVE
ME THAT I WILL OKAY IF YOU CAN
GET THAT BACK TO ME AND I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A DOCTOR FAN. LET ME TOUCH
ON A COUPLE OF THE ISSUES- THAT-
CENTER PANDAS ADDRESSED. WITH
RESPECT TO THIS APPROVAL
AUTHORITY OVER FACULTY. ARE YOU
WHERE DO ANY OF THE OTHER HEALTH
CARE LICENSING BOARDS HAVE
APPROVAL AUTHORITY OVER FACULTY
WHO TEACH IN. ADVOCATION OF
FACILITIES FOR EXAMPLE MEDICINE
PHARMACY. CHIROPRACTIC DENTISTRY. WITHIN CALIFORNIA. SO WITHIN
CALIFORNIA B. B. N. P. TI N. B.
R. N. B. OLY ONES THAT HAVE
EDUCATION APPROVAL INCLUDING THE
FACULTY HOWEVER WE ARE ALIGNED
WITH THE NATIONAL ACCREDITATION
WHAT ACTUALLY MATTERS I
UNDERSTAND THAT SO WIRE NURSES
IN THIS PARTICULAR SETTING
CALIFORNIA UNIQUE IN THAT REGARD
. WHAT IS UNIQUE ABOUT NURSING
EDUCATION. THAT REQUIRES THE
NURSING BOARD. TO REVIEW AND
APPROVE WHETHER ITS LIFETIME OR
INDIVIDUAL ASSIGNMENT- FACULTY.
STILL THE EVIDENCE AND C-SPAN IS
A NATIONAL COUNCIL STATE BOARD
OF NURSING IS A ROBUST COMPANY
THAT ACTUALLY MONITORS
EVERYTHING NATIONWIDE- AND
WORLDWIDE SO THEY HAD EVIDENCE
OF- WHAT THE BOARDS OF NURSING
STEW IN AFGHANISTAN BUT THE
BOARDS OF NURSING DO AND-
AUSTRALIA END OF OURS IN SO
BASED ON THAT OVERWHELMING
WEALTH AND EVIDENCE THEY ARE
ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT THE
SUCCESS OF A PROGRAM REALLY LIES
WITH THE FACULTY AND THE ABILITY
OF THE FACULTY TO BE FULL TIME.
THEY HAVE A LOW TURNOVER RATE
HAVE A LOW TURNOVER RATE AT THE-
DIRECTORS AS WELL AND DO YOU
HAVE- HIGH COMPETENCY LEVEL IN
THE CONTENT THAT THEY TEACH SO
BASED ON THAT THE FACULTY IS
WHAT SETS UP THE SUCCESS FOR THE
PROGRAM REMEMBER. THAT REALLY.
THAT'S NOT THAT'S DO THAN ANY
OTHER HEALTH COVERAGE AND- IS
IT. AND ISN'T THAT SOMETHING
THAT THESE NURSING PROGRAMS ARE
ROUTINELY. AND FACTOR REQUIRED
TO BE ACCREDITED SO ISN'T THAT
SOMETHING THAT AN ACCREDITING
BODY WOULD. INDEPENDENTLY AND
SEPARATELY ASSESS AND- INITIALLY
ACCREDITING AND RENEWAL THE YOUR
CREDIT AND AT THE POINT OF
RENEWAL OF ACCREDITATION. A
PARTICULAR PROGRAM. IT'S NOT
THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO BE
ACCREDITED AND IN FACT THE
STATISTICS THAT NCS COLLECTED
SHOWS THAT THE BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN NURSING PROGRAMS HAVE
DECREASED THEIR PERCENTAGE OF
ACCREDITATION WELL. KNOWN
FOREIGN. OKAY AGAIN THAT'S
THAT'S WITH US WE DO NOT HAVE A
REQUIREMENT TO HAVE. ANY OF OUR
PROGRAMS ACCREDITED. HELLO THERE
ARE MANY OTHER. BACHELOR'S
DEGREE PROGRAMS DO WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA NURSING. NOT MANY
DEGREE PROGRAMS BY JORDI ARE
CREDITED- IT'S OUR ASSOCIATE
DEGREE PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT AND
I CAN TELL YOU THAT OUR ENTRY
ASTOR'S PROGRAMS ARE A 100%
RIGHT BUT THE ASSOCIATED
PROGRAMS ARE CONTINUALLY
ASSOCIATES USE ME THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE PROGRAM TRYING TO CUT TO
THE CHASE HERE THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE PROGRAMS WERE THOSE
PROGRAMS GENERALLY- THAT ARE
CONDUCTED AT OUR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THEY NOT
. LET JORDY ART WE HAVE ABOUT A
HUNDRED. OF OUR PROGRAMS THERE
ARE STEPS YOU TO GREET AND WE
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
PROGRAMS SO THE MAJORITY OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
WELL THEN OKAY SO LET'S LET'S
CONCENTRATE ON THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE ACCREDITED. WHAT IS THE
VALUE ADDED MANY OF THE GOOD
NEWS HERE IS THE NURSING BOARD
AS A AS A FUND SURPLUS. IF YOU
WERE FINED INSOLVENT OR CLOSE TO
IT. MY QUESTIONS WOULD BE MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE AND MUCH MORE
POINTED. BUT WE STILL WANT
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS AND
I'M SURE YOUR LICENSEES WANT
THAT TOO. SO MY QUESTION IS IF
WE HAVE A HUNDRED ACCREDITED.
ASSOCIATE DEGREE PROGRAMS OR
WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS WHY WOULD
YOU WHY WOULD YOU. SPEND TIME ON
THE ACCREDITED ASSOCIATE DEGREE
PROGRAMS WITH RESPECT TO FACULTY
APPROVAL. WHY WOULDN'T IF YOU
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE WHY WHEN
YOU CONCENTRATE. ON THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE UNACCREDITED.
SO WE DO. CONCENTRATE ON THE
ONES THAT ARE UNACCREDITED AS
WELL SEE CREDIT PROGRAMS SO THE
ACCREDITATION PROGRAMS THEY HAVE
AN EIGHT YEAR CYCLE FOR
CONTINUING APPROVAL VISIT OR A
TEN YEAR CYCLE. WE HAVE MOVED TO
THE EIGHT AND TEN YEAR CYCLE FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS. THE ONES THAT
ARE NOT ACCREDITED WE CONTINUED
WITH OUR FIVE YEAR CYCLE OF
REVIEW. I MEAN MASS MARKET WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FACULTY APPROVAL
HERE. BACK T. APPROVALS ARE PART
OF THAT AND I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
KIND OF PROBABLY SPOKE TOO FAST
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT- WHEN I
WAS TALKING TO DOCTOR CAN. I
MENTIONED THAT WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING A ONE TIME FACULTY
APPROVAL THAT'S A HUGE HUGE
CHANGE FROM WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE PAST IN THE PAST WE USED TO
DO THAT FOR EVERY SCHOOL. AND
NOW WE'RE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL BOARD AND
JUST LIKE THE TEACHING
CREDENTIAL BOARD AS A SINGLE
SUBJECT OR MULTIPLE SUBJECTS. WE
ARE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE FACTS
AND SO. WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE OTHER SCHOOLS AND IN THOSE-
AREAS THAT HAVE ACCREDITATION.
AND THE OTHER BOARDS IN GIRLS
THEY PARTNER WITH THE TEACHING
CREDENTIALING BOARD AS WELL SO
THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS. WE DON'T
DO THAT WE ARE THE TEACHING
CREDENTIALING BOARD FOR THE FOR
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
FOR THAT. SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THAT DUAL ROLE WE DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER BOARD THAT IS
POTENTIALLY OUR TEACHERS WE DO
THAT SO HOPEFULLY THAT KIND OF
CLEARS THAT UP A LITTLE BIT. AND
WITH THE APPROVAL VISITS THE
APPROVAL VISITS DON'T ARE SORRY
FOR ANY PATIENT VISITS DON'T
OCCUR PRIOR TO PROGRAM. WE DO A
PROGRAM APPROVAL. IT CREDIT EACH
. I HEAR LATER. WE THREE YEARS
LATER TENURE LATER SO WE THE
MEAN THERE NOT ACCREDITED THEY
ARE APPROVED THEY NEED TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF FACULTY APPROVAL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
TEACH OUR STUDENTS AND SO IT'S
VERY COMPLEX THE USED TO RETREAT
DO YOU STILL READ DOES THE BOARD
STILL RETAIN APPROVAL AUTHORITY.
OVER NURSING PROGRAM DIRECTOR
HIRES AT INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS-
NURSING PROGRAMS YES WE DO IS
SIMILAR TO THE TEACHING
CREDENTIALING BOARD RIGHT-
INSULT MY QUESTION MY QUESTION.
MY QUESTION IS THIS AND YOU CAN
TELL I'M NOT PARTICULARLY- A
SUPPORTER OF THIS PIECE OF
REPARATION I AGREE WHEN YOU HAVE
. A PUBLIC SCHOOL FOR EXAMPLE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN PUBLIC SCHOOLS BETWEEN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PROGRAMS BETWEEN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAMS AND- SOME OTHER
PROGRAM THAT'S ON A STREET
CORNER SOMEWHERE THAT'S TURNING
OUT QUALITY NURSES. SO WHEN YOU
HAVE A PROGRAM IN A PUBLIC
SCHOOL WITH THE WITH THE CUT
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT
WITH THE DEAN OF A MEDICAL
SCHOOL ALL APPROPRIATE
APPROPRIATELY CREDENTIALED
BECAUSE THE YOUR THE
INSTITUTIONAL ACCREDITATION
REQUIRES THAT. FOR PROGRAMMATIC
ACCREDITATION IF THE SCHOOL HAS
THAT. AND YOU HAVE A FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND IN MANY CASES.
FRANKLY LABOR REPRESENTATIVES
FOR THE TEACHING FACULTY. WHY IS
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE NURSING
BOARD APPROVED NURSING PROGRAM
DIRECTORS IN EACH OF THESE
SCHOOLS APPROVE THE HIRING. AS
PART OF THE HIRING PROCESS I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT. C. H.
AGAIN IT GOESBACK TO IN RTP
WITH TEACHERS THEY HAVE A
APPROVAL PROCESS THEY WORK HARD
THROUGH EDUCATION AND
PREPARATION TO GET A PRELIMINARY
TEACHING CREDENTIALS THEY DO THE
SAME THING THEN GET A PERMANENT
TEACHING CREDENTIAL YOU CAN ONLY
HAVE THE PRELIMINARY ONE FOR
THREE YEARS AND THEN YOU CAN
HAVE A TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE RENEWED EVERY
FIVE YEARS IT'S IDENTICAL SQUARE
RECENCY PROCESS. THEY ALSO AS
THE TEACHER BOARD THEY
CREDENTIAL BEAR PRINCIPLES BUT
THE SAME THING AS OUR DIRECTOR
OF NURSING WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHERE THEY ARE IN A STRANGE AND
ALREADY WITH AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE
IS NOT TRAINED IN A LOT OF
THEORETICAL BACKGROUND AND
THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY NOT TRAINED
IN CURRICULAR DESIGN SO WHEN YOU
GET A BACHELOR'S PREPARED NURSE
YOU HAVE THEM AND THEY ARE GREAT
THEY ARE TRAINED IN THEORETICAL-
NURSING KNOWLEDGE BUT THEN WHEN
YOU GET TO THE MASTER'S DEGREE.
THAT MASTER'S DEGREE PERSON DOES
HAVE CURRICULAR- INSIGHT THEY DO
HAVE CLASSES AROUND THAT AND
THEY THEY THEN EARN BAD BILITY
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE
SPECIALIZATIONS IF YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A PERSON THAT WANTS TO
SPECIALIZE AND DO A MASTERS IN
NURSING BUT HAVE A FOCUS IN I.
T. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
CURRICULAR DESIGN SO IT'S NOT
JUST DEGREE SPECIFIC SO IT DOES
REQUIRE REVIEW PROCESS. AND WE
ARE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THAT EIGHT
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR EFFICIENCIES WE ARE AS WELL
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WANT TO
DECREASE THE BURDEN ON OUR
NURSING PROGRAM DIRECTORS I HEAR
YOU ON THAT I WANT TO DO THE
SAME THING AND SO DOES OUR FORD
WE'VE HAD THESE CONVERSATIONS
AND WE VOTED ON THESE WITHIN-
OUR BOARD MEETINGS TO MAKE THESE
THINGS AND ADDRESS THEM. SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
EFFICIENCIES FOR TRYING TO
DECREASE THAT BURDEN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN APPROVAL AND
ACCREDITATION THAT ACCREDITORS
VISITS AFTER THE APPROVAL IT CAN. BE YOURS IT IS NOT MANDATED
FOR ANY OF OUR PRO TAB APPROVAL
HEALTH. IN EVEN IF THEY BECOME
AN APPROVED PROGRA. IT'S AN APT
SITE DOES A CREDIT PROGRAMS
REQUIRE THEM TO BE A ONE TIME
APPROVAL FOR AN INSTRUCTOR AND
LIKE I SHARED BEFORE YOU DON'T
WANT. PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
CONTENT SPECIFIC CONTENT EXPERTS
TO TEACH THE NEXT BREED AT THE
NEXT- BATCH OF NURSES. COMING
THROUGH THE PIPELINE. IF THEY'RE
NOT ADEQUATELY PREPARED
THEMSELVES AND THAT'S WHERE THAT
PATIENT PROTECTION COMES FROM
WELL UNDER HIS. I WILL WANT. MY
WORDS USE ME I DON'T I WILL TELL
YOU THIS IT APPEARS TO ME THAT
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
HAS SORT OF AN IRON FISTED
CONTROL OVER NURSING EDUCATION
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND-
MAYBE THAT'S OKAY IF THE SCHOOLS
ACCEPTED I THINK YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IN
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. ALL OF THEM THOSE THAT
HAVE NURSING PROGRAMS- I'M NOT
SURE THAT THE THAT SORT OF
CONTROL WELL THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN APPROPRIATE TWENTY OR
THIRTY YEARS AGO OR MAYBE LONGER
I DON'T KNOW THE HISTORY. I'M
NOT SURE THAT IT'S NECESSARILY
APPROPRIATE TODAY AND IT'S
CERTAINLY RESTRICTS FLEXIBILITY
IT CERTAINLY AFFECTS THE TIMING
OF DECISIONS- AND I'M NOT
NECESSARILY SURE THAT THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING. MAYBE WE
SHOULD EXPLORE THIS HAS THE
EXPERTISE NECESSARY TO DO THE
KIND OF REVIEW THAT YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT TODAY PARTICULARLY
GIVEN YOUR- NURSING EDUCATION
COORDINATOR VACANCY RATE- AND
PERHAPS SOME ADJUSTMENT TO SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WHAT EFFECT THAT
NEC. VACANCY RATE AND THE NEED
FOR THE NUMBER OF ANY SEES THAT
THE BOARD IS. HAS HAD TO CARRY
ON THE ON THE BOOKS- IN YEARS
PAST BUT LET ME JUMP AHEAD I
DON'T MEAN TO BE DISRESPECTFUL.
I'M JUST TRYING TO MOVE ALONG
AND I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE EDUCATION
PROGRAM APPROVAL I'VE ASKED THIS
QUESTION BEFORE AND YOU YOU'VE
MENTIONED THAT. NURSING PROGRAMS
I GUESS THEY HAVE DIFFERENT.
CURRICULA FROM PROGRAM TO
PROGRAM AND- GIVEN THE IRON
FISTED CONTROL THAT I PERCEIVE
THE BOARD HAS OVER THESE
PROGRAMS. WHY IN THE WORLD HAS
THE BOARD NOT PUT OUT. THE
COMMON CURRICULUM FOR NURSING
EDUCATION. A COMMON CORE
CURRICULUM ONE THAT LITTLE THAT
IF SCHOOLS ADOPTED WOULD
RESTRICT THIS SOME OF THE
OVERSIGHT THAT THE BOARD-
EXERCISES WITH RESPECT TO THE
NURSING PROGRAMS. ENTER THE
EXPRESS THE EXTENT THAT YOU NEED
TO INSPECT AND APPROVE WHICH IS
I GUESS A LANGUAGE THAT WE ALL
USE HERE. YOU WOULD ONLY NEED TO
INSPECT AND APPROVE ONE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S THE CORE
CURRICULUM IN PLACE. AND TO THAT
YOU WOULD INSPECTED APPROVED AND
DETAIL ANY ADD ONS TO THE CORE
CURRICULUM. IS THERE A REASON.
CALIFORNIA DID PUT OUT A COMMENT
CURRICULUM BACK AT THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE WE DO HAVE SOME OF
OUR STUDENTS SCHOOLS THAT ARE
STILL UTILIZING THAT CURRICULUM-
HOWEVER WE IT WAS FOUND TO NOT
BE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL. THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSE
NURSING DOES NOT HAVE CONTROL
OVER CURRICULUM WHEN IT COMES
2 DEGREES GRANTING WE ONLY HAVE
A LICENSING REQUIREMENTS SO I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE A
MISUNDERSTANDING AS WELL. WE
ONLY APPROVE THE CONTENT THAT IS
REQUIRED FOR LICENSING ALL OTHER
CONTENT IS SPECIFIC TO THAT
SCHOOL AND SPECIFIC TO PREDICT
GREASE. CALIFORNIA BEING A
LEADER ALLOWS FOR MULTIPLE
DIRECTIONS INTO THE PROFESSION
WE HAVE AN ENTRY LEVEL MASTER'S
WE HAVE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE WE
HAVE AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE WE HAVE
THE THIRTY UNITS LV ENDS ARE AN
OPTION. SO WITH THAT THERE'S NO
DEGREE REQUIREMENT WITHIN
CALIFORNIA WE ONLY HAVE
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS
ADDITIONALLY THAT AFFECTS THE
RECIPROCITY IN THE INTEREST OF
OTHER NURSES FROM OUT OF STATE
COMING INTO CALIFORNIA. IF WE
HAD AN IRONCLAD YES THAT SAID
THIS CURRICULUM MUST BE THIS
THEN WE WOULD DECREASE THE
AMOUNT OF NURSES THAT WOULD MEET
THAT REQUIREMENT. FROM OUT OF
STATE COMING INTO CALIFORNIA
THAT'S ANOTHER THAT'S ANOTHER
SUBJECT THAT I HAVE A QUESTION
ON WHICH IS WHY YOU EVEN IF YOU
HAVE A TEN YEAR NURSE. COMING IN
FROM THE STATE OF GEORGIA WHY
YOU DO A COMPLETE PRE LICENSURE
REVIEW OF THE EDUCATIONAL
BACKGROUND OF THE TEN YEAR NURSE
BUT LET. ME FOCUS ON THE
QUESTION AT HAND. YOU APPROVED
FOR. YOU APPROVE NURSING. BUT
YOU DON'T. YOU DON'T PUT OUT AND
REQUIRE A CORE NURSING
CURRICULA. WHICH MAKES NO SENSE
TO ME AND IT CREATES A PROBLEM.
FRANKLY IN THE PIPELINE BETWEEN
THE ADN PROGRAMS AND A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN NURSING
PROGRAMS WHERE THE CURRICULA DO
NOT ALIGN. AND IT WOULD SEEM TO
ME THAT THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING HAS THE TIME TO SPEND ON
SOME OF THESE ACTIVITIES ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT SHOULD MOVE TO
THE TOP OF THE LIST. IS TO TRY
TO ARRIVE AT A CORE CURRICULUM
WHICH YOU CERTAINLY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DICTATE EITHER
IT'S- EITHER. IN YOUR CHARTER IS
A BOARD OR THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO MY QUESTION IS WHY NOT.
YEAH AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE IT IN
OUR PROFESSIONS CODE WHERE WE
WORK WITH OUR SCHOOLS AND MAKE
IT BACK ONLINE WHAT WE FOUND WAS
A LOT OF OUR SCHOOLS HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY ARE-
THAT THEY HAVE THE BEST WAY
FORWARD AND SO THEY HAVE THEIR
INDIVIDUAL CURRICULA AND
SOMETIMES WITH THE CSU SYSTEM
THEY ONLY ACCEPT SIXTY UNIT
TRANSFER WE HAD SOME NURSING
PROGRAMS THAT WERE WELL OVER
EIGHTY SO THEY'VE HAD TO
DECREASE THAT YOU ALSO GET INTO
COMPETITION WITH YOUR SCIENCE-
INSTRUCTORS AT THE COLLEGE WHERE
THEY BELIEVE. WE ONLY HAVE A
REQUIREMENT FOR AT LEAST SIXTEEN
UNITS OF SCIENCES AND THEY SAY-
OR NINETEEN SORRY AND THEY SAY
NO I NEED TWENTY FOUR UNITS ARE
NOT GOING TO DROP MY REQUIREMENT
OF MICROBIOLOGY SO THERE'S A LOT
OF ISSUES THAT HAPPEN. IN THE
DIVERSE ACADEMIC SETTING WITHIN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE MINIMUM
STANDARDS WE DON'T HAVE MAXIMUM
STANDARDS I WOULD THINK THAT IF
WE PULL CORD MAXIMUM OR MINIMUM
OR JUST A BLANK STANDARD- I
THINK THAT WOULD. CHANGE THE WAY
THAT NURSING EDUCATION YES
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT OUR
BOARD IS LOOKED AT YET I'D BE
HAPPY TO BRING THAT IN FRONT OF
THEM TO HAVE THEM CONSIDER THAT-
BUT- ARE ARE I THINK WE HEAR A
LOT OF FLASHBACK FROM RDG
DIRECTORS BECAUSE THEY TRULY DO
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE THE
CURRICULUM THAT FITS THEIR
DEMOGRAPHIC IN THEIR COMMUNITY-
AND SO WE'VE- ONLY EVER SAID IF
WE ARE IN. A MINIMUM LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS- AS IT PERTAINS TO
CURRICULUM AND NOT A SET
STANDARD- BUT I CAN SEE THAT THE
STATE STANDARD COULD HAVE SOME
BENEFITS IT MAY ALSO HAVE SOME-
COLLINS AND WE WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND REVIEW
ALL OF THAT. THE GREAT THING IS
WE DO HAVE THE NURSING EDUCATION
WORKFORCE- ADVISORY COMMITTEE
NEED BACK AND- WE REALIGN THEM
BACK IN NOVEMBER WE WERE BORED
AND THEY WILL BE MEETING COME
AGAIN IN APRIL AND THAT'S
EXACTLY THE STUFF THAT THEY'RE
TASKED TO LOOK AT. SO I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
RECOMMENDATION- CENTER ROCK AND
BRING IT FORWARD TO THEM AND SEE
WHAT THEY CAN COME UP WITH I
COULD SEE THAT THESE ARE SOME OF
THE COMPLAINTS THAT WE RECEIVED
I HEAR YOU WANT THEM AND I THINK
THAT'S ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN LOOK AT. WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE PAST BECAUSE WE'VE ONLY SET
MINIMUM STANDARDS YOU AND YOUR
YOUR BOARD TEAM TELL ME THAT
SOMEONE WHO GRADUATES FROM A TWO
OR THREE YEAR PROGRAM WHETHER
IT'S A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR SOME
OTHER PROGRAM OF THE- THAT
QUALIFIES FOR THE EXAM AND FOR
THE REGISTERED NURSING. LICENSE
CAN TAKE THAT EDUCATIONAL
BACKGROUND AND MOVE IT ENTIRELY
TO A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. SCHOOL OF NURSING OR
SOME OTHER SCHOOL OF NURSING
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I CALL THE
CORE CURRICULUM. AN INMATE ALL
OF ALL THE BASIC REBEL THE BASIC
NURSING REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT
HAVING TO RETAKE ANY CLINICAL
NURSING COURSES AND INSTEAD
CONCENTRATE ON THE LIBERAL ARTS
COURSES AND- THE MANAGEMENT
COURSES THAT MAKE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE ATM AND THE B. S.
AND- THEN I'M SATISFIED BUT I
SUSPECT. THE ANSWER TO MY
QUESTION IS THAT DOESN'T. EXIST
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TODAY. IT SAY. EXITING DOES THAT
WELL I KNOW I WAS. WAS OF THAT
PROBE IS YOU KNOW. STATE YEAH.
IT THE FIRST. JUST TAKES MONTHS
LATER BUT A REGIONAL. CURRICULUM
BROKE GROUP THAT IS LOOKING AT
THAT THEY'RE MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON IT IT IS MADE
UP OF OUR DEANS AND DIRECTORS
AND THEY WILL BE PUTTING THAT
OUT AND THAT WOULD BE PERFECT IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN.
GATHER INCLUDING THE EVIDENCE
AND SUBMIT APPROVAL I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS WHY DOES THAT TAKE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR SITTING
IN HIS DISTRICT OFFICE
CONVENING. LOCAL NURSING PROGRAM
DIRECTORS DEANS AND COLLEGE
PRESIDENTS AND PROVOSTS. TO DO
THAT IS THAT NOT A FUNCTION OF
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
BECAUSE BECAUSE IF YOU DID IT IT
WOULD BE TRUE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND WE WOULD NEED AND
DEPEND ON REGIONAL.
PARTICIPATION TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN RIGHT- THAT'S NOT. THAT
THE BOARD HAS GONE BEFORE
BECAUSE WE REALLY DO LIKE TO
LEVERAGE THE EXPERTISE OF OUR
DEANS AND DIRECTORS WHO KNOWS
WHAT KIND OF FACULTY THEY HAVE
NO THE DEMOGRAPHIC THAT THEY
SERVE. IN REALLY THE NEEDS OF
THAT COMMUNITY AND BASED ON
THEIR INPUT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA'S VAST WHICH YOU HAVE
IN IMPERIAL VALLEY DOWN HERE
NEXT TO THE BORDER. IS VASTLY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT YOU HAVE ND
WHY RICA OR BUY SELL YEAH OR
EVEN LA AND SO YOU WANT TO HAVE
THOSE SCHOOLS TO SERVE THEIR
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES. AND OUR
DEANS AND DIRECTORS HAVE THAT
INNATE INFORMATION THAT THEY CAN
LEVERAGE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT INPUT IT'S GREAT TO GET
THAT INPUT. I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT OUR NEW ACTOR
THAT NURSING EDUCATION WORKFORCE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE CAN LOOK AT
AND WE CAN PUT SOMETHING FORWARD
THAT'S EVIDENCE BASE AS YOU KNOW
IN ORDER TO GET ANYTHING
DEREGULATION IN ANYTHING IN THE
STATUTE EVERYTHING HAS TO BE
EVIDENCE BASED. AND SO WHEN WE
DO OUR REGULATORY CHANGE WHICH
WE DIDN'T VOTE- AS A WARD IN
NOVEMBER TO UPDATE SIXTEEN CC
ARE FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX WHICH IS
THE REQUIRED CURRICULUM. THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO UPDATE THAT AND
I THINK WE CAN GIVE YOU WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR SENATOR ROCKS
I THINK IT IS TIME AND THAT'S
WHAT OUR NATIONAL COUNCIL STATE
BOARDS OF NURSING AGREEING TO.
IT'S TIME TO DO A REVAMP OF
NURSING EDUCATION AND SEE WHAT
WE CAN ALIGN AND DO TOGETHER.
WELL I'LL SAY THIS I MEAN IF. I
WOULD BE CAN. ABOUT THE PORT.
AND MOBILITY OF OUR- NURSING-
CADRE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IF THERE THAT MANY DIFFERENCES
IN THE NURSING CURRICULA FROM
THE TOP OF THE STATE TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE STATE BUT FOR THE
NATIONAL EXAM WHICH MUST BE THE
LEVELING FORCE HERE TO MAKE
SURE. THAT SOMEBODY WHO'S
TRAINED AT HUMBOLDT OR SOME
OTHER OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CAN MIGRATE
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIAN PERFORM
EFFECTIVELY IN THE WORKPLACE BUT
THANK YOU FOR THOSE RESPONSES I
JUST HAVE. A COUPLE OTHER
QUESTIONS AND I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WORK FORCE
MANAGEMENT SCHOOL APPROVALS THIS
IS AN ISSUE FOR ME AND I KNOW
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
UTILIZES ECONOMICS AND WORK
FORCE OF. A DATA IN ITS DECISION
MAKING PROCESS BUT I DON'T KNOW
TO WHAT EXTENT SO. I GUESS THE
FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT FACTORS
ARE UTILIZED TO DETERMINE
WHETHER AN EXISTING PROGRAM.
NURSING PROGRAM THAT IT SHOULD
BE APPROVED FOR EXPANSION OR NOT
. OKAY I GOT THAT ONE TWO THREE
SO WE HAVE WHAT'S CALLED A
DIRECTOR'S HAND BUT WITHIN THAT
DIRECTORS HELM BUT IT ALLOWS THE
PROCESS AND WHAT THEY CAN DO TO
SEE CONGRESS OF STANHOPE CHANGE.
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGE- ALSO
INCORPORATE ENROLLMENT INCREASES
SO WHEN YOU HAVE AN ENROLLMENT
INCREASE THEY HAVE TO LOOK AT DO
THEY HAVE FACULTY SUPPORT THIS
CLINICAL SITES TO SUPPORT THIS
YOU HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT THAT DO THEY HAVE
BUDGETS FOR THE ONLY GETTING IT
BUDGETED BY COVERING IT WITH
GRANTS THE GRANTS CAN SOMEONE
GOING YEAR TO YEAR BASIS. IF IT
IS COVERED BY GRANTS DOES THAT
PROGRAM HAVE THE ABILITY TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THAT YOU'D BE
ABLE TO COVER THE FUNDING IMPACT
GOING FORWARD. ADDITIONALLY DO
THEIR CLASSROOM SPACE IF IT'S A
BRICK AND MORTAR CAMPUS AND YOU
WANT TO ROLL A HUNDRED STUDENTS
DO YOU HAVE A CLASSROOM THAT
WILL SUPPORT A HUNDRED STUDENTS-
IF YOU DO YOU HAVE A COMPUTER
LAB THAT WILL SUPPORT A HUNDRED
STUDENTS DO YOU HAVE A LIBRARY
RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT A HUNDRED
STUDENTS- ARE YOU IN A
FINANCIALLY GOOD STANDING. DO WE
NEED THAT BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
DOES THE COMMUNITY NEED THAT ARE
YOU A COMMUNITY LIKE LA OR SAN
DIEGO THAT IS SATURATED WITH THE
WORK FORCE THAT DOES NOT HAVE
CLINICAL SITE. AND WHY WOULD YOU
WANT TO ADD ANOTHER SCHOOL THERE
OR ARE YOU IN BUY SELL YEAH OR
MORE OR READ WHERE YOU'RE LIKE I
OUR VIEW. I ABSOLUTELY NEED MORE
STUDENTS I NEED SOME ASSISTANCE
HERE ARE YOU THAT AREA THAT
NEEDS THIS AND HAS THE ABILITY
TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS IT'S A
REALLY BREAKING IT DOWN. FROM
THE SCHOOL THEY ATTEND THEY-
REACH OUT TO THE NURSING
EDUCATION IS OFTEN SAY HEY I'M
LOOKING AT A ROMAN INCREASE WHAT
I HAVE TO DO WE WALK THEM
THROUGH THAT PROCESS TO GRAB
THAT ALL OF THE DATA. TO REALLY
MAKE SURE THAT BACK IS THERE AND
WHEN A STUDENT ENROLLED IN THAT
PROGRAM THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE. ASK THE EXPERTS AND
GET A JOB WE WANT THERE TO BE
ABLE TO REPAY THEIR FINANCIAL
AID WE WANT. THEM TO BE ABLE TO
BE GAINFULLY EMPLOYED I THIS AND
NOW YOU LOOK AT THE- INSTITUTES.
ONLY 82% OF THE STUDENTS SCHOOL
STUDENTS SORRY THANK A NURSE
PRO. ARE ABLE TO PASS AND CLICKS
ON THE FIRST TIME NATIONWIDE. SO
THAT MEANS IF YOU HAVE A HUNDRED
STUDENTS THAT MEANS EIGHTEEN OF
THEM WILL BE ABLE TO PASS ON THE
FIRST TIME THAT MEANS NATIONAL
ACCREDITING AGENCY SORRY THE
NATIONAL STATE BOARDS OF NURSING
SAYS YOU CAN'T RETAKE FOR
ANOTHER THREE MONTHS YOU NEED TO
GO BACK IN THE MEDIA THAT'S
THREE MORE MONTHS IF THIS PERSON
DOESN'T HAVE INCOME. AND IS NOW%
INCREASING MORE BURDEN TO THEIR
FAMILY AND SO WE WANT TO BE ON
TOP OF THAT SO WE ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS THEY PROVIDE AN
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY THEY SHOW THE
DOCUMENTS THEY TURNED THAT INTO
THEIR NEC WE THEN PUT THAT ON
THE CALENDAR THE BOARD IS ABLE
TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS AROUND
THAT. AND MAKE A GREAT
DETERMINATION AND I'M HAPPY TO
SAY THAT OUR BOARD JUST IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE APPROVED AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN NEW
STUDENTS SLOTS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS WHICH THAT MEANS IF IT'S A
TWO YEAR PROGRAM. YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS
COMING OUT OF THAT PROGRAM IF
IT'S A FOUR YEAR PROGRAM YOU
QUADRUPLE THAT SO THEY HEARD
THAT THEY APPROVED FIVE NEW
PROGRAMS LAST YEAR FOR NEW
CAMPUS LOCATIONS AND FOURTEEN
ENROLLMENT INCREASES AND
ACCEPTED BY MORE FEASIBILITY
STUDIES FOR NEW PROGRAMS TO SAY
HEY. I THINK I CAN RUN A NURSING
PROGRAM LET ME SHOW YOU HOW WE
CAN AND THEY'RE MOVING THROUGH
THE PIPELINE IT'S AN AMAZING DAY
TO REALLY SEE THAT OUR BORDERS
RESPONSE INTO THE WORK FORCE
NEEDS AND THEY'RE GETTING THE
STUDENTS TO THEIR SCHOOLS
THROUGH THEIR CREATING NEW
STUDENT SLOTS AND WERE
ABSOLUTELY HAVING EFFECT. AND
ADDITIONALLY SOME OF THOSE-
PLACEMENTS OCCURRED IN BOSTON-
YEAH THE OCCURRED IN IMPERIAL
THEY ARE CURRENTLY IN FLIGHT SO
THEY'RE TRULY LOOKING AT THE
AREAS THAT NEED THIS AND THEY'RE. GROWING INTO THAT WE HAD A FEW
PEOPLE- GET CAMP APPROVAL IN
PROGRAM APPROVALS ON. WHEN I MET
WITH CHF THEY SAID THERE WAS BIG
MEDIA AND ONTARIO IN THAT AREA
FOR NEW NURSES AND I WAS ABLE TO
SAY GREAT. ARIZONA COLLEGE WAS
ONE OF OUR COLLEGES TO KEEP YOUR
WE JUST APPROVE THAT AS A BSN
PROGRAM AT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
STUDENTS EACH YEAR AND ROLLED
INTO THEIR PROGRAM. IT'S A THREE
YEAR PROGRAM THEY'LL HAVE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY STUDENTS
GRADUATING FROM THAT PROGRAM ON
A THREE YEAR BASIS- GOING OUT
AND SERVING THAT COMMUNITY.
HELLO YEAH. WARRIOR THIS I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH ALL OF THE-
BRICK AND MORTAR CAPABILITY
CLINICAL PLACEMENT CAPABILITY
FACULTY SIZE AND QUALIFICATIONS.
ALL THOSE THINGS ARE TYPICALLY.
FACTORS THAT- THAT AN ACCREDITOR
OR APPROVAL AGENCY WOULD TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION IN DECIDING
WHETHER A MEDICAL SCHOOLS SHOULD
BE ACCREDITED OR APPROVED OR A-
PHARMACY SCHOOL OR- CHIROPRACTIC
SCHOOL OR YOU GO DOWN THE LIST
DENTAL SCHOOL. IN THIS CASE DOES
THE BOARD USED USE FORECASTED
SUPPLY OF NURSES IN OTHER WORDS
ECONOMIC FACTORS IN DETERMINING
WHETHER TO APPROVE OR DENY. NEW
SCHOOL OR MORE APPROPRIATELY THE
EXPANSION OR NOT OF AN EXISTING
SCHOOL AND IF SO WHY. WHAT
YOU'RE ON MUTE. THANK YOU- WE
ACTUALLY LEVERAGE THE REPORT
FROM UCSF WE DO A WORK FORCE
REPORT EVERY TWO YEARS AND WE DO
A SCHOOL REPORT ANNUALLY AND WE
PUT THOSE TOGETHER AND PRESENT
THAT TO OUR BOARD AND THEY'RE
ABLE TO GO AHEAD AND LOOK AT
THAT AND SAY WHAT IS HAPPENING
WE ALSO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
WHAT OUR SCHOOL SUBMIT TO US
THEY MIGHT FIND ADDITIONAL DATA
OUT THERE. THAT MAY CONFLICT
WITH WHAT WE HAVE IN STORE BOARD
MEMBERS WILL AT THAT POINT SAY
HEY YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH DATA TO MAKE A DECISION
TODAY I'M GOING TO DEFER ACTION
CAN YOU COME BACK IN OUR BOARD
MEETING NEXT MONTH WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION SO THAT I
CAN MAKE THAT DECISION AND UR
BOARD HAS NOT DENIED A SINGLE
ENROLLMENT INCREASE REQUEST A
NEW PROGRAM OR PRESS. REQUEST
FOR A NEW CAMPUS LOCATION
REQUEST SINCE I WENT BACK TO
LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE SINCE
TWENTY NINETEEN FORWARD- AND SO
THEY ARE TRULY LOOKING AT ALL OF
THAT TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
WHEN IT'S NEEDED AND MAKING
THESE APPROVAL. SO THERE ARE
SCHOOLS CAN BETTER SERVE. WELL I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS WELL LET ME
ASK A PRELIMINARY QUESTION MY R.
BACKGROUND PAPER SAYS THAT WE
HAVE FORTIN 580-001-0060 FIVE
ACTIVELY LICENSED REGISTERED
NURSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I ASSUME THAT'S
CORRECT SO DOES THE BOARD NO OR
DOES YOUR STUDY REFLECT HOW MANY
OF THOSE FOUR HUNDRED AND
580-001-0060 FIVE ACTIVELY
LICENSED NURSES ARE STILL IN
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THE PRACTICE
OF NURSING OR HOW MANY HAVE.
RETIRED OR DECIDED TO STAY HOME
OR HAVE FOUND JOBS IN OTHER
FIELDS OUTSIDE OF THE FIELD OF
NURSING YET HAVE MAINTAINED AN
ACTIVE LICENSE. SO THE GREAT
THING IS WE WON THEM ALL OF THAT
DATA REALLY SOON THAT
LEGISLATORS PASSED A BILL LAST
YEAR THAT GAVE THAT INFORMATION
OVER THROUGH DC AIRPORTS ACROSS
TO H. HIGH. AND SO H. KAISE
DEVELOPING THAT ANY NURSE ANY
HEALING ART TOWARD ANY RENEWAL
OF THE LICENSE TO COLLECT THAT
DATA TO FIND OUT ARE YOU
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED ARE YOU
DECIDING TO. RETIRE AND SO THAT
WAS JUST PASSED IN JANUARY OF
THIS LAST YEAR AND GIVEN TO H.
FIVE AND H. FIVE WILL BE GIVING
US THAT INFORMATION FOR ALL OF
THE DCA WHITE BOARDS AND GIRLS
ARE AFFECTED BY THAT WELL THEN I
ASSUME THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
BE USING FORECASTED SUPPLY OF
NURSES. OR ECONOMIC FACTORS
BETWEEN NOW AND THE TIME YOU
HAVE THAT NEW DATA AND ANALYZE
IT. IN MAKING THIS WHETHER TO
APPROVE OR DENY EXPANSIONS OR
NEW PROGRAMS. SO THE GREAT THING
IS THEY BASE THAT ON THE REPORTS
THAT WE DID AND SO WHEN THEY
WERE H. TIE WS DOING A
PRESENTATION. DEC EIGHT ACTUALLY
ASKED ME TO COME AND PRESENT
BECAUSE OUR BORDERS BUT IT WAS
MODEL LOT. SO YES WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY USING THAT DATA
CURRENTLY IT IS COLLECTED
THROUGH OUR UCSF CONTRACT THAT
WE JUST RENEWED LAST JUNE. AND
BASED ON THE CSA AUDIT
RECOMMENDATION THE HOW WE CAN DO
OUR PRE LICENSURE PROGRAM
APPROVAL BETTER. THEY
RECOMMENDED THAT WE GET DOWN TO
THE REGIONAL WATER LEVEL THAT
WAS ADDED TO OUR CONTRACT I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO IT AT THE
DATA TO GET IT DOWN TO REGIONAL
LEVEL LEVEL VERSUS JUST HAVING
IT STAY RIGHT. WELL IF WE HAVE
IT STATEWIDE THAN WHAT. WHAT'S
THE NUMBER IF IT'S NOT FOUR
HUNDRED AND 580-001-0060 FIVE
WHAT NUMBER. OF ACTIVE OF
ACTIVELY LICENSED NURSES. DO WE
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THE
PRACTICE OF NURSING. IN ONE
NURSING. CAPACITY OR THE OTHER.
I CAN REACH OUT TO YOUR
CONTRACTED PERSON TO GET THAT
DATA AND GET IT BACK TO CENTER.
I KNOW THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
USE I CAN ACTUALLY GET THAT DATA
FOR YOU. WELL I MEAN. WHAT
CAUSES MY CONCERN IS TO MY
KNOWLEDGE NO OTHER. LICENSED
PROFESSION WITH THE EXCEPTION
PERHAPS OF THE VOCATIONAL NURSES
NO OTHER LICENSED PROFESSION
USES WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ECONOMIC FACTORS VACANCY
ANALYSIS IN DETERMINING WHETHER
TO APPROVE PROGRAMS OR TO
APPROVE OR DENY EXPANSION OF
PROGRAMS EXCEPT YOU AND THE
OTHER- THE OTHER OCCUPATION I
MENTIONED. AND SO I GUESS I'M
WONDERING WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT
THE NURSING PROFESSION THAT
CAUSES YOU TO WANT TO DO THAT AS
A AS A FIELD YOU BEING THE
BOARD. NUMBER ONE- CAN THE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS WHY NOT
WHAT ECONOMIC FACTORS IN THE
MARKET PLACE DICTATE THE SIZE
AND SUCCESS OF NURSING TRAINING
PROGRAMS WHAT GIVES THE BORDER
THE STATE. THE RIGHT THE
ENTITLEMENT TO REACH DOWN AND
TELL ENTITIES THAT WANT TO TRAIN
NURSES THAT THEY CAN'T DO IT
BECAUSE OUR STUDY INDICATES WE
DON'T NEED ANY MORE NURSES. SO
I'LL TRY TO CLARIFY THAT A
LITTLE BIT- FOR YOU THERE WE
DON'T SAY THAT BECAUSE THE WORK
FORCE NEEDED IS NOT NEEDED IN LA
THAT WE MORE GROUP WHEN THEY
BRING INFORMATION TO US OUR
BOARD LOOKS AT THAT INFORMATION
AND IN FACT WE'VE APPROVED
SEVERAL SCHOOLS JUST THIS LAST
YEAR. FOR LA IN ORANGE COUNTY I
HAVE THREE SCHOOLS RIGHT OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD THAT I CAN THINK
OF THAT A LADY IN A INCREASE IN
ORANGE COUNTY INCREASED ACTUALLY
BY SCHOOLS IN LA. AND SO WITH
THAT YOU IT'S NOT BASED SOLELY
ON WORKFORCE NEED- BUT THERE ARE
STATISTICS OUT THERE THAT SHOW
THAT A PERSON THAT GOES TO
SCHOOL REALLY WANTS TO BE
EMPLOYED WITHIN FIFTY MILES OF
WHERE THEY WENT TO SCHOOL AND
STAYED WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITY
AND SERVE THAT COMMUNITY. WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN THE RECESSION HIT
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE IS NURSING
STUDENTS WERE GRADUATING AND
THEY WERE HAVING TO MOVE TO
ALASKA TO GET JOBS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA NEVER MOVED TO
KENTUCKY TO GET JUST. GIVE ME
JOBS OUT OF CALIFORNIA WHAT YOU
DON'T WANT TO SEE IS THAT YOU
GOT NURSES GRADUATING SCHOOL
PASSING IT COLLECTS AND THEY
CANNOT GET EMPLOYEE SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS ALWAYS
KIND OF IN THE BACK BURNER THAT
YOU WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. KNOWING THAT THE
DATA SUPPORTS OF THE STATEMENT
FIFTY MILES OF WHERE THEY GO TO
SCHOOL BUT ADDITIONALLY YOU WANT
TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS THE
CLINICAL IMPACTION THAT'S TRULY
THE NUMBER ONE INDICATOR AND
ALSO LET ME DIRECT I DON'T. I
DON'T. I DON'T. PLEASE I DON'T
DISAGREE THAT CLINICAL PLAY. ARE
FACTOR DIDN'T SAY THAT. LET'S
MICHAEL. IS WHY DO YOU CONSIDER
A WORK FORCE ANALYSIS. AND
SUPPLY OF NURSES OR NOT IN
MAKING THESE DECISIONS WHEN NO
OTHER OCCUPATION APPEARS TO BE
DOING THAT. AND FRANKLY IF WE
APPLIED YOUR STANDARD TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
THAT WOULD BE AN INTERESTING
OUTCOME TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN ONLY AND ROLL THOSE PEOPLE.
WHO WERE WORKING OR TRAINING FOR
JOBS WHERE JOBS EXISTED WITHIN
FIFTY MILES OF THEIR PLACE OF
RESIDENCE. SO THAT'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT THAT'S THE EVIDENCE
THAT SAYS WHY THIS IS SOMETHING
WE SHOULD CONSIDER THERE'S NOT A
ONE AND DONE ANSWER FOR THIS IT
IS A MUCH MORE ROBUST. AND VERY
DIFFICULT. TACTIC TO EVEN LOOK
AT WHICH IS WHY I BELIEVE AB TEN
FIFTEEN WAS ASKED FOR YOU GUYS
THIS LAST YEAR THEY GAVE THE
BOARD THE SPECIFIC DIRECTION IN
BPC TWENTY. SEVENTEEN SO LOOK AT
THIS TO FIND CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
TO FIND. ANSWER FOR ALL OF THIS
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE OUR SCHOOLS
EXPAND AS NEEDED TO SERVE THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT JUST LIKE
WE DO WITH- PRIVATE COLLEGES ARE
LOOKED OUT WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING
AT THEIR CREDIT EACH AND THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THEIR FUNDING.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- LOOKED AT
EXACTLY THE SAME WAY YOU CAN
GRADUATE SCHOOL STUDENTS BUT ARE
THOSE STUDENTS ABLE TO BE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED AFTERWARDS
AND THAT'S THE KEY YOU DON'T
WANT PEOPLE WALKING AROUND WITH
THE STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND A
DEGREE. I CAN'T GET A JOB SO YOU
HAVE TO TAKE IN ALL OF THESE
THINGS INTO CONSIDERATION TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WERE TRULY
ABLE TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. AND
OUR STUDENTS ARE PUBLIC AS WELL
AND SO YOU WANT THEM TO BE ABLE
TO BE GAINFULLY EMPLOYED
AFTERWARDS SO THAT IS ONLY A
PARTIAL CONSIDERATION THERE ARE
SO MANY OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
MORE TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION A
LOOK AT. WELL I LISTEN I
ABSOLUTELY RESPECT WHAT YOU AND-
THE MEMBERS OF THE BOARD AND
YOUR STAFF TO EACH AND EVERY DAY
WITH RESPECT TO NURSING
EDUCATION AND NURSING LICENSURE
IN THE STATE. I WOULD LIKE TO-
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET SOME INPUT
FROM YOU BECAUSE THEY'RE CLEARLY
APPEARS TO BE. EITHER A
DISCONNECT OR SOME STRANGE
ANOMALY IN THE MARKET PLACE NOW
WERE. HOSPITALS ARE FILLED WITH
TRAVELLING NURSES. HOSPITAL CEOS
COMPLAIN ABOUT SHORTAGES OF
NURSES AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
SECURE. NURSES TO FILL SHIFTS AT
THE SAME TIME THAT WE HAVE
NURSING RATIOS. THAT ABSENT AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER NEED TO BECOME
WITH. SO I LOOK FOR TO HAVING A
CONTINUE KIND. WITH YOU ON ON
THESE ISSUES THE APPROVAL
CRITERIA HOW THOSE FIT IN WITH
SCHOOLS AND WHETHER SCHOOL
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EXPAND OR NOT.
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
RESPONSES. TO MIKE POINTED
QUESTIONS AND I HOPE THEY WERE
TOO POINTED. LET ME LET ME TURN
IT BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE
IF- IF THEY HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS BEFORE OR COMMENTS
BEFORE I. I GO TO- MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC JERRY BERMAN THANK
YOU CHAIR OFTEN BY THE PATIENT
BY THE WAY AND I. NO IT'S BEEN
GREAT AND I'VE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
EVERY TIME I THINK I'VE GOT A
QUESTION THAT GETS ANSWER GETS
ASKED- SO IT'S A REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE'VE HAD MORE YOU APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWERS. I HAVE JUST GOT
ONE QUESTION THAT'S AS KIND OF A
SUBSET OF A QUESTION ANSWER ROTH
RAISED- RELATED ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN IN EDUCATION PROGRAM
APPROVAL ONE CONCERN THAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM. A LOT OF PUBLICLY
FUNDED SCHOOLS IS THAT THERE IS
A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY IN WHAT
CONSTITUTES A MAJOR OR MINOR
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE WHICH IS
ACCOMPANIED BY A TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE. FOR EVERY
APPLICATION I KNOW THAT THE
CHAIR OFF OF THE TWO THAT THE
STRONG FINANCIAL POSITION AT
THE- YOU KNOW THAT THE BOARD IS
IN- DOES THE B. R. AND HAVE
GUIDELINES THEY CAN SHARE- WITH
SCHOOLS TO HELP CLARIFY. WHAT
MAJOR VERSUS MINOR MEANS. YEAH
WE HAVE THAT IT'S CALLED THE
DIRECTOR'S HANDBOOK. WE SHARED
THAT AN UPDATE BACK ANNUALLY FOR
THEM IT IS BASED ON OUR
REGULATIONS WE DO HAVE A CURRENT
REGULATORY PACKAGE THAT IS THE
ACT AWAY ALL. THAT WE RECEIVE
SOME PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT WILL
BE ADDRESSING. AND THAT
ADDRESSES THE TWO REGULATIONS
THAT WE UPDATED THAT PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION ON
THAT. AND THAT IS FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE APPROVAL
REQUIREMENTS AND FOURTEEN THIRTY
TWO CHANGES TO AN APPROVED
PROGRAM. SO ONCE THOSE
REGULATIONS ARE CLEARED THEY
HAVE GONE THROUGH THE STEPS WE
GOT THE EXECUTIVE SUMMARY. THE
EYESORE AND THAT THAT EPISODE
OURS WELL THE FINAL STEPHEN
REASONS ALL THERE IT IS WITH A
WAY OUT. WE DID GET GO OUT FOR
COMMENTS WERE WORKING ON
ADDRESSING THOSE AND THAT WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATION
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW. OUR BOARD
OPERATES SOLELY UNDER REGULATORY
AUTHORITY AND STATUTORY
AUTHORITY SO IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THAT GUIDANCE YOU ARE PROGRAM
DIRECTORS. WE HAVE TO BE
ALIGNMENT BALL THOSE LAWS. AND
SO WE'RE UPDATING OUR
REGULATIONS TO BE MORE CLEAR.
AND WE ARE UPDATING THAT WITHIN
OUR DIRECTOR'S HANDBOOK INSTILLS
THE REGULATIONS. ARE PASSED BY
THE TIME WE DO THAT YOU.
ADDITION OF THE DIRECTORS HAVE.
THAT WILL BE AS WELL- BUT ARE
ANY SEES ARE VERSED IN THIS AREA
EXPERTS IN THIS AREA AND THEY
WORK HAND IN HAND WITH THOSE
PROGRAM DIRECTORS. YOU REALLY
SEE CAN WE DO THIS AS A MINOR
CREEK MORE VISION OR DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE A MAJOR CURRICULUM
VISIONS AND THE MAJORITY OF TIME
IT'S MINOR. AND SO THEY DO NOT
HAVE TO PAY ANYTHING THAT'S
APPROVED BY THE NEC BROUGHT
FORTH AS OUR BOARD TO ACT AS A
CONSENT AGENDA ITEM. AND IT GOES
THROUGH THE CURRICULUM COMMITTEE
AT THEIR SCHOOL- WITHOUT. IT'S A
IT'S A GREAT PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE AND WE CAN
DEFINITELY IF THERE'S ANY
SPECIFIC PROGRAM DIRECTORS ARE
HAVING SOME PROBLEMS WITH THIS.
OR ANY SEES CAN REACH OUT TO
THEM AND HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT WE ARE
UPDATING OUR REGULATIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU AND MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR FEE IS CODIFIED IN STATE
LAWS THE MINIMUM IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON ON LOWERING THAT
MINIMUM- IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU GUYS DEEM AS NECESSARY
WE- WE- MOVE IN THE DIRECTION
THAT THE LEGISLATOR TELLS US
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS I'M
HERE ASKING IF NOT THE SUNSET SO
WE CAN HAVE FOUR MORE YEARS TO
DO THAT IT'S UP TO YOU GUYS TO
TELL US WHAT WE COULD DO. SO
WITH THAT IF YOU GUYS DECIDE TO
BE DECREASED IS NEEDED. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS BUT WHAT I CAN SHOW YOU.
WANTED TO USE A CONTROL OF OUR
BORDERS JANICE FOR LAST YEAR. WE
HAD FOR REGULARLY SCHEDULED
MEETINGS. AND THE MAJORITY OF
THE ITEMS THAT GO THROUGH GO AS
MINOR CREEK REVISIONS PROGRESS
FRIEND WITH. PROGRESS REPORTS
AND DO NOT HAVE A FEE ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM AT ALL. SO IT IS ONLY
A FEW. THAT COME THROUGH AS A
MAJOR CORPORATION THAT EVEN HAS
THAT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
FEE WITH THAT BECAUSE- ANY
SEASONS WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
THOSE PROGRAM DIRECTOR TO SAY.
YOU'RE JUST CHANGING THIS IF
YOU'RE JUST WORKING N THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT AS A MINOR
CORPORATION. GRAIL SPEAKING.
THANK THE- BIRTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU TO BERMAN
CALLINGS IN FURTHER COMMENTS
CONCERNS I SEE NO MIKE'S JUMPING
UP INTO THE AIR SO. LET'S NOW-
ACCEPT TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING BEGINNING
WITH WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY WISH TO TESTIFY BOARD
BUT THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING I SEE. NO MOVEMENT IN
THAT AREA LET'S NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING WE WILL.
BEGIN. MODERATOR. I PUT HIM TO
SLEEP.
MR MARTIN MISTER OR MS MODERATOR. IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR
ME. PERFECTLY. THANK YOU WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT IN Q. I AM TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE
PROCEED. LINE TWENTY SIX LINE
TWENTY SIX. WELL TRY LINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I PUT THEM ALL
TO SLEEP NINE FOUR ZERO. NINE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M
SORRY FIFTY SEVEN. HE. NINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME
IS WENDY HAMPER- AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL OF
NURSING AT. STATE UNIVERSITY IN
SAN MARCOS. I WOULD LIKE. TO
QUICK ISSUES. ONE IS THE COMMENT
REGARDING CLINICAL SIMULATION
WHICH HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
MORNING. ARE THESE THE CLINICAL
SIMULATION IS NOW A COMMON AND
ACCEPTABLE TO THE SECTION. BEEN
TESTED TICKET ONLY DURING THE
COPA NINETY PANDEMIC. IT HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO BE A VALUABLE
TEACHING STRATEGIES THAT ALIGN.
WITH AN EFFECTIVELY PREPARES FOR
DIRECT PATIENT CARE. THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO USE
VALIDATED. SIMULATION
EXPERIENCES ARE MORE DIRECT
PATIENT CARE HOURS. WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT THE BRN. DEVELOP
GUIDELINES THE POLICY THE PRE
LICENSURE PROGRAMS THAT ALIGN
WITH THE LACE AND NATIONAL
STANDARD. THE BOARD NEEDS TO
PROVIDE GUIDELINES AS TO THE
NUMBER OF DIRECTLY TO CARE
CLINICAL HOURS TOGETHER WITH THE
TYPE OF RELATION EXPERIENCE.
THAT ARE NEEDED FOR A PRACTICE
OF LAW THAT YOU PRE LICENSURE
ARE IN GRADUATE. MY SECOND
COMMENT IS ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
CONCURRENCY HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
HERE TODAY. ADVOCATES REQUIRED
TO HAVE CLINICAL AND CLASSROOM
LEARNING OCCURRED CONCURRENTLY.
WE BELIEVE THERE IS A NEED TO
COMMIT ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY TO
THIS REQUIREMENT ALLOWING PRE
LOADING OF CONTENT AS AN
ADDITIONAL OPTION ALONG WITH
CONCURRENT THE HEARING AIDS THE
MASTER. IT FLEXIBILITY YEAH HE
DID THE MAXIMIZE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT EXPERIENCE IT. OTHER
PROFESSION WITH THE MEDICINE
ONBOARD REQUIRED THE COURT
HEARING. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ABSOLUTELY RIGHT HM
EVIDENCE OF CONCURRENCY
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE REFERRED TO
BY LORD AND ALL THE I WOULD
DEFINITELY LIKE TO BE PROVIDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
MODERATOR. THANK YOU NINE FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF
NURSE ANESTHETISTS FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU YOUR STAFF ON
PICKET HEARING TODAY SECONDLY WE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO BE ON.
BOARD NOT THE KIND THAT ADD ON
WE THINK THAT THEY PROVIDE A
VERY VALUABLE ON ANY NEEDED ON-
PROGRAM TO THE COMMUNITY TO.
PUBLIC PROTECTION AS WELL AS TO
THE INDUSTRY- WE REALLY WHEN I
THINK I THINK ABOUT MR MEL B.
AND HER STAFF FOR EVERYTHING
ACCEPTABLE TO ADD. ON THE ONLY
BEING AVAILABLE AND HAPPY TO
GUIDE A COUPLE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU CAN I CAN HAPPEN AND ANY
QUESTIONS. THANKYOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF CRIPPLING
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON THE COMMENTS ON THAT
YOU'RE THE ITEM THAT WAS
MENTIONED TODAY ANOTHER ONE OF
THE AUDITORS NOTED OVERSIGHT BY
THE B. R. IN THIRD VERY
DIFFERENT PURPOSES THAN NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION. WE ARE IN A
GOVERNMENT ENTITY WITH A
STATUTORY MANDATE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC WE'RE AT A CREDITORS.
FROM FIFTEEN. GRAND IN A BID
RELATION. THE B. R. N. HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CLOSE OUT THAT
STANDARD NURSING PROGRAM AND
TAKE IMMEDIATE. IMMEDIATE ACTION
WHEREAS IF YOU'RE NOT. NATIONAL
PRESERVATION DOES NOT CONSIDER
COMMUNITY REGIONAL OR STATEWIDE
LABOR MARKET NEEDS. ALTHOUGH YOU
MAY BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE- THE PROGRAM ARE NOT
WE- ARE IN A GOOD SPOT. HAPPY ON
REGULATED EXPANSION OF PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT PLAYGROUNDS. 70% OF
CALIFORNIA'S NURSING PROGRAMS
FOR PUBLIC PROGRAMS IN OUR
NETWORK PASSWORD LEFT WAS NINETY
POINT EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT. WHEN
COMPARED THAT TO FLORIDA WHERE
80% OF THEIR NURSING PROGRAMS
ARE PROVIDED AND THERE IN FACT
PASS RATE WAS ONLY UP SIXTY
EIGHT POINT EIGHTY THREE
PERCENT. ORDER ONLY ANALYSIS
NOTED PUBLIC PROGRAM PASS RATES
WERE ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
WHERE THE PRIVATE PROGRAMS- WELL
BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE IN
THE MEANTIME. WE NEED TO GO OUT
. OKAY LICENSOR. I YEAH THAT'S
GOING TO LICENSE YOUR CAR. I
WOULD BOTH PEOPLE UNITS
AVAILABLE TO RECEIVE CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER DID YOU KNOW HE HAD BEEN
AROUND FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS YES THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
HAS LED TO GREATER. VISIBILITY
MY PREVIOUS LEVEL PLUS. DURING
THE COMBAT UNDER MINE PROTECTION
BY BEING HEALTHY AND ABILITY TO
SET AND- I HAVE YOUR- YOUR KNEES
UPWARD MOBILITY. NURSES WHO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CALIFORNIA LPN TO
RN OPTION OR THE MILITARY OPTION
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR LIKE
WINTER UNDER THE CONTRACT.
LASTLY FILIATION UNIT OPPOSED TO
THE SUBSTITUTION OF CLINICAL
LEARNING WITH ACTUAL PATIENTS
FILLING IN THE HIGH FIDELITY
SIMULATION LABORATORY BEYOND
WHAT IS CURRENTLY ALLOWED THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED MANIC AND
COULD NOT REPLICATE THE HUMAN
RESPONSE TO NURSING CARE OR
INDICATE THE SUBTLE CHANGES THAT
CAN OCCUR. DURING THE COURSE OF
MANY ELEMENTS. A MENTOR IT ALL
TIME WE PATIENTS AND ACTUALLY.
DO SHOULD BE EDUCATED SO THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO DEVELOP SKILLS
AND CRITICAL THINKING ABILITY
RATHER SIMPLY BEING TRACKED YEAH
- I WILL CHOOSE ONE MORE COMMENT
INCLUDE NEWS MELBY MENTIONED IT
IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE BURIED IN
CLINICAL EDUCATION DELIVER. SO
THAT NURSING STUDENTS CAN BRING
WALKING AND EXPERIENCES FROM
CLINICAL BACK. EVERY COMPONENT
OR DISINFECT OCCASION AN
EXPANSION OF THEIR KNOWLEDGE
BASE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUY THESE
PRODUCTS. AND IR BEFORE YOU
CLICK OFF- YOU BROKE UP DURING A
PORTION OF YOUR TESTIMONY SO I
SUSPECT THAT'S YOUR TESTIMONY IS
WRITTEN DOWN SO I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU SUBMIT THAT TO. BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
SENATE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR OUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. BUT
RETURNING TO INDONESIA. THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS DR CAN
YOU HELP ME AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CFU DIRECTOR OF
NURSING REGARDING FACULTY AND
CLINICAL APPROVAL. WE HOLD THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS FOR NURSING
EDUCATION AND PRACTICE IN OUR
TWENTY NURSING PROGRAM AND WE
WISH TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
REDUNDANT PAPERWORK AND LEVEL OF
APPROVAL THAT WOULD NOT GO TO
JIFFY CLINICAL PLACEMENT AND
FACULTY APPROVALS FROM B. R. N.
IT IS THE NURSING DIRECTORS AND
THEIR FACULTY WHO ARE
REPONSIBLE FOR ADMINISTERING
PROGRAMS TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE IRAN REGULATIONS. WHILE
ALSO PREPARING FUTURE NURSING
WORKFORCE. CURRENTLY THE NURSING
PROGRAMS CAN NOT YOU KNOW LIKE
CLINICAL EXPERIENCES. WITHOUT
PRIOR. APPROVAL THE SAME IS TRUE
FOR NEW FACULTY HIRED TO TEACH.
OR CLINICAL COURSEWORK. PROGRAMS
OFTEN HIRE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF CLINICAL FACULTY EVERY YEAR
AND SOMETIMES THIS HAS TO BE AT
THE LAST MINUTE. POLITICAL
CURRENCY IT ALSO NARROWLY
DEFINED AS ACUTE CARE OFTEN
DISMISSING THE CLINIC AND
OUTPATIENT SETTING WHERE MANY
ADVANCED PRACTICE NURSES WORK.
THE CSU STRONGLY ADVOCATE FOR
LAST THIRTY SOME PROCESSES WHICH
WE DID NOT. ADD NOTHING
UNNECESSARY PAPERWORK IF YOU'RE
IN NEED TO RE DEFINE THE PROCESS
FOR FACULTY AND CLINICAL SITE
APPROVAL. AND ELIMINATE
REDUNDANT PAPERWORK IN PUBLIC
APPROVAL I CAN DELAY IN HIRING
AND THE CLINICAL THANK
ONBOARDING PROCESSES. WE
UNDERSTAND THERE NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND A CHECK AND
BALANCE. IT CAN PUT IN PLACE. WE
SUGGEST GIVING UP AND GUIDE TO
FOLLOW THANK YOU PLACE MUST BE
WITH. AGENT HOT THAT ARE
LICENSED IN CAL HEALTHCARE. BUT
THE ISSUE ONLY PARTNERS WITH
CONTRACTED AGENCIES AND
HOSPITALS THAT ARE LICENSED
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. OF NOTE. THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF STATE BOARDS
OF NURSING MEMBER PROFILE DATA.
EIGHT THAT 78% OF THE BOARD OF
NURSING DO NOT ACCRUE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMMENTS THE MODERATOR NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU NINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DEBRA WILSON I AM THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE NURSING
PROGRAMS AT CSU BAKERSFIELD AND
SPEAKING ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CSU DIRECTORS OF NURSING. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK REGARDING
ALLOWING NURSING PROGRAMS TO
REVISE CERTAIN CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS DURING
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE ACADEMIC YEAR.
EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY TO FIFTEEN
THIRTY TO ALLOW SUPPORTERS BOARD
NURSING EDUCATION CONSULTANTS TO
APPROVE A REQUEST FROM APPROVED
NURSING PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
CERTAIN CLINICAL EXPERIENCE
REQUIREMENTS HOWEVER IT EXPIRES
AT THE END OF THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ACADEMIC YEAR. MANY
NURSING AND PROGRAMS ARE
EXPECTED TO EXPERIENCE THE SAME
LEVEL OF DIFFICULTY IN SECURING
VARIOUS CLINICAL PLACEMENT
ESPECIALLY IN THE NURSING
SPECIALTY AREAS LIKE PEDIATRIC
AND PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH
NURSING IN THE NEXT ACADEMIC
YEAR. HOUSE WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN
THE PAST TWO YEARS THIS IS DUE
TO CLINICAL PLACEMENT SITES
LIMITING AND RESTRICTING THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS PLACED IN A
FACILITY UNDER CLINICAL FACULTY
SUPERVISION. THE PANDEMIC. BACK
TO THE STUDENT RATE RATIOS WERE
TYPICALLY ONE TO TWELVE PROVIDES
A TEN FOOT CAN HELP MAKE MOST
CLINICAL SITES HAVE LIMITED
THEIR CLINICAL PLACEMENT- RATIOS. TWO ONE SIX EIGHT FOUR ONE TWO
SIX I'VE EVEN EXPERIENCED AS LOW
AS ONE TO FOUR IN THE
PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH AREA.
THE SECRETIVE AND FACULTY TO
STUDENT RATIO ARE EXTREMELY
COSTLY AND DRIVE UP THE NUMBER
OF FLIGHTS NEEDED TO PROGRESS.
THIRTY STUDENTS IN THEIR STUDY.
THIS ISSUE IS THERE ANY COST HOW
. THE LIMITED NUMBER OF SITES IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BEYOND THE
CAMPUS OF CONTROL. ADDITIONALLY
IN ORDER TO. FOR A REQUEST FOR A
REVISED A CLINICAL EXPERIENCE
REQUIREMENT TO RECEIVE APPROVAL
CURRENT REGULATIONS REQUIRE
NURSING PROGRAMS TO CONTACT
EVERY POSSIBLE CLINICAL FACILITY
AND A TWENTY FIVE MILE RADIUS TO
VERIFY THAT THERE IS NO
AVAILABILITY FOR STUDENT
PLACEMENTS. THIS PROCESS IS AN
UNNECESSARY BURDEN FOR THE
NURSING PROGRAMS. OUR FOCUS
NEEDS TO BE UNSUCCESSFULLY
TRAINING NURSING STUDENTS IN A
TIMELY MANNER. WE UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
REGARDING CHECKS AND BALANCES-
BUT THE NURSING PROGRAMS HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO ADMINISTER
PROGRAMS FCPA COMPLIANCE WHILE
ALSO PREPARING THE SEARCH
FEATURE NURSING WORKFORCE THE
CSU STRONGLY ADVOCATES FOR A
LESS BURDEN BURDENSOME PROCESS.
WHICH DOES NOT ADD UNNECESSARY
AND TIME INTENSIVE PAPERWORK OR
CALLING EVERY CLINICAL PLACEMENT
FIGHT WITHIN A TWENTY FIVE MILE
RADIUS TO NO AVAIL. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBER THERE BUT
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK
TO BE ARE AND HAVE BEEN DONE THE
PHILOSOPHY THAT REVIEW HEARING.
SOMEONE OFFER A FEW COMMENTS OR
ANY CONCERNS ALL TYPES OF
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN BOTH URAN AND
RURAL AREAS HAVE TO BE YOUR
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES PARTICULARLY
IN NURSING WHICH I'VE ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE COLD AT
NINETEEN POINT THAT MIGHT. BE A
DISTRICT RELY EAVILY ON GROWING
THEIR FUTURE WORKFORCE TO ENSURE
AND PRESERVE ARCTIC HERE IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR MANY DISTRICTS IN
THE R. AND INCONSISTENT
APPLICATION OF REGULATION
WORKERS OFTEN LOCKED
OPPORTUNITIES TO STAND UP NEW
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. OR EXPAND
EXISTING PROGRAM WITH 50% THE
HARBOR THERE IS VERY LITTLE
FLEXIBILITY TO STAND UP PROGRAMS
IN UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITY.
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS ARE
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING THE
CREATION OF PROPERLY TRAINED
WORKFORCE BUT YOU NEED
REGULATIONS I CAN BETTER ABOUT
NOT ALL COMMUNITIES AND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS OR EVEN
THE REPORT. FOR EXAMPLE SMALL
RURAL HOSPITALS MAY NOT MEET THE
REGULAR REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED
BY THE R. AND THEREFORE CANNOT
RECEIVE CLINICAL PLACEMENT EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE IN DESPERATE
NEED OF NURSE BUT- WE BELIEVE
THAT TO MEET THE ONGOING DEMAND
WE NEED TO EXTEND FLEXIBILITY IN
AREAS SUCH AS SIMULATED OUR-
CURRENCY AND BURGER REQUIREMENT.
ADDITIONALLY WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
BE OUR ETHNIC THE DIRECTOR'S
HANDBOOK WIDELY AVAILABLE TO
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS REALLY
RIGHT THEMSELVES WITH THE
ONGOING REQUIREMENTS AS THEY
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS NURSING
SHORTAGES AND THEIR ABILITY. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS. THE
BUILDING A SUSTAINABLE AND MORE
ABOUT NURSING WORKFORCE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND. YOUR TIME MODERATOR NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE
FURTHER. THING YOU AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU THE MODERATOR. ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTION
COME IN OR- I SEE. NO MIKE. IN
THE AIR SO. WE'LL WRAP UP THIS
PORTION OF. PRESIDENT TRUJILLO
AND MISS MEL B. THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU AND- THE MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING DO
FOR ALL OF THE REST OF US- SINCE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION-
MISS MEL B. YOU GET TODAY. TODAY
OF FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. AND
PUTTING A TWIST ON IT AND
PUTTING UP WITH ME SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT IRAQ. THANK YOU
SENATOR RON. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW BEGIN A REVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL AND WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME. DR JEFFREY FOREMAN
BOARD CHAIR- AND I THINK I WILL
LET THE REST OF YOUR GROUP-
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FOR THE
RECORD PLEASE. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ROTH CHAIRMAN BERMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM DOCTOR JEFFREY FOUR MINUTES
WAS JUST STATED AND IT'S NOT AN
EXAGGERATION TO SAY THAT THE
ADVANCEMENT OF THE MASSAGE
THERAPY PROFESSION AS HEALTH
CARE AND FOR PAIN CONTROL AND
STRESS REDUCTION HAS BEEN MY
LIFE'S WORK. I'M FORMER
PROFESSOR AT THE ANZA COLLEGE IN
CUPERTINO CALIFORNIA AND- IN
THAT CAPACITY I DEVELOPED THE
FIRST COMMUNITY COLLEGE MASSAGE
THERAPY PROGRAMS AND THE FIRST
DEGREE IN MASSAGE THERAPY IN
CALIFORNIA AND A FEW DIFFERENT
CERTIFICATES. I AM PRESENTLY THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL M. BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC I WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE
SCHOOL ADVISORY COMMITTEE ALL OF
OUR- C. M. D. C. OF APPROVED
SCHOOLS. A UNIQUE. C. M. D. C.
IS ONE OF THE GREATEST SUCCESS
STORIES OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE A UNIQUE NONPROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATION THAT
ENCOURAGES COLLABORATION BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND KEY
STAKEHOLDERS C. A. M. P. C. WAS
CREATED BY LEGISLATION SIGNED IN. TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
IMPLEMENTED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. THE TITLE PROTECTION
PROGRAM ALLOWS THE USE OF THE
TERM CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST
AND CERTIFIED MASSAGE
PRACTITIONER. THE HOLDER OF THIS
CERTIFICATE IS WELL VETTED
MASSAGE PROFESSIONAL WHO'S BEEN
EDUCATED IT IS C. A. M. P. C.
YOU APPROVE SCHOOL. IN IS
IDENTIFIED BY THIS CERTIFICATE
NUMBER AND THEIR ABILITY TO
PRACTICES TIED TO THEM
CONFORMING TO LEGAL BEHAVIOR.
LICENSURE FOR MASSAGE THERAPY
WAS CONSIDERED. IN THE
COMPREHENSIVE DISCUSSION OF THE
INITIAL LEGISLATION AND HAS BEEN
SUBSEQUENTLY DEBATED AND
REJECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE
SEVERAL TIMES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE. IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN INDEPENDENT
FEASIBILITY STUDY SAID
SPECIFICALLY THE C. A. M. P. C.
IS A SUPERIOR MODEL TO LICENSURE
. THE REASONS ARE EASILY
DELINEATED LICENSURE IS MORE
EXPENSIVE A RECENT FEES STUDY
DONE OUR SHOWS THAT LICENSURE
WOULD BE FIVE TIMES MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR- ARE THE MASSAGE
THERAPIST IN WOULD ACTUALLY
EXCEED A THOUSAND DOLLARS. AS
WAS SO ABLY WRITTEN BY THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CONSULTANT C. A. M. P. C. IS
ABLE TO ACCESS REMOTELY FLEXIBLY
AND INEXPENSIVELY IN ITS
OPERATIONS. ACTUALLY WHEN
COMPARED TO AN ALL I GUESS
BOARDS UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. MANY DCA
BOARDS AROUND THE VERGES OF
INSOLVENCY AT THIS POINT IN TIME
RECIENTE C. HAS A BALANCED
BUDGET AND MORE THAN SIX MONTHS
OF CASH RESERVES. PERFORMANCE
METRICS D. C. A. BOARDS WE'VE
COMPARED THEM CAN'T EVEN COME
CLOSE TO C. A. M. P. C.'S
ABILITY TO SWIFTLY ANSWER PHONE
CALLS ASSIST CERTIFICATE HOLDERS
ISSUED NEW AND RENEWAL
CERTIFICATES IN DISCIPLINE
VIOLATORS OF THE ETHICAL AND
LEGAL STANDARDS OF PRACTICING
CARE. PERHAPS THE DIFFERENCE IS
NEVER MORE STRONGLY REALIZED
THEN IN A STATEMENT BY OUT OF
STATE INSURANCE COMPANIES IN
ADVOCATING FOR LICENSURE THEY-
BEHIND THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND PROSTITUTION I'M NOT THE
BUSINESS OF A BODY REGULATING
MASSAGE. C. A. M. P. C.
CONSIDERS THE EFFORTS TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING TO BE THE CORE
OF ITS MISSION AND MANDATE FROM
THE LEGISLATURE. WE ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO CLOSE SCHOOLS THAT
PROVIDE THE DIPLOMAS. THAT ARE
PAID FOR AND NO EDUCATION IS
PROVIDED THAT HE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS UTILIZE THIS. THIS
AVENUE TO TRY TO LEGITIMIZE
THEIR- WORKERS THE C. A. M. P.
C. SCHOOL APPROVAL PROCESS IS A
MODEL THAT MANY STATES ARE
INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE
ABOUT AND POTENTIALLY ADOPTING.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THE
SUPPORT FOR C. A. M. P. C. IS
FAR REACHING AND DEEPLY ROOTED.
THE STRONGEST ADVOCATES FOR C.
A. M. D. C. R. GROUPS SUCH AS
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND SISTERS OF
CHARITY OF THE BLESSED VIRGIN.
WHO SUBSCRIBE TO COMMENTS BY THE
SAN FRANCISCO COLLABORATIVE
AGAINST HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THAT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING A PARTICULARLY
WELL SERVED BY C. A. M. P. C.'S
OVERSIGHT. AND REGULATION. CMT
C. IS SUPPORTED BY MAJOR
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATES SUCH AS
MASSAGE ENVY M. BURKE WILLIAMS.
WHO SUPPORT THE SENSIBILITY
INSTRUCTURE BRINGS TO THEIR
BUSINESSES. AND C. A. M. P. C.
IS SUPPORTED BY POLICE CHIEFS
RANK AND FILE OFFICERS. AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WHO SUPPORT
DUE PROCESS YET STRONGLY SUPPORT
C. A. M. D. C. TO DO WHAT DCA
BOARDS CAN'T. AND THAT IS
QUICKLY QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY
DISCIPLINE THOSE WHO BREAK THE
LAW. WE ALSO COLLABORATE CLOSELY
AS WITH CITIES AND COUNTIES
HELPING THEM UPDATE THEIR
MASSAGE ORDINANCES. C. A. M. D.
C. HAS ELEVATED THE PROFESSION
IN CALIFORNIA WHEN I FIRST BEGAN
pTEACHING MASSAGE THERAPY IT WAS
IN MANY COMMUNITIES CONSIDERED
IN THE AREA OF ADULT
ENTERTAINMENT. IN MY GRADUATES
WERE FORCED TO TAKE VD TESTS. WE
HAVE THOSE JACKIE JUST OVER
THANK GOODNESS BECAUSE C. M. D.
C. HAS ELEVATED OUR STATUS AND
WE ARE NOW CONSIDERED LEGITIMATE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS IN FACT
I WAS ABLE TO GET MY CODE
NINETEEN VACCINE WITH HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS DUE TO THE HARD
WORK OF THE CFTC STAFF. AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I'M HERE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE A AND- THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS.
THANK YOU THAT FUHRMAN DO. ANY
OF YOUR OTHER COUNCIL
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE ANY
COMMENTS TO OFFER BEFORE I TURN
IT OVER TO MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. YES MARTIN'S ZERO MY
TECHNOLOGY AND- GENEROSITY. IN
GERMAN BERMAN AND- THE COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
I'LL TRY TO MAKE MY COMMENTS-
BRIEFS- BUT I THINK I'M UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED TO TALK ABOUT THE
SUBJECT MATTER JUST A QUICK
BACKGROUND ON ME- I SPENT THIRTY
YEARS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M A
LICENSED ATTORNEY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M CURRENTLY THE
COUNTY EXECUTIVE FOR THE COUNTY
OF SAN MATTEO. I AM A C. A M. T.
C. BOARD MEMBER. AND AS A POLICE
CAPTAIN I SPENT A YEAR UNDER
COVER. INFILTRATING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATION THAT
RESULTED IN THE TAKE DOWN OF
SEVERAL MONTHS SOLID COLORS THAT
WERE ACTING ILLEGALLY. I'M ALSO
UNIQUELY QUALIFIED TO TALK ABOUT
THE SUBJECT MATTER BECAUSE AS A
DEPUTY CHIEF I STOOD IN THE
HALLWAY OUTSIDE THE CHAMBERS.
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO LEGISLATOR
INSTITUTING THE C. A. M. P. C.
AND I WAS REPRESENTING CAL
CHIEFS AT THAT TIME. I AM HERE
TO TELL YOU. I WAS WRONG. IN ALL
OF YOU. RIGHT CERTAINLY YOUR
PREDECESSORS WERE RIGHT ON THIS-
IT WAS INGENIOUS- TO CREATE A
NEW STRUCTURE THAT WAS MINIMAL
YOU CAN FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
FACING WITH THE MASSAGE
INDUSTRY. THAT HAD LITERALLY
BEEN BY CRIMINALS THAT CREATED.
A PIPELINE FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. I GOT TO WITNESS
HIS FIRST UP. IN A TELL YOU IT
WAS SEEM LESS. THAN TRAGIC. BY
CREATING THE C. A. ANTI CD- YOU
ALL CREATED IN A NIBBLE LEAD
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU GO TO THE
VERY HEART OF THE PROBLEM IN A
WAY THAT NO STATE BOARD NO CITY
IN NO COUNTY COULD EVER DO. AND
I SAY THE CREATION OF THE C. M.
D. C. WAS INGENIOUS. BECAUSE HE
CREATED A FLEXIBLE STRUCTURE
THAT FINALLY FINALLY ALLOWED THE
STATE TO ADDRESS THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT THAT HAD INFILTRATED.
THE MASSAGE INDUSTRY IN IT
ALLOWED US TO DO IT IN A
COORDINATED AND COMPREHENSIVE
WAY. THE PROCESS IN PLACE NOW-
THE D. C. M. D. C. OUR HOUSE
ALLOWS FOR DENIALS IN DISCIPLINE
A BAD ACTORS IN A QUICK FASHION
AND THAT IS ABSOLUTELY KEY.
BECAUSE WHITES ARE AT STAKE. IN
FINANCIAL GAME FOR CRIMINALS IS
JUST TOO GREAT WITHOUT THAT
SWEPT IN DECISIVE ACTION. IN
FACT I'M A MEMBER OF THE STATE
BAR. AND- I HAVE LOOKED AT MANY
OTHER- LICENSURE ASSOCIATIONS.
AND WHAT TAKES THEM YEARS TO DO
IN THE AREA OF DISCIPLINE YEARS
WE CNT SEE USUALLY DOES AN
AVERAGE OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE DAYS. THIS ALSO US DCA MP
C. TO GO OUT THE TRAFFICKING
PIPELINE. THESE WERE THE SHAM
SCHOOLS IN THE DIPLOMA MILLS
WERE LOCATED. IT WAS INCREDIBLE
THE AMOUNT OF- WORK IT TOOK TO
ROUTE THOSE OUT AND- IT
CERTAINLY. WAS WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO
STOPPING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PIPELINE. BUT THE PROCESS OF
DEALING WITH THE SAME SCHOOLS
AND THE ORGANIZATIONS COULD NOT
BE REPLICATED BY CITIES COUNTIES
OR STATE BOARDS. IN THERE IT
REALLY HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
IMPACTFUL THINGS THAT WE'VE
DONE- IN IN- IN OUR TEN YEAR TO
ELIMINATE THAT PIPELINE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. SO AFTER COUCHES
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
UNION G. C. WHICH WE LOST
TONIGHT AND I WAS EDUCATED THANK
GOODNESS WE DID LOSE AT THAT
TIME. THE LEAGUE OF CITIES PUT
ME ON THE C. A. M. P. C. BOARD
AS THEIR REPRESENTATIVE- I MEAN
I WAS TRULY THERE TO WAGE A WAR
AGAINST THE C. A. M. P. C.
BECAUSE- CERTAINLY DIDN'T
BELIEVE THAT I COULD DO WHAT
REPORTED TO DO. AND AND I WAS
WRONG AGAIN- I GOTTA TELL YOU
THAT- I WAS SO PROUD TO FIND OUT
THE DATE- REPRESENTED MY
GREATEST DESIRE AND THAT WAS
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE WORK
TOGETHER TO BRING ABOUT THE
RULES AND REGULATIONS. THAT
WOULD PROMOTE THIS PUBLIC SAFETY
SO I QUICKLY REALIZED THAT THE
CMT C. WAS EMBARKING DOWN THE
PATH THAT CITIES AND LICENSING
BOARDS IN COUNTIES COULD NEVER
ACCOMPLISH. AND THAT WAS TO
BRING ABOUT COORDINATION
COLLABORATION ENFORCEMENT OF
STATEWIDE RULES TO THE HEALING
ART PROFESSION. AS I MENTIONED-
THAT WAS A GREAT THING THAT THE
LEGISLATOR DID AND NOW IT LOOKS
LIKE WE ARE LOOKING FOR A
SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM
IN THERE IS NO PROBLEM. I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU THIS IS THE BEST
AFTER FORTY YEARS IN THIS
BUSINESS THIS IS THE BEST
POSSIBLE. SOLUTION AND YOU ARE
CREATED- SO I TELL YOU THAT I.
SO MY IN FAVOR OF THIS AND I'M
PROUD OF WHAT THIS LEGISLATOR
DID IN CREATING THE C. M. D. C.
AND I'M PROUD TO BE ON THE
DIVERSE SPORT. NOW REPRESENTING
C. SACK- THIS BOARD IS PROVIDING
DEGREE OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND
BORDER THAT IS REALLY
UNPARALLELED. THE C. M. D. C.
BOARD MEANS ARE TRANSPARENT
OPEN. WE HAVE A VIGOROUS
DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE PERFORMANCE
METRICS IN PLACE- WE ARE FOCUSED
ON CUSTOMER SERVICE AND I THINK
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY KEY BECAUSE
OUR CUSTOMERS. ARE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. AND IN FACT WE HAVE
CUSTOMER SERVICE AGENTS ON. LINE
READY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. IN
SECONDS THAT I KNOW OF NO OTHER
AGENCY THAT DOES THAT. WE ARE
SOLVENT WITH THAT AS MENTIONED
BEFORE SIX MONTHS OF RESERVES IN
A BALANCED BUDGET- IN IT I CAN
TELL YOU WOULD BE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ANY LICENSING
BOARD. TO ACHIEVE THAT WITH OUR-
INCREDIBLE BUT WITHOUT AN
INCREDIBLE INCREASE IN
INTERVIEWS. AND WE LISTEN AND
CERTAINLY WE'RE NOT PERFECT BUT
WE'RE WILLING TO LISTEN IN ORDER
TO GET BETTER I THINK THAT'S THE
KEY MARKET ANY. AGENCY SO RIGHT
NOW EVERYONE IS ROWING IN THE
SAME DIRECTION. WE ARE THERE. WE
THERE USED TO BE TO SEE. AND
DOUG- IN THE WORK. WE'RE GONNA
IN GREAT CHAOS IN THE
ENFORCEMENT WHICH I. WORKED ON
FIRST HAND THERE IS NOW EXTREME
COOPERATION AND COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION. AND THERE YOU
WILL HAVE OTHER SPEAK AGAINST-
THE C. M. D. C. I'M SURE. BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU TO LOOK AT
THEIR MOTIVATION THAT IS KEY
BECAUSE OUR MOTIVATION CAN'T BE
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY WHICH I
THINK IS PARAMOUNT FOR THE
CONSUMERS AND THE THERAPIST. WHO
WANT TO OPERATE IN GENERAL
BUSINESS. IN MY OPINION CHANGED
THE MODEL THAT YOU ALL CREATED
WOULD SEND US BACK TWENTY PLUS
YEARS TOOK PLACE WE NEVER WANT
TO GO BACK TO. AND THOUGH- I'VE
HAD MANY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN
THIS AREA I DON'T SPEAK FOR
MYSELF. I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC AGENCY THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ENTITIES THAT I HAVE REPRESENTED
IN THE PAST. YEARS AND NOW- I
REPRESENT- IT IS A COUNTY
EXECUTIVE C. SACK. IN FACT- I'VE
NEVER IN MY TENURE- SEEN SUCH A
DIVERSE COALITION OF GROUPS COME
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT ANYTHING.
ANYTHING WE'VE GOT THE POLICE TO
SURE UP THE DA'S NGOS CODE
COMPLIANCE- DOES IN THE MISSILE
DUES IS ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INDUSTRIES. CITIES AND COUNTIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ALL WORKING
TOGETHER FOR THE FIRST TIME ON
ON THIS ISSUE AND WE ARE MAKING
PROGRESS. C. N. T. HAVE BROUGHT
ALL THESE GROUPS TOGETHER TO
WORK THROUGH COLLABORATION ON
ISSUE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING WHICH
HAS PLAGUED THIS. INDUSTRY FOR
DECADES. WE ARE MAKING A GREAT
DIFFERENCE THROUGH PRIDE- BITE
INTO. MO USE AND SHARING OF
INFORMATION AND EDUCATION OF
THOSE BOOTS ON THE GROUND. WHEN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES FOUND SWIFT
AND DECISIVE ACTIONS ARE TAKEN.
AND WE ARE FORTUNATE CRIMINALS.
OUT OF THIS HI JACK HEALING
PROFESSION. AND IT IS B. BECAUSE
HE AND HE DELIVERS ON WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY SET OUT TO DO.
AND THAT IS TO TAKE BACK THE
MASSAGE INDUSTRY FROM THE
CRIMINALS. THERE ARE SO MANY
GOOD PEOPLE IN THIS INDUSTRY BUT
IT WAS LITERALLY. YOU SHOULD ALL
BE CONGRATULATED. FOR INNOVATION
AND CREATIVITY IN DEVELOPING AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS A RATHER
CANYON HUMAN TRAFFICKING. IN THE
CRIMINAL ELEMENT FROM THE DISK
FROM HIS HEALING ARTS PROFESSION
WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
UNPARALLELED CUSTOMER SERVICE.
AN INTERIM WHILE ALSO BEING
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE IN DOING SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS SIR- ANY OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL WHICH TO MAKE REMARKS
BEFORE I GO TO MEMBERS. GERMAN
ROSS AND JIM BERMAN I'M I'M
LISTENING TO MEL I'M THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL. I'M DELIGHTED TO BE
HERE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME SIR. ANY OTHER ONE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. YES THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALLISON
SIEGEL I AM SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL I AM ALSO HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. OF OUR
COMMITTEES HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL CHAIR BERMAN THANK YOU
JERRY ROSS I KNOW AFTER THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION WE HAD ON B.
R. AND R. CALL I GUESS NUMBER
ONE IS RUNNING A LITTLE LATE I
WANNA KICK IT TO HER FOR
QUESTIONS HE HAS AND THEN I'LL
FOLLOW UP THANKS SERVER BERLIN
PLEASE PROCEED. THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND- CENTER ROCK I
JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THE CEO OF- C. A. N. T.
C. WAS PAID THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH
AN ADDITIONAL 8% ANNUAL RAISE
BEING DESCRIBED THIS CAST BY THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. CAN WE HAVE
THE EITHER THE ATTORNEY OR THE-
BOARD MEMBER- EXPLAIN WHY THEY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
REASONABLE SALARY CONSIDERING
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS STATED THE MEDIAN SALARY
FOR A SIMILAR. REGULATORY AGENCY
EXECUTIVE. THE AGENCY USES
AROUND A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
THOUSAND AND I DID SEE THAT.
THEY WERE COMPARING TO CEOS OF
THE- CHAMBR AND- THE- MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. I DON'T THINK
THAT'S NECESSARILY. APPROPRIATE
COMPARISON BUT MAYBE I'M MISSING
SOMETHING. ANY TAKERS. YES YEAH
I THINK YOU'RE ON MUTE CAN YOU
PLEASE ANSWER. I THINK YOU'RE
STILL ON MUTE SIR M. I. CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW PERFECTLY PLEASE
PROCEED. C. M. D. C. WORKS
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL BUT NONE OF
THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT WE'VE
ACHIEVED JUST HAPPENED THEY COME
FROM SOMEWHERE C. A. M. P. C. IT
ALL STARTS WITH THE STRONG
LEADERSHIP OF OUR C. E. L. IS A
TRUE VISIONARY WHO GUIDES THE
ORGANIZATION WITH A DEFT HAND.
WHILE MUCH HAS BEEN MADE ALL OF
HIS COMPENSATION I IT'S
POLITICAL THEATER TO ME BECAUSE
THE BOARD KNOWS WHAT THIS MAN
HAS BEEN PAID AND IS BEING PAID
YEAH WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE GETTING
WE GET IT WE HAVE A TIRELESS
WORKER. WHO WORKS ON HIS
VACATION. I'VE HE'S CALLED. ANY
DAY OF THE WEEK DAY OR NIGHT
THIS MAN WORKS AND- AND I. HE'S
VERY QUALIFIED HE HAS BEEN IN
THE INDUSTRY SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE AS A THERAPIST
INSTRUCTOR AND ENTREPRENEUR. HE
BEGAN WORKING ON THE REGULATORY
ASPECT OF MASSAGE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO. AND HE UNDERSTANDS
THE ISSUES FACING THIS INDUSTRY.
A. N. MASAI'S PROFESSIONALS ED
HE EEPS THE ORGANIZATION ON
COURSE AND FOCUSED ON HIS
MISSION. HE IMPLEMENTS OUR
STRATEGIC PRIORITIES OF THE
BOARD. AND HE HAD THE
FORETHOUGHT FOR THOUGHT TO FOCUS
ON HMAN TRAFFICKING FROM THE
BEGINNING EVEN THOUGH THIS WAS
NOT A POPULAR MOTION WHEN C. A.
M. P. C. WAS STARTED. HE WORKS
COLLABORATIVELY WITH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ORGANIZATIONS FOR
NON GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS IN
ADDITION TO WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. HE'S CREATED AND
STRENGTHEN RELATIONSHIPS WITH
CITIES COUNTIES AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ADVOCATED FOR
STRONGER INFORMATION. SHARING
PROVISIONS IN THE LAW WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO PROMOTE
OUR COMBINED INTERESTS. HE HAS
WORKED WITH MULTIPLE COUNTY DA'S
TO STRENGTHEN COLLABORATION
RESULTING IN MEMBER- A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING WITH
THESE ORGANIZATIONS. HE WORKS
EVERY DAY TO ELEVATE THE
PROFESSION. HE UNDERSTANDS THAT
UNTIL PROSTITUTION IS SEPARATED
IN THE MINDS OF THE PUBLIC FROM
THE SIZE THE ENTIRE PROFESSION
WILL SUFFER. HE TOOK AN ACTIVE
ROLE IN ENSURING THE C. A. M. P.
C. PROVIDED ACCURATE AND TIMELY
INFORMATION FOR THE COVERT
PANDEMIC. I HAVE. COUNTLESS.
MEMORANDUMS WAS SENT OUT TO THE
C. A. M. P. C. MEMBERS OF S. THE
TICKET HOLDERS AND WE EVEN HAD
IT A NATIONAL SPEAKER DR MANY-
SPEAK ON A PANEL AND ROOF WARNER
SPEAK ON A PANEL- IT'S RING
QUESTIONS ABOUT COVERT FOR THE
PUBLIC. IN HIS COMPENSATION IS
IN LINE WITH WHAT A. M. P. A. M.
G. A. PAYS ITS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND WITH OTHER
SIMILARLY SIZED NONPROFITS PAY
IS C. E. O.'S. WE DID. HAD A
NATIONWIDE CONSULTING FIRM DO A
STUDY IN THIS. PACKAGE THAT HE
HAS IS WELL WITHIN IRS
GUIDELINES FOR NON PROFIT CEO
COMPENSATION. SEVEN NUMBER ONE
PHONE I JUST JUST BEEN OPENED
AND MAYBE IT'S YOU CAN'T BUY I
APPRECIATE THE- EXPLANATION BUT
I WILL SAY IT AGAIN THREE AND A
HALF ALMOST THREE AND A HALF
TIMES THE COMPENSATION FOR A
SIMILAR REGULATORY EXECUTIVES
AND- I I'M SURE A LOT OF THEM
ARE DOING VERY HARD WORK ON
DIFFICULT ISSUES ALSO SO. WHAT
YOU'RE MIXING APPLES AND ORANGES
HE HE HAS SIXTY EMPLOYEES. THAT
HE'S HE'S MANAGING OKAY HOW MANY
. DOES THAT OTHER BOARD HAVE.
HOW MUCH RESPONSIBILITY IS THAT
THOSE- THOSE PEOPLE HAVE. I
THINK THOSE ARE QUESTIONS WE CAN
CERTAINLY ANSWER SIR ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OF SOME OF OUR- ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS SIR. OKAY THANK YOU
MA'AM SURE BERMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MIGHT HAVE SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ON THAT
ISSUE LATER- ITEMS IN MR
CALLAGY- YEAH YOU AND I'VE HAD
THE CHANCE TO WORK TOGETHER FOR
THE LAST FIVE PLUS YEARS AND
IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT I THINK
YOU BEING WRONG ON ON THIS ISSUE
IS THE ONLY TIME I'VE EVER SEE
YOU BE WRONG- SO- THAT YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T GET EVERYTHING ABOUT A
HUNDRED. OR A THOUSAND. FROM ON
THE ISSUE OF- I BELIEVE IT WAS.
MR FORM MR FOREMAN WHO YOU SAID
YOU KNOW THAT THAT YOU'RE HAPPY
TO SEE MASSAGE THERAPISTS TO
FINALLY BE CONSIDERED LEGITIMATE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS WHICH
I COMPLETELY AGREE DO YOU
CONSIDER MASSAGE THERAPY TO BE
HEALING ART. YES I DO I AGREE
WITH THAT IT APPEARS FROM
STATUTE THAT THAT OF THIRTEEN
MEMBERS ON YOUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ONLY TO HAVE TO BE
ACTUAL MASSAGE THERAPISTS WHICH
IS QUITE DIFFERENT FROM OTHER
HEALING ARTS BOARDS IS THERE A
REASON WE SHOULD TREAT MASSAGE
THERAPY DIFFERENTLY. IN THIS
REGARD. THEIR MANAGER. PLEASE
SO- CPC HAS A BOARD OF THIRTEEN
MEMBERS. WE HAVE SIX MASSAGE
SERVICE IN SEVEN OUR MEMBERS
WERE NOT MASSAGE THERAPIST.
EIGHTEEN SEE YOU SEE. OF COURSE
ONCE THE INPUT OF THE MASSAGE
PROFESSION. THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
SIX MASSAGE THERAPIST ON THE
BOARD. OBVIOUS IT WAS VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUES A
MULTIFACETED ISSUE THIS IS WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT. TO HAVE. A
DIVERSE BACKGROUND. IN HAVE
GRASS WOULD BE PUT INTO THE
BOARDS SO WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES OF CITIES OR
COUNTIES OF POLICE CHIEFS- ENTER
YOUR TRAFFICKING REALIZATIONS
MASSAGE SCHOOLS- TO MASSAGE
ASSOCIATIONS- BUT THAT BEING
SAID. IF THE COMMITTEE KILLS
THERE- WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD AND
REASSESS IT. WE ARE ALWAYS THERE
TO- TO LISTEN AND THAT THE WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE WHAT MAKES
THE MOST SENSE IS. ONE MORE
ISSUE PERTAINING TO. THE SUBJECT
OF- OF. OUR PROFESSIONALS ON
REGULATORY BOARDS AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT THE- TO START THE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. U. S.
SUPREME COURT DECISION ON THAT
MATTER BETWEEN- THE NORTH
CAROLINA- BOARD OF DENTISTRY A.
N- AND THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION- I'M GONNA ASK
ALLISON SIEGEL MAYBE TO ADDRESS
ITS REAL QUICKLY. SURE ALMOST IS
REFERRING TO- NORTH CAROLINA
STATE BOARD OF DENTAL EXAMINERS
VERSES FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION
THIS ISSUE WAS RAISED IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER A TWENTY
FIFTEEN U. S. SUPREME COURT CASE
AND JUST GENERALLY THAT CASE
HELD THAT WHEN A STATE
REGULATORY BOARD FEATURES A
MAJORITY SHARE. OF ACTIVE MARKET
PARTICIPANTS ANY ALLEGEDLY ANTI
COMPETITIVE DECISION MAKING MAY
NOT BE SUBJECT TO PARKER
ANTITRUST LITIGATION IMMUNITY
UNLESS THERE IS QUOTE AN ACTIVE
STATE SUPERVISION TO AN END
QUOTE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
DELEGATED AUTHORITY IS BEING
EXECUTED IN THE INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC AND NOT THE PRIVATE
COMMERCIAL INTERESTS OF THEIR
MEMBERS. AND WHY THIS IS REALLY
A COMPLICATED LEGAL ISSUE AS TO
ITS APPLICABILITY TO SEEING TCD
THERE IS A CONCERN- THAT ABOARD
ISSUE CAN BE TOO HEAVILY
INDUSTRY MOTIVATED. AND HAVE A
MAJORITY OF INDUSTRY MEMBERS
THEREFORE THIS CONCERN REALLY
WEIGHS HEAVILY IN FAVOR OF
HAVING BOARDS THAT HAVE LESS
THAN A MAJORITY OF INDUSTRY
MEMBERS ON THEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER I DO MY
NOTES SHOW THAT THREE MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OR MASSAGE THERAPISTS-
SO MAYBE MY INFORMATION IS
OUTDATED- THE- THE MR NICK
NETANEL I BELIEVE YOU SAID SIX
MEMBERS ARE BECAUSE THEY'RE
DRESSED THAT'S CORRECT WE HAVE
SIX MASSAGE THERAPIST GREAT. ONE
UP IF YOU COULD- MAYBE PROVIDE
US WITH THE UPDATED LIST THE
BOARD MEMBERS OF THE FANTASTIC
APPRECIATE IT. SO COMPLETELY
AGREE ON ON THE VALUE OF
ENFORCEMENT BEING QUICK AND
NIMBLE GOD CAN YOU WALK ME
THROUGH THE COUNCIL'S
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS WHICH I
UNDERSTAND. IS VERY FAST AND
EFFICIENT WHO ALTERNATELY
REVIEWS A CASE BROUGHT BY THE
COUNCIL FOR DISCIPLINE. SURE I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
SO LET ME JUST START THE
BEGINNING WITH THE PROCESS DOES
SEEM TO SEIZE PROCESS. A WIRE
THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN WHEN A
STATE AGENCY DOES THE PROCESS IS
AN ALL WAY ALWAYS EXCUSE ME
ROBUST FAIR AND COMPLIES AND
ALWAYS WITH COMMON LAW FAIR
PROCEDURE DOCTRINE. THE MASSAGE
THERAPY ACT AND THE BOARD
APPROVED PROCEDURES IT MEANS THE
CORE TENETS OF DUE PROCESS WHICH
ARE NOTICE AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HEARD. ROSS THIS IS VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES ENGAGE IN WHEN THEY
DENY OR DISCIPLINE A LOCAL
PERMIT- SO INITIALLY A LETTER
SENT TO AN INDIVIDUAL A
CERTIFICATE HOLDER OR AN
APPLICANT. FOR CERTIFICATION
THAT LETTER CLEARLY ARTICULATES
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW. THE
BASIS FOR THE PROPOSED DENIAL.
OR DISCIPLINE AND DISCIPLINE
INCLUDES RELOCATION OF A
CERTIFICATE. THE EVIDENCE
SUPPORTING THE DECISION AND THE
PROCEDURES TO FOLLOW SO THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL CAN ACTUALLY ACCESS
PROCESS. SO THE LETTER- WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHERE ENGLISH IS
THEIR SECOND LANGUAGE SO THE
LETTERS- WE DO TRAIN RIGHT THEM
TO AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL READING
LEVEL VERSES- SOME TYPE OF A
HIGHER LEVEL- IN A LETTER
CLEARLY IDENTIFIES DATES AND
DEADLINES. SO IT NOTIFIES
INDIVIDUALS WHEN THEY MIGHT MAY
REQUEST A HEARING HOW TO REQUEST
A HEARING AND ALL OF THOSE
SPECIFIC DETAILS- LETTERS ARE
SENT APPROXIMATELY THIRTY DAYS
BEFORE SPECIFIED HEARING DATE.
INDIVIDUALS CAN REQUEST A
CONTINUANCE CONTINUANCE IS ARE
REGULARLY AND ROUTINELY GRANTED-
THERE'S ALSO A DEDICATED EMAIL
ADDRESS IN THE LETTERS AND THAT
GIVES THE INDIVIDUAL POINT OF
CONTACT THAT THEY CAN TALK TO-
BY EMAIL IF THEY HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT PROCESS AND HOW TO ACCESS
IT- INDIVIDUALS CAN REQUEST. AN
ORAL TELEPHONIC HEARING FOR
CONSIDERATION OF A WRITTEN
STATEMENT- THAT CHOICE IS UP TO
THEM IT'S WHATEVER THEY WOULD
PREFER. AND THE ACCESS TO
PROCESS ALL DONE REMOTELY SO
WHEN KOBE CAME ABOUT THERE WAS A
NEED TO CHANGE THE PROCESS
BECAUSE INDIVIDUALS. COULD
ALREADY ACCESS IT- SO THAT THAT
REALLY CREATES A NICE EASE OF
USE FOR PEOPLE AND IT DECREASES
THEIR COSTS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE TO TRAVEL TO A LOCATION.
AND MISS WORK FOR THE TIME TO DO
THAT TOOK- EVERYONE HAS THE
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO CHALLENGE THE
PROPOSED DECISION BEFORE IT
TAKES PLACE. AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE LETTER THAT
THERE'S THAT THEY'RE SENT.
PROPOSES THAT SCENE DC IS GOING
TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST THEM
EITHER DO NINE APPLICATION OR
DISCIPLINE OR CERTIFICATE- AND
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO COME HERE
AND CHALLENGE THAT BEFORE THAT
BECOMES FINAL AND EFFECTIVE.
THEY'RE NOT LIMITED IN THE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY CAN SUBMIT-
THEY- ARE. ALL DIFFERENT KINDS
OF THINGS WE SEE VERY VERY PIECE
OF EVIDENCE WE SEE DECORATIONS
WE SEE OUR CHARACTER LETTERS WE
SEE ALL KINDS OF THINGS-
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE REPRESENTED
BY COUNSEL OR REPRESENTATIVE AND
OFTEN AREN'T. AND THEY CAN
PROVIDE THE LIVE TESTIMONY OF
WITNESSES- THROUGH THE ORAL
TELEPHONIC HEARING IF THEY
CHOOSE THAT OPTION. THEY CAN
SUBMIT LEGAL BRIEFS- ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES OR ANY FACTUAL ISSUES
AND WE SEE THOSE. THOSE ARE NOT
LIMITED IN IN LANE THREE
SOMETIMES AND REGULARLY GET
FIFTY PAGE BRIEFS THAT COME IN.
ARE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I GET TO
SUBMIT REPORT USUALLY ARE MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE. MATTERS AND CAN
I ASK YOU WHO HERE'S THE ISSUE
THE ISSUES ARE HEARD BY
DEDICATED HEARING OFFICERS. SO
THAT'S WHO DECIDES THE MATTERS
HE TALKED ON THIS GUY STARTED IT
DID JUST GOING KIND OF FAST FOUR
THINGS A LITTLE BIT WHAT ARE THE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS TO
BECOMING HEARING OFFICER. WELL
WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFIC. MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS AS A AND- WE
DON'T SEE. I MEAN I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE MINIMUM
WOULD BE BUT WE REQUIRE THAT
THEY HAVE A BACKGROUND EITHER IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR IN MASSAGE.
SO GENERALLY HEARING OFFICERS
ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND- THEY'VE
GOT BACKGROUNDS AS MASSAGE
TEACHERS- MASSAGE SCHOOL OWNERS.
ARE CURRENTLY EVERYONE AND
EVERYBODY WHO'S BEEN A HEARING
OFFICER THAT IS IN SIZE
PROFESSIONAL IS CERTIFIED- AND
THEY'RE ALL WELL QUALIFIED FOR
THEIR POSITIONS. THEY'RE WELL
TRAINED- AND THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE THE SUBSTANTIVE KNOWLEDGE
TO UNDERSTAND WHEN CONDUCT IS
APPROPRIATE WELL MASSAGE IS
BEING PROVIDED AND WHEN IT'S
NOT- THEY'RE ALSO GUIDED BY
STAFF COUNSEL THE STAFF COUNCIL.
MUCH LIKE A STAFF COUNCIL MIGHT.
PROVIDE OPINIONS AND ANALYSIS TO
A CITY CITY COUNCIL STAFF
COUNCIL PROVIDES THEM WITH-
ADVICE ON LEGAL ISSUES SUCH AS
EVIDENTIARY ISSUES. HOW TO WEIGH
THE EVIDENCE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE PROPERLY COMPLYING WITH
THE PROCEDURES- ADDRESSING LEGAL
ARGUMENTS THAT MIGHT GET ME IS
MADE IN BRIEFS. IT'S ALWAYS
ENSURED THAT THE HEARING
OFFICERS HAVE NO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. SO THEY HAVE NO
PECUNIARY INTEREST IN THE
MATTERS BEFORE THEM. THERE'S NO
RELATIONSHIP OF ANY KIND WITH
THE INDIVIDUALS BEFORE THEM. ARE
THERE NOT TO MENTION MATTERS
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL THEY'VE NOT
BEEN TARGETS OF ABUSE BY THE
INDIVIDUAL WE'RE NOT FRIENDS OR
RELATIVES OF THE INDIVIDUAL. AND
REALLY MORE IMPORTANTLY. THEY
ONLY HEAR THE MATTER AT THE END
SO THEY ARE NOT INVOLVED AS AN
INVESTIGATOR A FACT FINDER
FINDER WARRANT INITIAL DECISION
MAKER. IN THE PROCESS THAT LEADS
UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL GETTING A
LETTER PROPOSING TO DENY OR
DISCIPLINE THEM THINGS SENSUALLY
HEARING OFFICERS COME INTO A
COLD. I ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE HEARING OFFICERS. IT IS
NOT A DECISION MADE BY AN
INDIVIDUAL IT'S A DECISION MADE
BY A BODY. SO THERE HAS TO BE A
MINIMUM LOOK TO HEARING OFFICER
THAT HERE EVERY. GENERALLY WE
HAVE THREE FOUR AND IT'S A
MATURE RULE. SO WE HAVE TO
HEARING ON. THEY HAVE TO DECIDE
UNANIMOUSLY- AND- I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHILE IT'S NOT REQUIRED
IF THERE'S THREE OR FOUR HEARING
OFFICERS ON A ON A MATTER. I
CANNOT REMEMBER THE LAST TIME A
DECISION WAS DECIDED THAT WAS
NOT UNANIMOUS GREAT AND AGAIN
HEARING OFFICERS AS A BODY
THEY'RE THE ONLY ONES WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE A FINAL
DECISION. IN THAT DECISION
CANNOT BE MADE BY THE BOARD- CAN
BE MADE BY STAFF OR STAFF
ATTORNEYS- SO THEY'RE
INDEPENDENT AND THEY THEY MAKE
THESE DECISIONS- VERY WELL I
HAVE TO SAY I'M ALWAYS
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF THE HEARING
OFFICERS- THERE REALLY DILIGENT-
THEY SPEND THEIR TIME REALLY
DEBATING ISSUES. AND CONSIDERING
HOW TO ACT ON THE INDIVIDUAL
ISSUES. THANK YOU THANK YOU AN
E. YOU YOU MET YOU MENTIONED A
LOT IN IN THAT ANSWER WHICH I
APPRECIATE UP AROUND THE PROCESS
AT ANY POINT IN THE INFO IN THE
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. DOES ANYONE
OUTSIDE THE COUNCIL REVIEW
ACCUSATIONS- THAT ARE BROUGHT BY
THE COUNCIL. NO THE PROCESS ALL
RIGHT SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT.
SOMETHING COMES IN A COMPLAINT A
NOTIFICATION FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BACK IT'S REVIEWED
BY WHAT WE CALL THE BACKGROUND
BACKGROUND REVIEWERS THE BACK
AND REVIEW DID DIVISION. THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT ACTS SORT OF LIKE
IN A CRIMINAL PROCESS WOULD BE-
LIKE THE INVESTIGATORS THE DA'S
OFFICE. THEY INVESTIGATE THEY
LOOK AT THE MATTER THEY MAKE A
ROPOSED- SOME PROPOSED FINDINGS
ABOUT WHAT THEY BELIEVE
OCCURRED. THEN THAT GETS SENT
OFF AFTER THAT INVESTIGATION IS
COMPLETED. BACK IT'S NOT TO THE
LEGAL DEPARTMENT AND LEGAL
DEPARTMENT DROPS THE LETTER
PROPOSING TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
THE INDIVIDUAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- ECHOED A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS- TO THE BEST OF YOUR
KNOWLEDGE IN THIS IS OPEN TO
ANYBODY WHO'S WHO'S ON TODAY TO
THE BEST OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE HOW
MANY CITIES AND COUNTIES
CURRENTLY REQUIRE CERTIFICATION
BY THE COUNCIL. THE PRACTICE
MASSAGE. I CAN I CAN ANSWER IT
APPROXIMATELY FIVE M. TO ONE
FIFTY. BUT THAT NUMBER CHANGES.
AND DOES THE COUNCIL WORK WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DRAFT
ORDINANCES REQUIRING
CERTIFICATION. EVERY DAY- WE
HAVE A VERY ROBUST AND ON GOING
RELATIONSHIP WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE WE HAVE A VERY
ACTIVE OUTREACH PROGRAM- WISDOM
SO WE MAINTAIN A LIBRARY OF
VARIOUS- COUNTY ORDINANCES AND
CITY ORDINANCES. WE ARE GIVE
THEM FEEDBACK WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH- SUGGESTIONS OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES- DIFFERENT- WHEN YOU
DEAL WITH A RURAL COUNTY OR YOU
DEAL WITH THAT- LARGE CITY THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT NEEDS. WE ALSO
ARE INVOLVED WITH THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN ALCOHOL ORDINANCE
WHICH ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
MASSAGE THERAPY ACT AND TO MAKE
SURE THEY DON'T CREATE ANY KIND
OF LOCAL RULES AND REGULATIONS
WHICH ARE ONEROUS. AND ARE ARE
CREATING HARDSHIPS. ON CERTIFIED
MASSAGE THERAPIST. THANKS ENJOY
GOT YET DO YOU BELIEVE THAT FOR
THE AVERAGE CITY OR COUNTY
INCORPORATING REQUIREMENT THAT
ALL MASSAGE THERAPISTS BE
CERTIFIED IS A GOOD POLICY. SO
GENERALLY SPEAKING- THE
CORNERSTONE OF THEIR REVOKE
HERBAL REGISTRATION- OUR PROGRAM
WHICH I'M GONNA ASK- MR CALLAGY
MAYBE YOUR ADDRESS IN A MINUTE
THE CORNERSTONE OF THIS POGRAM
IS THE REQUIREMENTS TO HAVE THE
CERTIFICATION SO THAT PROGRAM IS
VERY EFFECTIVE IN GOING AFTER
ILLICIT MASSAGE BUSINESSES AND
HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO BE REALLY
AFFECTED. US O MANY MANY CITIES
AND COUNTIES DO REQUIRE
CERTIFICATION HOWEVER THIS IS
REALLY A DECISION THAT IT'S BEST
LEFT FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
DECIDE BECAUSE THE BEAUTY OF THE
STATE LAW THAT THE CREATION OF
STATEWIDE CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITY TO A DOCTOR- THIS
PROGRAM AND TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT BUT IN SOME LOCAL COMMUNITIES
MAYBE IT MAKES SENSE FOR THEM
NOT TO REQUIRE IT FOR EXAMPLE.
THE MANY THERAPISTS IN OUR
INDUSTRY REFERRED TO THEM AS
THEIR LEGACY THERAPISTS
THERAPISTS WILL BE AROUND FOR
TWENTY THIRTY FORTY YEARS HARD
WORKING VERY DEDICATED VERY
PROFESSIONAL WHO DO NOT MEET THE
CORN REQUIREMENT IN STATE LAW
THE EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS SO
IF A LOCAL COMMUNITY HAS THIS
ISSUE THEY CAN ALLOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO WORK AND TO SERVE
THE COMMUNITY EVEN THOUGH THEY
DON'T NEED THIS THE HIGHER
REQUIREMENTS. ISN'T THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE LAW SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS SOMETHING.
BEST LEFT FOR LOCAL CONTROL.
INTERMENT BERMAN I MAY- CEMETERY
COUNTY ONE OF THE LEADERS IN IN
ONE OF FIRST OF THE I IN THIS.
STUDENTS A VOCAL REGISTRATION AT
THE PROBLEM WE FOUND WAS IN THE
PAST WHEN HE WENT AFTER THE
MASSEUSES MANY OF WHO ARE HUMAN
TRAFFIC- THE BUSINESS WOULD JUST
KEEP OPERATING THEY WOULD
SUPPRESSION WITH WITH THE- WITH
NEW INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY BRING
IN. FOR PURPOSES OF PROSTITUTION
WE HOLD THE OWNER ACCOUNTABLE-
REVOKE REGISTRATION AND
THEREFORE TAKE THE INSTEAD OF
OUT OF IT- FOR- DOCTOR OWNER
JUST KEEP CONTINUING TO BRING
IN. NEW VICTIMS- SO WE GO AFTER
THE OWNER AND WE WILL MERELY-
CLOSE OUT BUSINESS DOWN. IF THEY
ARE. INVOLVED IN ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY. THANK YOU BOTH WE IN
AND MISTER CARRIE. ARE YOU WHERE
IS OUR MOST COUNTIES DO IS THAT
WHAT WHAT MOST MUNICIPALITIES DO
BECAUSE HE DID DO SOME PEOPLE
RAISE ME THE CONCERN THAT. YOU
KNOW THE ESTABLISHMENTS WERE TO
SHUT DOWN AND THEN POP UP. A
COUPLE OF DAYS LATER- YOU KNOW
WITH A NEW NAME AND IT'S THE-
MASSAGE THERAPIST WHO WHO IS
OFTEN A VICTIM- AS AS YOU ALL
SAID- WHO WHO ENDS UP YOU KNOW-
IMPACTED BUT NOT NECESSARILY-
THE- DID YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE
THE REAL CRIMINAL- BEHIND ALL OF
THIS. IS DENNY THOUGHTS ON THAT.
RIGHT RIGHT WE HAVE RECEIVED.
MANY MANY INCREASE INTO OUR
ORDINANCE AND MANY OTHERS HAVE
EMULATED WHAT WE HAVE I DONE
HERE BUT THIS IS THE KEY AND
HAVING WORKED IN THIS INDUSTRY
AND TAKING DOWN MANY OF THESE
ILLEGAL MASSAGE PARLORS. IN MY
PRIOR CAREER- YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE
THE FINANCIAL INCENTIVE OUT OF
THAT- FOR THESE OPERATORS IF
THEY BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT WILL BE IN
JEOPARDY IN THE FIRST WEEK IN
THE FIRST MONTH. THERE ARE A LOT
LESS LIKELY TO OPEN UP THE
ILLEGAL CYCLE OR IN THAT.
JURISDICTION SO THAT'S WHY MANY
HAVE GOLF BALL IT QUITE FRANKLY-
YOU KNOW THERE'S SERVER AS FAR
AS THE VICTIMS THEY ARE TOO BIG.
BY THE WAY THAT THE- HAVING DID
INSIDE OUT AND RUN AN UNDERCOVER
OPERATION FOR A YEAR INSIDE I
GOTTA LOOK INTO THIS THAT. WAS
UNBELIEVABLE. BUT MANY OF THEM
ARE FORCED INTO THAT IN BELIEVE
ME- THEY ARE WAY BETTER OFF OUT
OF IT. IN IN MOST OF THEM ARE
NOT CERTIFIED. THE YOU- I THINK
THAT WRAPS UP OKAY I HAVE
ZHOROV. THANK YOU JERRY BERMAN
ME JUST STAY ONE YOU KNOW AND
LISTENING TO THE- QUESTION AND
THE RESPONSES REGARDING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS OF
DISCIPLINARY IS PROCESS OF.
HE'LL OF DENIAL OF PROCESS IN
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT HEARING
OFFICERS EMBEDDED IN THE COUNCIL
. YOU KNOW IT OCCURS TO ME THAT
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE LICENSURE OR
THE CREATION OF A STATE BOARD TO
DEAL WITH POTENTIAL ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED- DUE PROCESS ISSUES.
SO MY QUESTION IS THIS- TO THE
COUNCIL AND THE MEMBERS HERE.
HAVE YOU HAVE YOU CONSIDER
UTILIZING THE SERVICES OF- AN
INDEPENDENT ARBITRATOR OR A
JUDGE ON THESE CASES WHERE.
THESE ARE FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES APPROVAL DENIAL
DISCIPLINE NOT. USING THE
SERVICES OF AN INDEPENDENT
ARBITRATOR OR A JUDGE FOR
EXAMPLE RETIRED JUDGE TO LISTEN
AND ULTIMATELY- MAKE FINDINGS OF
FACT AND RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING THE DECISION TO THE
BOARD ITSELF- FOR THE ULTIMATE
DECISION. YES CHAIRMAN ROB I
THINK I'LL ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
THAT'S OKAY SO TO MY KNOWLEDGE
SEEM TO SEE HASN'T LOOKED AT
THAT BUT I WILL SAY THAT THAT
KIND OF A PROCESS IS INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE IF ANYONE'S BEEN
INVOLVED IN ARBITRATION IT'S NOT
UNUSUAL THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
PAY AN ARBITRATOR. IN PAST CASES
I'VE HAD LITIGATION MATTERS
WE'RE PAYING ARBITRATORS YOU
KNOW THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS A DAY
TO ARBITRATE THE MATTERS AND GET
GOOD ARBITRATORS HERE SEEM TO
SEIZE PROCESS IS A VERY
INDEPENDENT PROCESS- AND I WANT
TO SAY YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME
SIMILARITIES TO WHAT WE SEEM TO
SEE OPERATES WITHIN ITS HEARING
OFFICERS. THE WAY THAT ALE JAY'S
WORK BUT YEAH I THINK SEEM
DISEASE PROCESS IS MORE
INDEPENDENT THAN THE WAY ALE
JAY'S WORK FIRST IN OUR STATE
LICENSURE MATTERS LOWER JUST.
SAY THAT THE ALE JAY'S
TYPICALLY. I COULD BE WRONG WORK
FOR THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW. AT LEAST IN MANY CASES AND
THAT'S SEPARATE FROM WORKING
DIRECTLY FOR. THE STATE BORDER
BUREAU OR A OR A STATE AGENCY.
AND I'M NOT SAYING THERE'S AN
ISSUE I'M JUST. ASKING THE
QUESTION BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A PERCEIVED ISSUE OR IT
WOULDN'T BE REFLECTED. IN OUR
BACKGROUND PAPER AND- I'M NOT
SURE FIRST OF ALL IF YOU CHARGE
FOR A VARIETY OF THINGS AND
CERTAINLY OUR BOARDS AND BUREAUS
TOO YOU CAN CERTAINLY ASSESS A
FEE FOR THE USE OF A OF AN
ARBITRATOR OR A RETIRED JUDGE.
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO YOU
COULD ALSO TRIAGE THE CASES IN
WHICH THE PROCESS SUPPLIES AND
RESTRICTED TO ONLY THE MOST
SERIOUS WHERE SOMEONE'S ABILITY
TO IN ESSENCE EVEN THOUGH THIS
IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. WORK IS
IN JEOPARDY OR- SCHOOLS ABILITY
TO FUNCTION. IS IN JEOPARDY SO
THAT'S WHY I ASKED THE QUESTION
. SURE AND I UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION BUT I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT IN A MINUTE
RIGHT IT MINISTRY OF LAW JUDGES.
THE WORK THAT THEY DO IS PAID
FOR BY THE AGENCIES THAT THEY
PROVIDE THE WORKFORCE SO IT'S A
VERY ANALOGOUS IT'S REALLY NOT
THAT DIFFERENT. THE OTHER THING
ABOUT ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENS FOR- IF
SOMEONE HAS A STATE LICENSE. AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE ISSUES
A PROPOSED DECISION THEY DO NOT
ISSUE A FINAL DECISION. AND THEN
THE BOARD ITSELF DECIDES WHAT TO
DO WITH THAT PROPOSED DECISION.
AND THIS IS A GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION ELEVEN FIVE ONE SEVEN.
C. ONE. SO THE BOARD CAN DO
NOTHING AND JUST ADOPT THE
DECISION- IF THAT'S HOW THEY
LIKE TO ADDRESS IT. THE US THEY
CAN DOCTOR IN THEIR ENTIRETY.
THEY CAN REJECT THE DECISION AND
REFERRED BACK TO NAIL J. THEY
CAN MAKE CHANGES TO THE
DECISION. AND THEY CAN REJECT
THE DECISION AND DECIDE THE
MATTER FOR THEMSELVES. SO I
UNDERSTAND THESE ISSUES ARE
RAISED AND- YOU KNOW WE'RE HERE
TO ADDRESS THEM. BUT I THINK THE
PROCESS IS APPROPRIATE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FAIR
PROCEDURE DOCTOR IN COMMON LAW-
THERE ARE NO CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST AND THE HEARING
OFFICER. OFFICERS ARE VERY WELL
THAT IT. AND I THINK YOU HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL ABOUT WANTING TO. PUT
IN A VERY EXPENSIVE PROCESS ON
INDIVIDUALS. WHO DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND FINANCES TO AFFORD IT- SO
THAT'S ALWAYS A CONCERN YOU
KNOW. IN ST. I DON'T USUALLY
GIVE THEM A CHOICE. BUT IN IN
SITUATIONS I'VE SEEN AND STATE
BOARDS FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE
BOARD OF THE COUNTY THERE MIGHT
BE AN ACTION AND THEN THEY GET
THAT MONEY BACK THAT THEY PAY
FOR THAT TO PROCESS THE- A
COUNTY BOARD FOR EXAMPLE CAN
REQUEST THAT MONEY BACK- AND- IN
THOSE INDUSTRIES THERE'S ENOUGH
MONEY WHERE INDIVIDUALS. WILL
PAY YOU TO BE LICENSED AGAIN
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE FINANCES
TO DO IT YOU KNOW MIGHT BE
TWENTY OR THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR INACTION HERE ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE MAKING A MUCH LOWER
AMOUNT OF MONEY PER HOUR. AND
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE AT
THE FINANCES TO PAY FOR THAT
TYPE OF DUE PROCESS WITH ELEVEN
YEARS AGO GOOD THE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT QUESTION SURE IF COST
ISN'T AS A FACTOR AND- THE
DETERMINATION IS MADE TO KEEP
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
INTERNAL TO THE COUNCIL. WHY
WOULD THE COUNCIL BOARD DELEGATE
FINAL AUTHORITY TO HEARING
OFFICER EMPLOYEES. AND NOT
PROVIDE AN AVENUE FOR APPEAL TO
THE COUNCIL. IF THE INDIVIDUALS
OR THE ENTITIES IMPACTED
DISAGREE WITH THE HEARING
OFFICER'S DECISION. WELL SO. IF
YOU'RE ASKING WHETHER THERE IS
AN APPEAL I'M I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
ARE YOU ASKING WHETHER THERE IS
AN APPEAL PROCESS WELL I'M
LOOKING AT THE BACK ROOM OF
TALKING ABOUT DENIED SCHOOLS
RIGHT HERE. OKAY WELL SCHOOLS
ARE A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
PROCESS SO- I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS
SCHOOLS BUT SCHOOLS HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT PROCESS THAN
INDIVIDUALS AND THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT REASONS BUT ONE OF THE
REASONS HAS A COOL COOL STILL
USE A HEARING OFFICER CONCEPT
TO. PAGE THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
OF OUR BACKGROUND PAPER. AND
MAYBE IT'S A DIFFERENT CERTAINLY
A DIFFERENT. CERTAINLY A
DIFFERENT SUBJECT. BUT MY
QUESTION IS- IT RELATES TO THIS
STATEMENT A DENIED SCHOOLS SUCH
AS THE ONE IN THE RECENT CASE
HAS NO OPTION FOR APPEALING A
CA. CA MTC DECISION. EXCEPT TO
DIFFERENT SEGMENTS OF THE CMT C.
ITSELF I EITHER TO HEARING
OFFICERS. WHAT SORRY I'M SORRY
CENTER OFF THAT IS NOT FACTUALLY
CORRECT SO FOR SCHOOL PROCEDURE
UP SCHOOLS FIRST OF ALL HAVE THE
RIGHT TO FULL PROCEDURE THE
PROCESS IS VERY FAIR OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT THEY'RE PROVIDED
WITH ALL THE EVIDENCE AGAIN WITH
THE PROPOSED DECISION LONGER
TIME FRAMES FOR SCHOOLS SCHOOLS
MATTERS ARE HEARD- AGAIN BY A
MINIMUM OF TWO HEARING FFICERS
BUT GENERALLY THREE AND THEN IF
SCHOOLS AREN'T HAPPY WITH THAT
DECISION THEY DO YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO APPEAL IT TO THE FULL
BOARD- AND THEY HAVE I CAN SEE
WHERE MEMBER COUNTY SHAKING HIS
HEAD BECAUSE HE'S BEEN HE'S
HEARD THOSE APPEALS WILL
CONTINUE TO GO TO THE FULL BOARD
AND THEY KIND OF KILL IT OR NOT. A LABOR IT'S NOT TO BELABOR IT
THEN. OUR BACKGROUND PAPER ON
PAGE THIRTY FIVE IN THE LITTLE
PAGE IS INCORRECT AND LET'S
FOCUS ON THE DISCIPLINE CASES TO
DISCIPLINE CASES IN THE CASE OF
A DISCIPLINE CASES AN INDIVIDUAL
BEING DISCIPLINED WHO HAS HIS
HER OR THEIR- CASE HEARD BY THE
TWO OR THREE HEARING OFFICERS I
THINK YOU MENTIONED TWO DOES
THAT INDIVIDUAL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT
DISCIPLINARY DECISION APPEALED
TO THE FULL BOARD. THEY DO NOT
SO INDIVIDUAL CERTIFICATION
MATTERS- AGAIN REQUIRED TO VAST
MAJORITY WE HAVE THREE OR FOUR
HEARINGS I'M SORRY HEARING
OFFICERS ON THE HEARING SO HE'S
A MINIMUM CASE SOMEONE GETS SICK
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. BUT THE
WAY THAT- THE WAY THAT IT'S RUN
IT'S ALMOST ALWAYS THREE HEARING
OFFICERS. THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BRING AN ACTION SUPERIOR COURT
SO THEY WOULD BRING A PETITION
FOR WRIT OF MANDATE CHALLENGING
THE DECISION. AND THAT IS THEIR
LEVEL OF APPEAL WHICH IS
PROBABLY MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
HAVING A THIRD JUDGE YOUR
ARBITRATOR HEAR THE CASE IN THE
BEGINNING. HAS THERE IS ANY
CONSIDERATION BEING GIVEN BEEN
GIVEN TO. ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS.
WHO FOR EXAMPLE ARE SUBJECT TO
HAVING THEIR OR HAVE. HAD THEIR
CERTIFICATION WITHDRAWN THAT'S
THE PROPER TERM. BE ABLE TO TAKE
THAT DECISION TO THE FULL BOARD
GIVEN THE POTENTIAL IMPACT ON
THEIR ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK. AND AGAIN SENATOR ALSO TO
MY KNOWLEDGE IT HAS NOT AND THAT
HAS TO DO WITH IT'S A VOLUME
ISSUE C. N. T. AND THE TIMING
ISSUE SEEM TO SEE AS A VOLUNTEER
BOARD THAT MEETS FOUR TIMES A
YEAR. IF THIS IF AN APPEAL WAS
INSTITUTED WITH IN THE BOARD.
THEN I THINK THAT THAT THAT
WOULD BE MEETINGS EVERY WEEK
POTENTIALLY I MEAN IT WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON VOLUNTEER
BOARDS WITH A LOT OF OPTIONS
FULL BOARD. SUB COMMITTEE OF THE
BOARD I GUESS I'LL START OFF TO
JUST REPEAT THE PREAMBLE TO MY
QUESTION YOU KNOW IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY REQUIRE LICENSURE.
FOR THE CREATION OF A STATE
BOARD IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH THAT
EITHER ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED DUE
PROCESS ISSUE SO- SUFFICE IT TO
SAY ADDRESS MY QUESTION YOU
RESPONDED. BY PROVIDERS OF- A
SUGGESTION. THAT SOMEONE MIGHT
NEED TO AT LEAST PROBABLY SHOULD
GIVE A LITTLE THOUGHT TO THE
PROCESS. YOUR PERMANENT THANK
YOU FOR THE RESPONSE FROM YOUR
BOURBON ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS I
DO NOT THINK. OKAY SO AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD ON TO OUR PANEL WHO
WE'VE ASKED TO WEIGH IN ON
VARIOUS MODELS FOR MASSAGE
THERAPY REGULATION HOPEFULLY
THEY'VE- STUCK WITH ME AND I
HAVEN'T PUT THEM TO SLEEP-
STARTING WITH BOB BENSON
CHAIRMAN ASSOCIATED BODYWORK AND
MASSAGE PROFESSIONALS JAMES
PARKER. SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
INDUSTRY AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AMERICAN MASSAGE
THERAPY ASSOCIATION TERRY HARMON
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA AND MIKE
CONNOTES IN CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE THERAPY.
COALITION LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN RALPH AND GERMAN
PERMANENT MEMBERS MAY YOUR
STAMINA IS IMPRESSIVE. A YEAR
AGO THIS COMMITTEE STEERED AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IT'S ALL
REQUIRING CALLING FOR SUBSEQUENT
CONSIDERATION OF LEGISLATION TO
CREATE A NEW STATE BOARD AND A
NEW CATEGORY OF LICENSED MASSAGE
PROFESSIONAL. A. B. M. P. DID
HOMEWORK TO PREPARE BOTH THE
SIXTY PAGE SOME BRIDES
QUESTIONNAIRE AND A DRAFT BILL
TO ACHIEVE THESE OBJECTIVES. J.
M. D. SAVE INITIAL INSURER
CONSTRUCTIVE APPROACH OF
OFFERING VOLUNTARY CERTIFICATION
TO SARS SERVICE. KEEPS MOVING
AWAY FROM THAT PURPOSE WHICH TO
REQUIRE LICENSURE IS BOTH
SHEARER AND OVERDUE. MORE THAN
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVE MASSAGE THERAPY EACH
YEAR SERVED BY SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND BESIDES THEIR APPROACH
NONE OF THOSE SERVICES ARE STATE
LICENSE THIS IS A PROBLEM WITH
MULTIPLE DIMENSIONS. NORWAY'S
MASSAGE CONSUMERS BELIEVE
MASSAGE THERAPISTS ARE REGULATED
BUT THAT ISN'T THE CATCH. OF
SCOPE OF PRACTICE DEFINITION BUT
ENGAGED AGAINST THEIR POSTS
KEEPING THEIR WORK WITHIN
BOUNDARIES APPROPRIATE TO THEIR
TRAINING. ONE FOUR SPECIFICALLY
LOOK UP IN THE STREET IS STIFLED
BY INCOMPLETE PROFESSION
REGULATION. GMT SEATS ONLY
DISCIPLINE. WOULD EITHER BE
HOLDS ALL OR SUBSTANTIALLY
MITIGATED BY CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTING REQUIRED LICENSURE
FOR MASSAGE THERAPISTS
REGULATORY MODEL USED BY FORTY
FIVE OTHER STATES. BY CONTRAST
GMT SHE CANNOT TRULY PROTECT THE
PUBLIC OR CREDENTIALING OVER
THREE FOURTHS OF MASSAGE
THERAPISTS WILL BE BOTH
CONSUMERS AND WALL OFFICERS
AREN'T SURE HOW TO RELATE TO THE
OTHER ONE FOR. J. M. T. C.
PREACHERS PUBLIC PROTECTION OR
QUIETLY ALLOWING THE EMBARKS
PROFESSION ENTRY EXAM YOU
REALIZE BY FORTY THREE STAGE
REMAINS SUSPENDED BECAUSE NO
TEST REQUIREMENTS HELP C. A. M.
P. C. ENROLLMENT NUMBERS. J. M.
T. SENIOR MANAGEMENT HAS BECOME
ABSORBED BY THE SERIOUS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PROBLEM. UNDER DRUG
OF GROWING THE NUMBER OF
CERTIFIED THERAPISTS EDUCATING
THE PUBLIC AND ADVOCATING FOR
AND SECURING A RECOGNIZED LOCAL
PRACTICE FOR MASSAGE THERAPISTS.
TRAFFICKERS PLACE CONTROLLED
INDIVIDUALS AND RESTAURANTS
LANDSCAPING JANITORIAL
CONSTRUCTION HOUSEKEEPING AND-
TELLS IN ADDITION TO SO CALLED
MASSAGE- WHICH LEADERSHIP OF
ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING EFFORTS
SHOULD COME FROM OUR
ORGANIZATION WHAT BROADER
CHARTER. ONE CHARGED. WITH
ISSUING MASSAGE CERTIFICATION.
WITH MANDATORY ALL CONCERN RIGHT
NOW EVERY LICENSE THERAPIST HAS
MEANT QUALIFICATION CRITERIA AND
WILL BE SUBJECT TO DISCIPLINE
FOR WORK L. FOR YOUR BOARD. AND
POLICE WOULD GAIN CERTAINTY
EITHER THERAPIST CAN PRODUCE A
LICENSE VERIFIABLE STATE BOARD
DATABASE OR BE SUBJECT TO
PROSECUTION. MY PLEA TO
RECOMMEND IT. DON'T UNWITTINGLY
BECOME COMPLICIT IN PERPETRATING
ALLUSION OF PUBLIC PROTECTION
WITH THE CFTC MALL INSTEAD SIGN
UP FOR A WIDE PATH TO. ADOPTION
OF REQUIRED LICENSURE. THANK YOU
I INVITE QUESTIONS ARE ONE
TEASER YOU MAY WISH TO PURSUE AN
OUTLINE OF A POTENTIAL
APPROACHED THE COURT OF APPEAL
BOTH THE LICENSEE EVER GETS AND
C. A. M. P. SHEARER. THANK YOU
SIR WHO'S NEXT MISTER SPEAKER BY
PRINCE SECRETARY. YES SIR THANK
YOU- GERMAN ROCK CHAIRMAN BERMAN
MANY MEMBERS- ON BEHALF OF
AMERICANS THERE VIEWS CHANGE I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- THIS AFTERNOON AND
I HAVE BEEN I'VE BEEN THIS ALL
IMPORTANT SUNSET REVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA DISASTER COUNCIL- AS
YOU STATED SENATOR ROB MY NAME'S
JAMES VIKRAM BHATT SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF INDUSTRY AND
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR. THE
MTA LARGEST NON PROFESSIONAL
NONPROFIT NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
SERVING SIZE THEIR STUDENTS AND
SCHOOL. AND NUMBER EIGHT
THOUSAND NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS NATIONALLY WITH. OVER
EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED AND STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FOR SEVENTY FIVE
YEAR M. HAS WORKED TO ADVANCE
THE PROFESSION GRAPHIC STANDARDS
PUBLIC EDUCATION ON THE HEALTH
BENEFITS OF MASSAGE THERAPY AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE PROMOTE THE
PROMOTION OF FAIR AND CONSISTENT
LICENSING A MASSAGE. THERAPIST
IN ALL STATES. THE PROMOTION OF
- INCONSISTENT LIKE NOTHING HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE DRIVING FORCES
BEHIND ENTERTAINMENT MSN SINCE
OUR INCEPTION. THAT THAT J. AND
RESPECT STATES RIGHTS TO GOVERN
AND REGULATE THEM THE MANNER OR
MODEL THAT WORKS FOR THE
CONSTITUENTS OF BACKSTAGE
HOWEVER. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE THAT LOG BE WRITTEN IN
A MANNER THAT PROTECTS THE
CONSUMER. FROM HARM AND IT'S
FAIR AND EQUITABLE FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS BUT PUBLIC
PRACTITIONER SCHOOLS OR
BUSINESSES. MTA DOES NOT SUPPORT
SYSTEMS THAT CREATE UNNECESSARY
AND UNPARALLELED FINANCIAL
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON THE
INDUSTRY. THAT IS VOID OF
CLEARLY DEFINED MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS FOR ENTRY INTO
SYSTEM THE MAJOR CONFLICT.
ABSENT A LEGALLY DEFINED SCOPE
OF PRACTICE OR ONE THAT SERVES
TO CREATE CONFUSION TO THE
PUBLIC AS IT RELATES TO WHO IS
OR WHO ISN'T QUALIFIED BAYERN
FASTER SERVICES. ACCORDING TO
RECENT RESEARCH RESEARCH
CONDUCTED. NATIONALLY OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION MASSAGES WERE
GIVEN LAST YEAR. 73% OF THEM
WERE STOCKWELL POOR HEALTH OR
MEDICAL REASONS HE HAD A CUTE
FOR CHRONIC PAIN STRESS MENTAL
HEALTH. OR AN EXTENSIVE LIST OF
OTHER HEALTH OR PAIN RELATED
CONDITIONS THIS IS UP 3% FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN. MASSAGE THERAPY
. THE GROWING PRESENCE IN THE
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONAL HEALTH
CARE LANDSCAPE AS AN EFFECTIVE
NON PHARMACOLOGIC TREATMENT FOR
PAIN. ARMEN OF DEFENSE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS
INCLUDING SUCH THERAPY IN THEIR
PAIN MANAGEMENT GUIDELINES. AS
AND MASSAGE THERAPY IS COVERED
IN THE DOD VA FACILITY.
ADDITIONALLY THE VA HAS
ESTABLISHED JUST A FEW SHORT
YEARS AGO IF YES FIVE GS NINE
POSITION OR MASSAGE THERAPIST.
THE CENTER FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES CMS IS
RECOMMENDED IN THEIR PLAN BETTER
FOR GUIDANCE THERE PETER PROVIDE
MASSAGE PROVIDED BY A STATE
LICENSED MASSAGE THERAPISTS TO
BE A SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT WITH
THEM. MEDICARE ADVANTAGE PLANS
SIMILARLY MASSAGE THERAPIES.
THEN SINGLED OUT AS AN EFFECTIVE
NON PHARMACOLOGICAL APPROACH TO
PAIN MANAGEMENT SUPPORTED BY THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND CAST FORTH.
YOU CAN ME- FAMILY PHYSICIAN THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF PHYSICIANS
AND THE JOINT COMMISSION. WE AS
AN ASSOCIATION HAVE A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD ACROSS THE COUNTRY
OF BEING WILLING AND PRODUCTIVE
COLLABORATORS WITH FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
ASSISTING IN CREATING MEANINGFUL
AND- LAWS AND REGULATIONS
INCLUDING OUR OWN ADVOCACY
AROUND THE CREATION OF. THE IBM
PC. WHICH AT THE TIME THOSE
INVOLVED VIEWED AS COMPROMISED
AS WELL AS A STEPPING STONE IF
THEY LIVE THERE. AS A LEADING
ORGANIZATION MUST SERVE THE
ADVOCACY AND THE LARGEST FUNDER
OF MASSAGE THERAPY THE RESEARCH
WE ARE CELL B. WE OFFER
OURSELVES TO YOUR- AS A RESOURCE
AND A PARTNER. AS YOU COMPLETE
THE CMT C. SUNSET REVIEW. YEAH
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ASSISTING YOU
ARE PROVIDING YOU ANY SCIENCE OR
EVIDENCE BASED DATA WE HAVE.
SHOULD YOU NEED TO SUPPORT YOUR
ONGOING CONVERSATION HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND THANK YOU ADAM.
WHERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SIR. EXCUSE ME. LET'S NOW
TURN TO THE ASSISTANT DA FOR THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA TERRY ARM
. GOOD AFTERNOON I AM APPEARING
ON BEHALF OF SANITARY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN THE ROSE AND
MISSION AS THE DA OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IS TO ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY THROUGH THE PREVENTION
AND PROSECUTION OF CRIME HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS A VERY COMPLEX
CRIME AND THERE CAN BE MANY
VARIANCES IN THE FORM THAT IT
TAKES AND THE MOTIVATING FACTORS
OF THE PARTIES INVOLVED. IT IS
ALSO A CRIME THAT HIDES IN PLAIN
SIGHT. ITS INSIDIOUSNESS OFTEN
WEARS A MASK OF RESPECTABILITY
OR HARMLESSNESS. THE AMERICAN
MASSAGE THERAPY ASSOCIATION
CLAIMS THAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND PROSTITUTION IS THE PROVINCE
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THIS IS
REALLY A VERY SHORT SIGHTED
STATEMENTS WHILE POLICE WERE
ABLE TO INTERVENE WHEN THEY SEE
SOMETHING OR WHEN SOMEONE
REACHES OUT TO THEM USUALLY BY
CALLING NINE ONE ONE. THE
REALITY IS THAT THIS CRIME
OCCURS BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
MAKING IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TASK
FOR POLICE TO OBSERVE AND
INTERVENE. THE VICTIMS OF THIS
CRIME ARE OFTEN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
MANIPULATED AND CONTROLLED
ENERGY SIMPLY UNACCUSTOMED TO
HAVING A WEIGHT. LET ALONE
MAKING A NINE ONE ONE CALL. IT
IS A CRIME UNLIKE SO MANY OTHER
CRIMES WHICH REQUIRES A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH WITH MANY
DIFFERENT PARTNERS. C. M. T. C.
HAS BEEN A TERRIFIC RESOURCE IN
THE FIGHT AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THE C. A. MTC IS
PART OF THE SOLUTION. IT
PROVIDES SPECIAL ATTENTION WITH
CONSISTENT MEASURES THAT DO NOT
EXIST IN CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMER
PROTECTION BUREAUCRACY. THE
COLLABORATIVE NATURE OF CMT C.
IS WHAT SEPARATES THEM FROM
LICENSING BOARDS. SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IS IN YEAR TWO OF THE
FIVE YEAR MOU WAS C. A. M. P. C.
AND WE ARE READY TO SIGN ON FOR
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS. INCLUDED
AMONG THEIR MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
ADMINISTRATING ADMINISTERING
LOCAL ORDINANCES SHARING
INFORMATION WITH THE DA WHEN
AUTHORIZED BY STATUTE. PROVIDING
HISTORY OF DISCIPLINARY ACTION
PROVIDING STATUS OF MASSAGE
THERAPISTS CERTIFIED BY C. A. M.
P. C. THE SHARE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS HIGHLIGHTING RISKS AND
EXPLORING SOLUTIONS AND THEY
PROVIDE THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT A
DEDICATED POINT OF CONTACT. HERE
IN THE DA'S OFFICE WE WORK WITH
OTHER OR I SHOULD SAY WE DEAL
WITH OTHER LICENSING BOARDS ARE
BOARDS THAT GOVERN ATTORNEYS
DOCTORS DENTISTS CONTRACTORS
REAL ESTATE PROFESSIONALS AND
THERE IS NO MEANINGFUL
COLLABORATION BECAUSE EVERYONE
IS IN THEIR OWN SILO. WHEN THERE
ARE SILOS IN THE WORLD OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. V. OFFENDERS SLIVER
AROUND THE SILOS WHITE SNEAKS.
SILOS ARE PART OF THE PROBLEM
AND COLLABORATION AS PART OF THE
SOLUTION. YOUR SHIFT WAS C. A.
M. P. Z. A SIGNIFICANCE AND YEAH
AND IT'S ABOUT USING PRACTICAL
ANSWERS TO A FESTERING PROBLEM.
IF THE C. M. D. C. WERE BROKEN
IN. WHY SO SURE MIGHT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE BUT IT'S NOT BROKEN IT IS
WORKING IT'S WORKING WELL WE
LIKED IT. R. D. ROSEN PREVIOUSLY
STATED IF IT AIN'T BROKE DON'T
FIX IT AND THIS IS STILL TRUE
THERE IS A REASON WHY SO MANY
PEOPLE LAW ENFORCEMENT. VICTIM
SERVICES GROUPS OUR WOMEN'S
GROUPS SUPPORT C. A. M. CHEESY
WERE UNITED AND THE SUPPORT
BECAUSE IT WORKS. WE ASKED FOR
AN EXTENSION THAT ALLOWS THE MO
USE BETWEEN C. A M. T. Z. AND
OTHER ENTITIES TO BE EXECUTED.
YOU'VE GIVEN FIVE YEARS IN THE
PAST IT'S BEEN A GOOD FIVE YEARS
IT'S A GOOD TIME TO GIVE FIVE
YEARS AGAIN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NOW MICHAEL CONNECTS
CALIFORNIA. PROFESSIONALS SUCH
THERAPY COALITION. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN CHAIRMAN- MEMBERS MY
CONNECTION HERE ON THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE
THERAPY COALITION WHICH
REPRESENTS MANY OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND LICENSEES
FRANCHISEES OF THE NATIONAL
CHAINS AND THE LARGEST SCHOOL
FOR THERAPIST I'M HERE ON ON
BEHALF OF THE INDUSTRY I'M HERE
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT MAKE UP MOST OF
OUR INDUSTRY. I WANT TO GIVE
THIS LITTLE CONTEXT IN WHICH
THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER
TO CONTINUE WITH C. M. D. C. OR
EMBARK ON ON A VERY AMBITIOUS-
TENUOUS LICENSING PROPOSAL-
MASSAGE BUSINESS LIKE MANY
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAVE BEEN
THROUGH A GREAT DEAL IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS. MANY OF MY MEMBERS
AND THOSE ARE NOT MY MEMBERS
COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN FOR SEVEN
TO ELEVEN MONTHS- DRAMATICALLY
REDUCED INCOMING CUSTOMER
TRAFFIC AFTER REOPENING
THERAPISTS- EXITING THE INDUSTRY
IN DROVES AND OF COURSE
THERAPISTS ARE THE THING THAT
MAKES OUR BUSINESSES WORK- IT
WAS AWFUL- IT WAS TERRIBLE WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO CATCH YOUR BREATH
AND STABILIZE AND WE'RE TRYING
TO DO THAT IN. A VERY
CHALLENGING TIMES WITH EXTREME.
INFLATION AND THAT SORT OF THING
SO I OFTEN GET ASKED OFTEN IN
DIFFERENT ROLES YOU KNOW WHAT
CAN WE DO WHAT CAN THIS
LEGISLATURE DUE TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESS CENTER IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE- YOU CAN YOU CAN
HELP SMALL BUSINESS BY NOT
PLACING ANY ADDITIONAL BURDENS
ON US AND WE NEED. REGULATORY
CERTAINTY AND PREDICTABILITY I
WE DON'T NEED ANY NEW EXPENSES
AND WE DON'T NEED REGULATORY
COMPLEX- SO THAT'S POINT ONE
ALSO I WANNA MAKE THIS A QUICK
OBSERVATION ABOUT THIS
CONVERSATION AND SEEING TO SEE-
YOU'LL SEE HIM TO SEE IS A
SUCCESS- IT REFLECTS KIND OF THE
GENIUS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS DECIDE YOU KNOW WHAT HOW
ARE WE GOING TO DO THIS. AND
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT
AND THEY GET IT IN A WAY THAT.
YEAH I THINK WE HAVE TO MINUTES
NOT. BUT ITS WORK AND AS SOMEONE
WHO IS- BEEN DOING THIS FOR A
WHILE IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
SINCE I'VE SEEN THIS BREATH. OF
GROUP COMING TO THE SUPPORT OF
ANYTHING THAT LOOKS LIKE A
REGULATED THERE IS WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT MEANS DEEP- IT'S
ACTUALLY PRETTY PRETTY PASSION
AS WELL- AND IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
THAT'S GOT TO GIVE ONE PAUSE
ABOUT. A TINKERING WITH WITH
THAT MODEL- AND ONE MUST THINK
ABOUT KIND OF THE VALUE THAT IT
THAT IT BRINGS. SO LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF LICENSING
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THIS
CONVERSATION IN MY MIND IS THAT
THE LICENSING IS KIND OF BEING
TALKED ABOUT- UP HERE IS SOME
KIND OF UNREALIZED GOLD AND- YOU
KNOW THOUGHT. PROCESS THAT
DOESN'T REALLY REFLECT WHAT
HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA AND WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE WORLD- I'M VERY
CONFIDENT THAT THAT THIS WILL
CREATE HIGHER COSTS- THAT
INCREASE THE COST OF THE TEST-
BOTH THE ACTUAL OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS TO ENTRY. THERE ARE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED C. L. E. WHICH IS ALSO
GOING TO CREATE COSTS FOR THE
THERAPIST- MEAL THERE WAS
REFERENCE TO THE STUDY I MEAN A-
VERY QUALIFIED. ENTITY THAT
REGULARLY DOES STUDIES ON THE
COSTS RELATIVE TO DCA BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS- AS IS DONE VERY
THOROUGH STUDY ON KIND OF WHAT
IT WILL COST AND IT'S A FIVE
FOLD INCREASE. IT'S A THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHATEVER. I'M IT'S NOT
GONNA BE IN LIKE. WHAT MAYBE
MAYBE IN MISSISSIPPI- I OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IT WOULD BE A
CALIFORNIA LICENSE. IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE REGULATORS
HAVE A STATE OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE. AND IN A VERY DIFFICULT
TASK AND SO WE SHOULD BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT WE SHOULDN'T-
TRY TO PRETEND THAT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE- ALSO IF YOU LOOK AT
IT- YOU KNOW ONE OF THEIR MAJOR
PROBLEMS FOR WHY WE NEED
LICENSING IS SO THAT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN DO ITS JOB
IRONICALLY TO MEET IS
UNANIMOUSLY AND WILL SEPARATELY
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ON THE OTHER
SIDE THING THEN AND NOW. WE HAVE
WHAT WE NEED TO SEE HIM TO SEE
IS A VERY GOOD PARTNER. AND C.
M. D. C. ONE OF THE KNOCKS ON US
YET TO SEE IS THAT IT FOCUSES
TOO MUCH ON. TRAFFICKING I FIND
THAT KIND OF AN ASTONISHING
ASSERTION- THAT IS ONE OF THE
ISSUES OF THE DAY WHICH REALLY
NEEDS TO BE. YOU KNOW GOT
MASTER. AND PARTICULARLY. IN THE
SENATE DISTRICT- EIGHT YOU KNOW
. ONE OF THE PRIMARY. I GUESS
OBJECTIONS TO SEE AND DO YOU SEE
IS THAT WELL THE DEFICIT THE
DEFECT IN THE C. M. D. C. MODEL
IS THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH. OF
THE C. M. D. C. THERE'S SOME
THERE'S SOME FOLKS OUT THERE
OPERATING THAT AREN'T SUBJECT TO
THE CFTC CERTIFICATION- THE
ASSUMPTION IS THAT IF THERE'S A
LICENSING REGIME. EVERYBODY WILL
GET LICENSE EVERYONE WILL COMPLY
AND THAT'S JUST. NOT THE
EXPERIENCE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S NOT TRUE- EVERYBODY
SUPPOSED TO HAVE CAR INSURANCE
AND THERE'S A DRAMATIC NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. WHO DON'T HAVE SO IT'S
NOT REALLY ACTUALLY GONNA SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM NECESSARILY- SO A
COUPLE THINGS SPECIFICALLY THE
FINANCING- THE KIND OF THE BACK
OF THE ENVELOPE APPROACH THAT I
SAW WAS SUGGESTED. ONE OF THE
WAYS THEY'RE GONNA PAY FOR IT IS
SWEET CMT C. SPOTS. DOES NOT.
IT'S NOT LEGAL IT WOULD BE A
TAKE. ON THE REPORT WHICH IS
LONG I JUST SIXTY PAGES. DOESN'T
ACTUALLY HAVE A LOT OF REAL DATA
DATA ABOUT. WHAT'S WRONG WITH C.
M. D. C. AS IT RELATES TO
CONSUMERS. AND LICENSEE. I'M NOT
EVEN ACTUALLY A LOT OF GREAT
ANECDOTES ABOUT THE GREAT ARM.
THAT'S HAPPENING THE CALIFORNIAN
I DON'T HAPPEN TO BELIEVE. THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT CONSUMERS
THINK. IS A GOOD RATIONALE FOR
TRYING TO GET IN THERE AND DO
THE KIND OF THIS DRAMATIC
OVERHAUL OF THE LICENSING OF. A
GIGANTIC INDUSTRY NOW. IF
CONSUMERS ARE BEING HARMED IN
THAT CAN BE SHOWN THAT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION. THE
OTHER THING IS- IT IT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE- DID THEY REPORT ASSUMES
THAT GOING TO A LICENSING WILL
ESSENTIALLY CREATE STATEWIDE
PREEMPTION OF WHAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE DOING- AND SOMEHOW
THAT WILL SAVE MONEY FOR THE
ENTITIES THAT INTERACT IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS AND THAT
KIND OF THING THAT HASN'T BEEN
MY EXPERIENCE THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO PREEMPT. LOCAL AUTHORITY OVER
SOME OF THESE ESTABLISHMENTS IF
WE LEARNED ANYTHING DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE LEARN THAT YOU KNOW
LOCAL AUTHORITIES AND PARTICULAR
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE AN
EXTRARDINARY AMOUNT OF CONTROL
AND THAT'S APPROPRIATE AND
THAT'S RIGHT- SO. FOR US WHO ARE
DEEPLY STEEPED IN THE INDUSTRY
AND WHAT WORKS WE SUPPORT C. M.
D. C. FROM A COUPLE OTHER THINGS
IS BRINGING BACK THE EXAM SHOULD
NOT BE SOMETHING THAT'S- LIFE-
30% FAIL RATE. CURRENTLY THE
THERAPIST PROFESSION IS VERY
ACCESSIBLE IT'S INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE IT'S NINETY PLUS PERCENT
WOMEN AND AN EXAM IF NOT DONE
PROPERLY AND THEY HAVE A
SPECIFIC EXAMINE MY- UP EITHER
OWNED. BY THEIR OWN DOCUMENT
SAYS THEY'LL BE 30% PEOPLE
THAT'LL BE WASHED OUT OF THE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PASS
THAT EXAM. THIS BODY HAS BEEN
VERY CONCERNED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS WHAT AN EXAM DOES FOR
DIVERSITY INCLUSION AND THAT
SORT OF THING AND THAT SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT VERY CAREFULLY. THE
OTHER THINGS THAT I NOTICE IS-
THE TIME FRAMES ARE ASTONISHING
NINETY- DENTISTS TO PACE THE
IMPOSITION OF A SCOPE OF
PRACTICE WITHOUT DELAY OR DRUNK.
ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED
THERE'S NO PRACTICE CONVERSATION
IN CALIFORNIA KNOWS THAT'S GOING
TO BE A MULTI YEAR SLOG AT BEST-
THOSE. THIS ONE DEFINITELY GOT
MY ATTENTION THAT THERE WILL BE
MONITORING SAVINGS FROM
IMPLEMENTING A NEW IT SYSTEM FOR
A PUBLIC ENTITY- I'LL LET THAT
SINK IN FOR JUST A SECOND I
ASSUME THE CFTC WILL HAND OVER
ITS DATABASE. OF COURSE THERE'S
A LOT OF PRIVACY ISSUES ELATED
TO THAT ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
THEY'LL DO GRANDFATHERING IS
ALLOW OR WILL REQUIRE- SOME OF
THE LEGACY FOLKS. TO HAND OVER
THEIR TAX RETURNS SO THAT THEY
CAN PROVE HIMSELF I THINK THIS
THIS. THIS IDEA. SURFACED A
COUPLE OF DAYS BEFORE A WINNER
HEARING WAS ORIGINALLY-
ORIGINALLY SCHEDULED IT HASN'T
GOTTEN REALLY ANY KIND OF
THOROUGH REVIEW AND I WAS REALLY
DELIGHTED TO HEAR THE CHAIRS
ASKING SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE END YOU
SEE BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT'S%
THE PROPER APPROACH AND LET'S
LET'S DIVE IN LET'S ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES. LET'S SEE WHERE THERE
ARE SOME. CHALLENGES OR ISSUES
ALWAYS SEEM TO SEE WHERE WE CAN
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR THERAPISTS
FOR THOSE CONSUMERS UP TO THE
VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING MAYBE
GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT MORE TOOLS-
THAT KIND OF THING- LICENSING AS
ENVISIONED IN THIS REPORT
DOESN'T EXIST. IN CALIFORNIA IT
WILL BE VERY COMPLICATED IT
WOULD BE VERY EXPENSIVE- AND IT
WILL BE LAID ON AN INDUSTRY THAT
IS STRUGGLING- MILE SO I THINK
FOR US THE ENERGY SPENT TALKING
ABOUT LICENSING WOULD BE BETTER
SPENT LOOKING AT. IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE AN EXISTING INSTANCE YOU
THAT'S VERY SUCCESSFUL VERY
ESTABLISHED TO USE KIND OF A
METAPHOR. THAT BEEN GOING ON IN
MY HOUSE AT THE- IF THE KITCHEN
NEEDS REMODEL THAT'S YEAH.
THAT'S FINE LET'S NOT THIS MAN
IT AND PRETEND THAT WE CAN BUILD
SOMETHING BETTER FROM SCRATCH
OVER HERE IN ANOTHER LOCATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO- RESPOND
ANY OTHER THINGS THAT THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND.
THANK YOU BYE AND BEFORE WE MOVE
TO QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS THAT AT
THE RISK OF OPENING UP. THE
WHOLE PURPOSE FOR HAVING PANELS
WHICH IS SOMEWHAT UNUSUAL FOR
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A FULL AND- FAIR
AND OPEN CONVERSATION ABOUT
THESE ISSUES SO THAT. WELL WE
HAVE NO PRECONCEIVED NOTION AS
TO HOW THIS. ENDS UP. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE DO HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
ON THE RECORD SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE AN APPROPRIATE DECISION. AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME SO HAVING
SAID THAT I'M GOING TO START AT
THE TOP. AND GIVE EACH ONE OF
THE PANELISTS ON THIS PARTICULAR
PANEL. TWO MINUTES- TO OFFER ANY
POINT COUNTERPOINT TO WHAT'S
BEEN SAID BY ANY OF THEM
STARTING WITH MISTER BOB BENSON
SERVED TAKEN AWAY. YOU'RE ON
YOU'RE ON MUTE I'M NOT GOING TO
COUNT THIS AGAINST YOUR TIME NOW
YOU'RE ON. OKAY THANK YOU- YEAH
OPPONENTS OF LICENSURE HAVE NOT
ANSWERED FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION OF
WELL FIRST OF ALL. HOW DOES A
PEACE OFFICER WALKING INTO AN
ESTABLISHMENT- WHERE- IFSOMEONE
DOES THAT'S NOT CHOSEN TO OBTAIN
CA AND PIECES OF RETENTION-
HAVE- AN ABILITY TO REALLY KNOW
HOW TO RECOVER REACT TO WHAT'S
GOING ON TO MAKE A JUDGMENT
SPARE- IF YOU HAVE MANDATORY
LICENSURE WELL UNDER PERCENT OF
PEOPLE UNDER THE TENT. SO TO
SPEAK- IT'S A CLEAR CUT-
SITUATION- OFFICER CAN SAVE
PLEASE SHOW ME YOUR LICENSE-
CHECK AGAINST DATABASE-
MAINTAINED BY THE STATE BOARD
AND WOULD KNOW DEFINITIVELY
WHETHER SOMEBODY IS OPERATING WE. TO OR NOT THAT'S ONE ASPECT.
THE STATEMENT WAS MADE BY MR
FORM- CHAIR- SUGGESTING THAT SO
THE COST OF THE LEDGER WOULD BE
FIVE TIMES. WHAT IT IS FOR ANY
SEM PIECES FOR PROPRIO OVER A
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THAT'S NOT
SUPPORTED BY THE FACT THAT THE
MEDIAN- LICENSEES GAVE BIRTH TO
YOUR LICENSE AND THE FORTY FIVE
STATES DO HAVE LICENSING IF ONE
HUNDRED FORTY DOLLARS A YEAR-
THE- WE HAVE FIVE. THE FIRST
RESPONSE- TO GERMAN ROSS-
COMMENTS SAID IN OUR
CONVERSATION I WAS. SHARED WITH
THEM LAST NOVEMBER I SPENT SOME
TIME PUTTING TOGETHER MODEL
WORKING COSTS FOR A YEAR A
LICENSING REGIME AND-
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ENDED UP
CONCLUDING THAT- IT WOULD WORK-
WITH EACH INDIVIDUAL FEE OF A
HUNDRED SIXTY DOLLARS
TRANSITIONING THEM AFTER THAT
INITIAL PERIOD UP TO A HUNDRED
NINETY DOLLARS- THERE ARE
CERTAINLY SOME ASPECTS OF THE
MAKE. THINGS MORE EXPENSIVE- IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL BOARDS ONE
THOSE ARE FACTORED INTO BATTLE.
THAT INFORMATION AND THE
REQUIRED BY PEOPLE THAT SO THE
ANSWER THE CENTER ALSO WAS
LARGELY INCORPORATED- IN THE-
ANSWER TO ONE OF THE SUNRISE
QUESTIONS ON THE DOCUMENTS JUST
RECENTLY WELCOME ABOUT. I
SUGGEST THAT WE BEGAN. ALSO
SERVED- AND THAT YOU THE PEOPLE
USED THAT. SOME CRISPY THAT WE
PUT TOGETHER ALONG WITH TAKING A
THOUGHTFUL WORK AT FOURTEEN PAGE
SHOW PROPOSED BILL- THAT- WAS
ALSO WERE INTRODUCED IN RECENT
DAYS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
OPPORTUNITY TO REBUT. THANK YOU
SIR- MISTER SPEAKER ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. I'M NOT TOO MUCH I
JUST JUST WANT TO POINT OUT- YOU
KNOW WHILE YOU WELL I APPRECIATE
YOU KNOW THE POSITION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF WICHITA KANSAS AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NOT HAD
ANY OPPOSITION FROM ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICES FROM EIGHT
POLICE ASSOCIATION- AND- HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT LICENSURE-
IN FACT YOU KNOW MOST RECENTLY
THE CITY OF ROCHESTER MINNESOTA.
I WENT TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
EXPAND UPON THEM HOW IMPORTANT
IT WOULD BE FOR THEM AND THEIR
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES- YOU
KNOW WE CAN WE CAN PROVIDE DATA
OUT LIKE I SAID I. DON'T WANT TO
BE BETTER FOR ANYBODY ARE. ON
THIS CALL- I'D ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT. YOU KNOW MISTER
JOHNSON DIED- PHYSICIAN ON EXAM
THIRTY PERCENT- IF I. I'M
READING MY DATA CORRECTLY 53% OF
PEOPLE PASSED THE BAR
EXAMINATION SO YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE WE'RE TALKING THIRTY
PERCENT. AND THERE THAT DO NOT
PASS- I CAN'T TELL YOU THE
NUMBERS OFF HAND ON THAT THE
SECOND GO AROUND WITH THAT WOULD
GO UP TO BUY. YEAH WE HAVE TO AT
SOME POINT RECOGNIZE THAT YOU
KNOW THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE-
YOU KNOW STICKING OUT SERVICES
FOR HEALTH RELATED REASONS AND
WE SHOULD PUT SOME REASONABLE
EXPECTATION OF COMPETENCY- AND
MEASURED AT COMPETENCY- AND
BEFORE WE SEND THEM OUT INTO THE
WORK FORCE. THAT'S ALL I HAVE
SURE THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR- MS
HARMAN ANY FURTHER COMMENTS. YES
THANK YOU THIS IS IN RESPONSE TO
MR BENTSEN'S COMMENT ABOUT AS I
UNDERSTOOD IT C. M. T. C. R.
REALLY NOT HELPING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND NOT. AND I HAVE
TO SAY THAT NOTHING COULD BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH THINGS
HAVE GOTTEN BETTER WE SEE A MTC
INVOLVED SO IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS C. A. M. P. C. IS
CONDUCTED. COUNTYWIDE TRAININGS
FOR LOCAL POLICE ON IDENTIFYING
ILLICIT MASSAGE ESTABLISHMENTS.
OUR TEAM AND SEE A MTC HAVE
INITIATE A SHADED PILOT PROGRAMS
OF CRIMINAL AND REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT. WITHIN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN CITIES LIKE CAMPBELL
CALIFORNIA. SHE COUNSELED FOR
CMT C. ASSISTED CAMPBELL CITY
COUNCIL IN RETRACTING LOCAL
ORDINANCES FOR MASSAGE
BUSINESSES PROVIDING INSPECTORS
AND POLICE GOOD TOOLS FOR BETTER
OVERSIGHT THIS WORK HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND THERE'S SOMETHING
ELSE TOO THAT I THINK MR BENTSEN
IS MISSING WHEN WE SAY THIS IS
WHY C. A. M. P. C. WORKS. WHEN
THE POLICE IDENTIFY EIGHTY
ILLICIT MASSAGE PARLOR WE NEED
TO MOVE FAST YOU HAVE TO BE
NIMBLE. AND BECAUSE THESE PLACES
IT CAN BE A SORT OF A GAME OF
WHACK A MOLE YOU TAKE OUT ONE
AND THERE'S A POP UP IN ANOTHER
CITY AND SO YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A MEANINGFUL. AND THE
FISSION PROCESS AND THAT'S WHAT
C. A. M. P. T. C. OFFERS IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THE OTHER
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION AND
COLLABORATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. MR CONNECTION YOU GET
THE LAST WORD. THAT'S THAT'S A
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THAT- I GUESS THAT'S
JUST HOW IT WORKS SO A COUPLE OF
THINGS I I'LL LET LAW
ENFORCEMENT KIND OF. RESPONDED
THAT OBVIOUSLY WON'T BE ABLE TO
DO THAT IN THIS HEARING BUT I'VE
NEVER SEEN A LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OFFICER THE STOCK IN DOING THEIR
JOB JOB- BY LACK OF A PIECE OF
PAPER IT'S JUST NOT REALLY HOW
IT WORKS- THEY ALSO CAN ACTUALLY
GO ON THE WEBSITE AND IF THEIR
LOCAL JURISDICTION REQUIRES THAT
THEY CAN GO ON THE WEBSITE AND
SEE IF YOU SEE AND LOOK UP
WHETHER SOMEONE HAS THAT- SO AND
- BECAUSE IT SUPPOSEDLY WORKS A
DIFFERENT WAY. IN OTHER STATES
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY UNIQUE
ANIMAL I HAVE LOOK AT THE
ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE. IN THE
BE KIND OF THE STEALTH SUNRISE
DOCUMENT- BUT THE ANALYSIS THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS INCLUDING A
RESPONSE TO THE SUNRISE
DOCUMENTS. DONE BY CAPITAL
COUNTY PARTNERS IS THERE- IT'S
ROBUST IT'S THOROUGH AND IT'S
DONE BY SOMEONE THAT IS DEEPLY
STEEPED IN HOW IT WORKS IN
CALIFORNIA. AS TO THE TEST I
DON'T WANT TO. PREDETERMINE THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE I JUST KNOW
AMONG MANY OF MY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THERE IS A DEEP CONCERN ABOUT
THE IMPACT THAT IT'S TESTING
OUT. ON DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
AND I APPRECIATE BRINGING UP THE
BAR EXAM BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF. OUR STATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS. ABOUT THE PASSAGE RATE
AND WHAT CAN BE DONE TO MAKE
SURE. THAT IT DOESN'T BECOME A
TOOL OF EXCLUSION AS OPPOSED TO-
SOME OTHER INDICIA OF SOME KIND
OF A COMPETENCE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS GO ON. ALL THE
TIME SO JUST BEFORE WE ASSUME
WE'RE GOING TO DO A TEST. WE
JUST NEED TO LOOK AT IT FROM A
CALIFORNIA LANDS AND HOW IT
WORKS ON OUR VERY DIVERSE
POPULATION. AND ARE WE DOING THE
RIGHT THING I DON'T I DON'T HAVE
ACTUALLY A PRE JUDGED OPINION ON
THAT. I JUST KNOW THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS LOOKED AT IT
VERY CAREFULLY AND IF WE'RE
GONNA GO DOWN THIS PATH. THAT
NEEDS TO BE PART OF A VERY
THOROUGH AND CRITICAL ANALYSIS.
AND ONE FINAL THING I GUESS IS-
I THOUGHT I HEARD MR BENSON SAY
THAT A BILL HAS BEEN INTRODUCED.
I'M I'M ESTIMATES. THAT I
APOLOGIZE THAT IS THERE A BILL
NUMBER. I'M SURE YOU ALL CAN
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT
OFFLINE OKAY. NOPE NO WORK THANK
YOU I SEE THAT A MEMBER OF THE
COUNCIL HAS HIS HAND UP ON THE
SCREEN. WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE
THAT- COMMENT- IN IN WRITING
DIRECTED TO- OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE
COMMITTEE AND WILL MAKE THAT A
MATTER OF A RECORD SIR. SO THANK
YOU TO OUR PANELISTS ON THIS
MASSAGE THERAPY REGULATION MODEL
MODELING PANEL- LET'S NOW TURN
TO- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES.
FOR BOURBON ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. YOU THE PLEASE THERE
IT IS THANK YOU SURE OFTEN AND I
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW THE ABILITY
FOR FOLKS TO IT TO ANSWER AND
HAVE A LITTLE BACK AND FORTH
BECAUSE I AGREE YEAH THAT WAS
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
OUT OF TODAY'S- LEASE THIS PANEL
ON TODAY'S HEARING ANYTHING
THAT'S HELPFUL- FOR ALL OF US AS
WE DELIBERATE THAT THE DIFFERENT
MODELS HERE- AND I WAS ALSO WANT
TO SAY I WAS HAPPY TO HEAR MR
COMMUTES AND SAY THAT- HE AGREES
THAT YOU KNOW WE DID IF THE IF
THEIR CAR TO BE HAD ABOUT
REMODEL. THAT THAT HE'S OPEN TO
THAT I DIDN'T GET THAT SENSE.
SOME OF THE ANSWERS. TO SOME
QUESTIONS IN THE EARLIER PANEL-
AND SO I'M GLAD TO HEAR AND-
THAT EVERYBODY IS OPEN. TO IT TO
DIFFERENT- IMPROVEMENTS EITHER
TO THE EXISTING MODEL. ARE THE
ME TO SAY THAT I'M I'M GLAD THAT
AT LEAST EVERYBODY. IS OPEN TO
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE EXISTING
MODEL- AND I THINK IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO. TO HEAR THAT. A
QUESTION FOR EVERYBODY I SUPPOSE
IS HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN THE
MASSAGE INDUSTRY. A BIGGER
PROBLEM. IN STATES THAT HAVE A
LICENSOR. I CAN I CAN ANSWER
THIS. PLEASE WELL I EXCUSE ME
OUT OF HERE THE FURNITURE OFF I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU WANT TO- I
DON'T I DON'T LISTEN I DON'T
MIND I'M NOT GOING TO STICK
STRICTLY TO THE PANELS BUT LET'S
START WITH PANEL B. WHICH IS THE
MASSAGE THERAPY MODELING PANEL
AND THEN. WE CAN MOVE TO THE
COUNCIL TO ANSWER THIS. ANY
TAKERS IN PANEL B. MR BENSON.
THIS RECORD. I'M QUESTION IF I'M
HEARING YOU CORRECTLY SIR AS IS
HUMAN TRAFFICKING- PROBLEM IN
OTHER STATES WHERE WHERE THEY
ARE NICE IS IT A BIGGER PROBLEM
IT YOU KNOW YOU GET GIVEN- THE
IF WE ALL AGREE THAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS AN ISSUE THAT
MUST BE ADDRESSED IS IT A BIGGER
PROBLEM IN STATES WITH LICENSURE
THEN IN IN CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS
A- DIFFERENT MODEL. I DON'T KNOW
IF WE CAN SAY THAT AND IT IT
REALLY- YOU KNOW EVERY AFTERNOON
BUT IF ANYBODY'S BEEN FOLLOWING
AND YOU KNOW WE DO A LOT OF WORK
WITH. LAWYERS AND YOU KNOW
THEY'VE TURNED DOWN A ROLE AND-
YOU KNOW OTHER FOLKS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY.
YOU KNOW. PUTTING IT IN.
PERSPECTIVE CALIFORNIA FLORIDA
PROBABLY THE WORST WHEN IT COMES
TO PROTECTING YOU HAVE. LICENSE
PERSON BY LICENSE- YOU KNOW I
DON'T THINK- YOU KNOW. WELL I
THINK WE CAN DEFINITIVELY SAY
THAT EVEN IN STATES THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED- RIGOROUS
RESTRICTIONS ON THE CLUSTER
ACTIVE BACK. IN AN ATTEMPT TO-
ADDRESS HUMAN TRAFFICKING THIS
YEAR HAS NOT WORKED- INTO THE
POINT OUT OF THE EMPTY SEAT AND
YOU KNOW I. WANT TO GO ON RECORD
AND THEN THE MDC DOES A LOT OF
THINGS WELL- AND I BELIEVE THAT-
BUT YOU KNOW WE DO- JIM IT'S
HARD TO FIND I BELIEVE- WORK.
WITH MUNICIPALITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- IN CREATING ORDINANCES
THAT HELP THEM ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE YOU KNOW
JUST IN THE LAST THREE WEEKS
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUE A BMP.
I'VE WRITTEN TO ORGAN ANSWERS-
WE'VE WRITTEN AN OREGON STATE.
COLORADO THAT NOW IS. RIGHT AN
ORDINANCE IN COLORADO THAT IS
NOW YOU KNOW THE SUBJECT OF
STATE LAW- BECAUSE LOOKING AT IT
THROUGH. THE CRIMINALITY LINES
AS OPPOSED TO. YOU KNOW PUTTING
IT OVERLY UNNECESSARY BARGAINING
ON THE MOST FASTER- SEVEN YOUR
QUESTION I YOU KNOW I THINK IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE. I CAN GET BACK
TO YOU ON ON NUMBERS BUT- I
DON'T THINK THAT- THERE IS A WAY
TO ANSWER THAT ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER. BECAUSE OF THE HEALTH
COMPLEX MASSAGE OR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING YEAH- IT JUST
DOESN'T HAPPEN YEAH. AND IT'S
NOT JUST THAT. YOU KNOW YOU'RE
NOT REALLY SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
ARE. BUT ON EARLIER IT'S YOU
KNOW THERE IS THERE IS A-
FINANCIAL. THERE'S LONGER AND
YOU KNOW IT GETS YOU KNOW IT CAN
GET YOU STARTED HERE- THANK YOU
HEATHER THANK YOU. YEAH I'M
LOOKING AT A GALLERY FULL OF
PEOPLE AND YOU HAVE TO SIT HERE
WHEN I SIT HERE SO. MR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE
TO ADD TO THAT IN ONE MINUTE.
YES I CAN DO ANYTHING LESS THAN
THAT- YOU KNOW I AGREE MUSIC
MISTER SPEAKER TO DO REASON. AN
ACTUAL- QUANTIFIED STATISTICS.
ARE ABOUT THAT BUT- YOU CAN SEE
IN THE NEWS THEY WERE VERY WELL
KNOWN CASES- IN FLORIDA A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WHEN THE OWNER OF A
VERY WELL KNOWN FOOTBALL TEAM.
WAS CLOCKED IN AT AN
ESTABLISHMENT WHICH WAS-
INVOLVING HUMAN TRAFFICKING. IT
WAS VERY SAD SITUATION IN THE
STATE OF GEORGIA- YEAR AND A
HALF AGO WITH A SHOOTER IN A-
ESTABLISHMENTS WERE INVOLVED IN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SO WE DID IT'S
A VERY SERIOUS- NATIONAL
PROBLEM. I WOULD OFFER THAT THE
COMMITTEE RECEIVED A LETTER FROM
THE NATIONAL CENTER ON SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION. BED IS WORKING
WITH STATES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AND ACTUALLY OTHER
COUNTRIES ABROAD. AND THERE WAS
SO IMPRESSED WITH THIS C. M. D.
C. MODEL. AND FIND IT TO BE SO
POWERFUL. THEY DEFECTED IN
DEALING WITH ISSUE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. THE FUTURE OF THEIR
LAST YEAR IN AN INTERNATIONAL
CONFERENCE. OUR WORD THE-
PRESENTED NOT ONLY TO OTHER
STATES WHAT DO OTHER COUNTRIES
TO TAKE A VERY CLOSE LOOK AT THE
CALIFORNIA MODEL IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY MAY WANT TO BE IN YOUR
LIFE. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU I
GUESS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA GET THIS INFORMATION
PERFECT. PERVERT BERMAN- WITH A
QUESTION PROBABLY FOR BENSON
INSPECTOR WE ARE ONE OF THE
CRITICISMS OF LICENSURE IS THAT
ENFORCEMENT WOULD TAKE MUCH
LONGER WHICH WE CERTAINLY SEEN
AS A PROBLEM WITH SOME BOARDS.
WHAT WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT CONCERN. ESPECIALLY GIVEN
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS IN IN THIS
INDUSTRY. IT STARTED OUT WITH
THE WITH THAT ONE- THE- MANY OF
MANY OF THE FEATURES- OF- THERE
HAVE BEEN TALKED ABOUT- BY CMT
C. ADVOCATES- HERE TODAY ARE
ALSO CONTAINED IN THE- OF THE
GRAPH BUILT OF THAT SO WE HAD
INTRODUCED- SOMETIME BACK HELP
AT THIS POINT- BUT UNTIL WE PUT
IT OUT THERE FOR PUBLIC VIEW-
THE SUMMARY SUSPENSION IS THERE-
THE- OR RADIO. CONTROL-
PENALTIES. IS EXPANSIVE- IN THE
PROPOSED BILL- THE WITH THE BIRD
SHE HAS BUT- WITH REQUIRED
LICENSURE- ALMOST ALWAYS THERE
BUT SHOULD BE COVERED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WOULD BE
INVOLVED- IN TERMS OF A JURY
GETTING CASES AND- THAT SERVE
WITH GREEK TOO WE BELIEVE STUFF
A STRONGER- SITUATION AND IN
TERMS OF STAYING ON TOP OF.
THESE CHALLENGES OUT OF CERTAIN
HOW TO SHARPEN THE PENCIL HERE
BUT- THE QUESTION IS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IS. WHO FORGOT TO
PARAPHRASE MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE A
JURY ASK IT BUT- WITH A LICENSED
ORGANIZATION DO YOU EXPECT TO
HAVE THE SAME TIME STANDARDS
THAT. THE COUNCIL HAS WITH
RESPECT TO DISCIPLINARY PROCESS
. GIVEN ALL THE THINGS THAT
HAPPEN. IN STATE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS THAT ARE REQUIRED BY OUR
CALIFORNIA LAW. SURE BERMAN THAT
I'VE- MESSED UP HE SAYS IT'S
OKAY THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT THANK
YOU. AND. BUT IF YOU DON'T MIND
IF I JUMP AND QUITE AND THIS IS
AN ISSUE AND IT IS AND WE'VE YOU
KNOW BEEN DEALING WITH THOSE
YOUNG FOR MY SEVEN YEARS- HERE-
AND LONGER- AND THAT YOU KNOW
ACTIVE LICENSING TOWARD PEOPLE
WITH ACCUSATIONS AGAINST THEM
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH I'M STATE
THOSE. IN FLORIDA AND GEORGIA
AND ALABAMA- IS- A TEMPORARY
SUSPENSION OF THAT LICENSE WHILE
DUE PROCESS- PLAYS OUT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ISSUES AND WHY THAT
AND YOU KNOW SO WIDELY REPORTED
IN THE MEDIA AS YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S AN ACCUSATION AND IT
MAKES IT TO THE CHRIST THE PRESS
INQUIRES WITH THE BOARD AND THAT
PERSON STILL HAS AN ACTIVE LIFE
BECAUSE THE PROCESS IS EXPLAINED
OUT MATS YOU KNOW THE CARDS THAT
WE WERE TOLD ME THAT'S WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO KNOW SPECIFIC
STATES DECIDE- SO WHAT WE ARE
ADVOCATING FOR IS WHEN THERE'S
AN ACCUSATION IF THERE IS. ANY
SORT OF LITIGATION AT THE
AUTOMATIC- TEMPORARY SUSPENSION
OF THAT LICENSE WHILE DUE
PROCESS PLAYS OUT I CAN'T SAY
THAT IN FACT YOU CAN GUARANTEE
ANY TIME FRAME- YOU KNOW LIKE
THE C. MCC I BELIEVE IS AT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE DAYS ARE
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT FIVE
YOU KNOW IT'S UP TO THE STATES
IN THE STATE COURT SYSTEMS FIVE
YOU KNOW WE ARE WORKING WITH
WITH THE STATE AND YEAH SIX-
HELPING YOU FIX THAT PROBLEM
DRESS THE ISSUE WELL MAYBE YOU
COULD HELP US EXCEPT WITH REGARD
OF SEVERAL OF OUR BOARDS AND
GIRLS BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT IT MAY DIFFER FROM
BORDER TO BORDER BUREAU TO
BUREAU BUT- IT MINISTRATION
BILLY YOU MAY BE ABLE TO DO THAT
BUT THEN YOU HAVE A VERY SHORT
TIME LINE IN WHICH TO. TAKE THE
ACCUSATION AND BEGIN THE PROCESS
AND YOU MAY NOT HAVE YOUR
INVESTIGATION COMPLETE AT THAT
POINT AND IF A CRIMINAL PROCESS
IS INVOLVED YOU ARE HERE MY
UNDERSTANDING AGAIN AGAIN
PERHAPS DEPENDED ON THE BOARD
YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE JUDGE IN
THE CRIMINAL PROCEEDING. AND
HAVE THE JUDGE APPROVED A
TEMPORARY LICENSE. SO I YOU WILL
WHO FUNCTION IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE- WITH LACE. ARE CLIMBING IN
THE NEWS. HERE IN CAL. WHETHER
IT'S GOOD ONE OR A BAD ONE. BUT
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH WHAT WE
HAVE HERE BERMAN. BUT THAT'S ALL
I'VE GOT FOR NOW FEATURE OFF.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE QUESTIONS I-
YOU KNOW MY CONCERNS HAVE TO DO
WITH THE REASON FOR PURSUING
LICENSURE IN THE COST OF THE
LICENSE AND THAT'S SIMPLY IT FOR
ME AND WE WERE JUST GOING TO
HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH THOSE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE LICENSE. FOR
PUBLIC OR CONSUMER SAFETY
REASONS WE DON'T LICENSE TO
PROVIDE ECONOMIC ADVANTAGE OR TO
AFFORD A STATUS TO ANY
PARTICULAR ROCK OCCUPATION FOR
ANY PARTICULAR REASON IT'S
SIMPLY THAT AND WE KNOW THAT
LICENSURE CAN BE A BARRIER TO
EMPLOYMENT LICENSURECAN BE A
BARRIER TO WORK. AND THEY CAN
CERTAINLY COST MONEY AND IT
CERTAINLY COSTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR
NOT AND DESPITE THE BEST EFFORTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES INCLUDING SURE
BERMAN AND THE MEMBERS OF THIS
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS A COMMITTEE. YOU
KNOW UNFORTUNATELY AND THIS GOES
. WAY BEFORE MY TIME HERE AND
WAY BEFORE MY COLLEAGUE SIMON
PROBABLY WAY BEFORE OUR
PREDECESSORS TIME WE HEAR WE
DECIDE TO LICENSE AN OCCUPATION
PRESUMABLY FOR THE APPROPRIATE
REASONS TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
AND CONSUMER SAFETY. WE CREATE A
BOARD A VERY EXPENSIVE BOARD
BECAUSE OF OUR WAGE AND BENEFIT
SCHEDULES HERE WITH STATE
WORKERS AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO OFFER.
AND THEN WE HAND THE NEW
LICENSEE OF BILL. I HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT SINCE WE'RE
DEALING WITH A FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE NONPROFIT CORPORATION
ORGANIZED UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW.
AND PROVIDED A TAX EXEMPTION
PRESUMABLY BY THE FEDERAL
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I HAVE
QUESTIONS AS TO WHETHER THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. CAN SWEEP
THREE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
OUT OF A PRIVATE FIVE OH ONE C.
THREES. A BANK ACCOUNT AND SWEEP
IT INTO THE STATE TREASURY. AND
WHETHER THAT CONSTITUTES A
TAKING- WHEN THE FIVE OH ONE SEE
THREE HAS AN IRIS FEDERAL IRIS
RESPONSIBILITY AS- WELL AS A
RESPONSIBILITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA UPON DISSOLUTION. TO
DIRECT THAT MONEY FOR TAX
EXEMPT. PURPOSES SO AT SOME
POINT THOSE WHO HAVE A PROPER
DIFFIE STUDY THAT SUGGESTS THAT
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT WHETHER
YOU'VE OBTAINED A LEGAL OPINION.
AS TO WHETHER THAT PROCESS
ACTUALLY WORKS AND HOW WE GO
ABOUT IT AND WHETHER WE HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT. AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
TAKING OF PRIVATE PROPERTY WHEN
WE DO THAT. BUT FINALLY IT
OCCURS TO ME THAT WHETHER
WHICHEVER FEE STUDY WE TAKE HER
WHETHER WE DIVIDE THEM IN THE
MAIL OR GET ANOTHER ONE. WHETHER
THE FEE STUDY SHOWS AN INCREASE
TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR
OR AN INCREASE TO TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR- AT THE OUTSET.
IT IS CLEAR TO THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS FOR ANY NUMBER OF
YEARS WITH. THIRTY SOMETHING
BOARDS AND BUREAUS THAT THE COST
OF LICENSURE WILL WILL BE FAIRLY
HIGH. AND THAT THE COST OF
LICENSURE ALMOST ASSUREDLY WILL
GO UP YEAR OVER YEAR OVER YEAR
AND THE BOARD IF THERE IS ONE
WILL BE BACK HERE THE GOVERNOR
AND THE ADMINISTRATION WILL BE
BACK HERE ASKING US TO APPROVE A
FEE INCREASE IMPOSED ON THOSE
WHO ARE LICENSED. IN THIS CASE
BY A POTENTIAL. MASSAGE THERAPY
LICENSE BOARDS SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH THOSE
ISSUES HI NOT SURE BERMAN JOINS
ME IN THIS. THESE ARE DIFFICULT
ISSUES WE WILL DEVOTE THE TIME
AND ATTENTION NECESSARY. TO GET
THIS RIGHT BUT- LAYS IN GERMAN
THOSE OF YOU WHO PARTICIPATED ON
OUR PANELS- AND THOSE FROM THE
COUNCIL WHO WERE HERE- I WANT TO
TELL YOU HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION
TO THIS IN THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
MADE. FOR I TURN IT OVER TO
PUBLIC COMMENT SURE BERMAN ANY
FINAL COMMENTS NO JUST
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
PARTICIPATION THANKS. OKAY LET'S
KNOW HOW EXCEPT TESTIMONY FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL WE HAVE I'M SURE VARIETY
OF WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY- SO
LET'S START WITH THE FIRST
HERE'S WHAT I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO DO YOU LOOK AROUND AND YOU
SEE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY AND THAT DOESN'T
COUNT THE NUMBER WHO ARE ON OUR
PHONE LINES. SO WHAT I'D LIKE IS
FOR YOU TO. IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
STATE YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENT IF YOU REPRESENT
ANYONE. AND THEN A VERY VERY
BRIEF STATEMENT OF YOUR
POSITION. I WOULD LIKE TO LIMIT
THE STATEMENTS OF POSITION TO
ONE TO TWO MINUTES I MAY HAVE TO
FURTHER RESTRICT THAT DEPENDING
ON THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. IF SOMEONE BEFORE
YOU SAID ESSENTIALLY THE SAME
THING THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SAY
WHAT I WOULD ASK YOU TO DO IS
SAY I'M I CONCUR IN THE PREVIOUS
STATEMENTS PROVIDED AND THAT
WILL GIVE THE SAME HAVE THE SAME
IMPACT ON ME. AND MY COLLEAGUES
AND ON THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
COMMITTEE STAFF SO LET'S PROCEED
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE NAME. OCT
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT IF
THERE IS ANY THERE IS ONE IN
YOUR POSITION PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ROTHMAN CHAIR
BERMAN AND MEMBERS I'M MONICA
WILSON COUNCILWOMAN FOR THE CITY
OF ANTIOCH CURRENTLY SERVING MY
THIRD TERM I'M ALSO THE SENIOR
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR LOVE NEVER
FAILS A NON PROFIT THAT WORKS
WITH THE SURVIVORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. I'VE BEEN ACTIVELY
WORKING IN THE ANTI TRUMP ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING WORLD FOR MANY
YEARS AND IN FACT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN I WAS THE ONLY
CALIFORNIA ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
ATTENDANCE AT THE NATIONAL
STRATEGY CONVENING ON THE
ILLICIT MASSAGE INDUSTRY IN
WASHINGTON DC. I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
SHARE WITH YOU HOW C. A. MTC HAS
BEEN A MAJOR FORCE IN MY CITY'S
FIGHT AGAINST ILLICIT MASSAGE
ESTABLISHMENTS PERJURY C.
IMPLEMENTING C. A M. T. C. OUR
CITY WAS DEALING WITH A MAJOR
EXPLOSION IN THE ILLICIT MASSAGE
BUSINESS. HOWEVER SINCE ITS
INPUT IMPLEMENTATION ACCORDING
TO OUR CHIEF OF POLICE WE'VE
SEEN A DRASTIC REDUCTION WOULD
SEE A MTC WE ARE WORKING WITH
OUR VALUABLE TIME WITH A
VALUABLE PARTNER WHOSE MODEL
WORKS AND HAS LED TO A DIRECT
ABATEMENT OF ILLICIT MASSAGE
BUSINESSES IN MY COMMUNITY. TO
ADD TO THE VALUE THERE THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY THEY CAN
MANAGE BUDGETS IN A FISCALLY
PRUDENT MANNER THAT'S ALLOWING
FOR MORE WORK TO HAPPEN IN OUR
IN OUR FIGHT TO TAKE BACK OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
ON UP ON THE BEACH IN THE WORLD
AND CHAIRMAN BACK. AND- MEMBER
DATED GENTLEMAN. I AM JUST THE
CHARM THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
CHINESE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OF
LOS ANGELES. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE CONTAMINATION CONSIDERATION
OF C. M. T. C. T. M. C. P. C.
HAS BEEN A STRONG. SUPPORTING
THE CHINESE COMMUNITY AND THE
CHURCH THAT'S JUST ME. BUT SUCH
FOR THE PEOPLE BUSINESS SINCE IT
BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND NINE GIVE
UP CHINESE AMERICAN BUSINESS AND
THE ASIAN COMMUNITY AND THAT'S
FULL AGAINST THE TRAFFICKING OF
ASIAN IMMIGRATION. IN LEGAL THEY
DIDN'T SAY A SIDE MASSAGE
BUSINESS. THERE WERE THERE WHAT
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ALLOWED. NOT TO MAKE THE- I'M SO
SORRY I'VE BEEN SICK K. EXCITED
THAT- HERE TAKE YOUR TIME WE'RE
WE'RE NOT JUST ME CHINESE
AMERICAN EX MAG MUST SUCH
BUSINESS TO DRIVE IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA M. B. THIS THING IS
THAT FROM THE CRIMINAL. ELEMENT
CHOOSING TO STATE LICENSURE WITH
ALL OF THIS MEMBERS IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO HIDE WELCOME TO FIGHT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DELL BACKGROUND
USERS. THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
ETERNITY TO MY SPEECH THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS OR ISSUE
THAT NEXT PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
SAM COMES AND GO. I AM THE
PRESIDENT OFTEN WITH HIGH END
SPOT SO IT'S THE ENGINE OF
AMERICA- AND NONPROFIT. FIVE OH
ONE C. THREE. ORGANIZATION WITH
OVER SIX HUNDRED- SUPPORT MEMBER
AND MY DAD SIXTEEN HUNDRED.
FACEBOOK MEMBER. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF KEEPING THEM HE'S
THE- THE WAY IT IS. SINCE OUR
ASSOCIATION WAS FOUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. FAMILIES THE
HAS ALREADY BEEN. RESPONSIVE TO
OUR NEEDS. S. WELL ASK PROTECT
THIS- TO HILT AND SAFETY UP.
NEXT THE SERVER. I'M SURE THAT-
DATE THE DATE HE'S ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT BUT- ELIMINATING
ELIMINATING CNPC. IS NOT DONE.
NO GOING TO HAVE MAKE ANYTHING.
BUT THAT MOM CRAZY WHICH WE DO
NOT NEED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS OMAR IN WATER I HAVE
BEEN A CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST FOR OVER TEN YEARS.
WHERE DURING THAT TIME I HAVE
OPERATED A SUCCESSFUL MASSAGE
BEAUTY AND THIS IS IN BUSINESS
IN LOS ANGELES ADDITIONALLY FOR
THE- PAST SEVERAL YEARS I HAVE
MANAGED AND TAUGHT AT A SMALL
MASSAGE SCHOOL WHICH I STARTED
HOLLYWOOD CAREER COLLEGE. I HAVE
A RATHER UNIQUE SET OF
PERSPECTIVE ON CMT C. COMING
FROM BUT THE SCHOOL OWNER AND
MASSAGE PRACTITIONER WILL POINTS
C. M. D. C. HAVE PROVEN TO BE A
VERY RESPONSIVE KNOWLEDGEABLE
AND MASSAGE FOCUSED ORGANIZATION
THAT I FEEL WOULD BE PROBABLY
ABOUT THE DIFFICULT TO
REPRODUCE. AS A MOM DEPARTMENT
OF A GOVERNMENT AGENCY FOR
SERVICE THE STATE WIDE
CERTIFICATION IS STRAIGHTFORWARD
CONSISTENT ENVIRONMENT OF.
WIDELY UNDERSTOOD FOR STUDENTS
THEY CAN BE EASILY VERIFIED THAT
OPPRESSED THE PROSPECTIVE SCHOOL
IS THE AGENCY APPROVED AND THAT
GIVES THEM CONFIDENCE IN THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE PROGRAM C. M.
D. C. HAVE EFFECTIVELY.
ELIMINATED THE PROGRAM OFF THE
PAINFUL HOURS TYPE JUNK SCHOOLS
WHICH WAS A SERIOUS PROBLEM
BEFORE AS SOMEONE RUNNING A
SCHOOL IT IS CLEAR FROM THE
CONTINUOUS LATELY FIND. CURLY
COLOR THE CHOIRMASTER CMCC IS
STOPPED BY THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY
KNOW THE FIELD AND IT IS WE
ACTUALLY DO KNOW THAT IF I HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS I CAN'T GET THE
ANSWER RIGHT AWAY WITHIN AN HOUR
USUALLY WE EMAIL. CNBC IS
CURRENTLY WORKING EFFECTIVELY IN
ALL OF THIS DIFFERENT AREAS.
WITH A WHY SWITCHING BUSINESS
PLUS THE ABILITIES TO OTHER
AGENCIES MAY BE POSSIBLE I FEEL
HE WOULD LOSE THE MASSAGE
INDUSTRY FOCUS THE C. M. D. C.
UNIQUELY PROCESSES NOT TO
MENTION THE PROBABLY INVISIBLE
CONFUSION FOR EVERYONE WHO WOULD
BE TRYING TO DEAL WITH A NEW SET
OF REGULATIONS. I WOULD LIKE. TO
SEE THE CURRENT SYSTEM CONTINUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OR GOING TO
HAVE SHORT THE COMMON JUST A- IN
ADDITION ALL OF WHO ARE SITTING
UP THERE WHO HAVE NOT SPOKEN
YET. WE HAVE AT LEAST TWENTY
SEVEN CALLERS ON THE PHONE LINE.
SO STARTING WITH THE NEXT
SPEAKER I WOULD ASK YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR- FILIATION IF
YOU'RE OR A
COMPANY. AND BRIEFLY WHICH IS
ONE MINUTE YOUR POSITION ON THE
ISSUE OF THE SUNSET REVIEW. OF
THE MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN ROB STEVE CARSON
PRESIDENT MASSAGE ENVY
CALIFORNIA FRANCHISEE
ASSOCIATION I AM HERE
REPRESENTING MYSELF AND HUNDRED
FORTY OR SO MISOGYNY LOCATIONS
WERE THE LARGEST EMPLOYER OF
MASSAGE THERAPIST IN THE STATE.
IMPLYING APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND SUCH THERAPISTS. I WAS
AROUND BEFORE THE CREATION THE
C. M. T. C. AND REMEMBER THE
DARK DAYS OF THERAPISTS HAVING
TO PAY. A LOT OF MONEY TO A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PLACES. THE CMT
SEASON UNQUALIFIED SUCCESS IN
CREATING A STATEWIDE STANDARD
THAT RESPECTS THE PROFESSION AND
ELEVATES IT. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WE SHOULD ASK WHEN
TALKING ABOUT LICENSURE IS WHO
EXACTLY WANTS TO. I TALKED TO
MANY PEOPLE ALL THE TIME I
PERSONALLY EMPLOYED OVER A
HUNDRED MASSAGE THERAPISTS. IF I
HAD A NICKEL FOR EVERY TIME ONE
OF THEM. TOOK ME ON THE SHIRT
AND SAID HEY STEVE WHEN WE GONNA
GET STATEWIDE LICENSURE. I HAVE
ZERO NICHOLS. OKAY NOBODY IS
CLAMORING FOR THIS BECAUSE WHAT
THEY HAVE RIGHT NOW WORKS VERY
WELL FOR THEM. IT'S EFFECTIVE
IT'S FAIR. LADIES NOWADAYS RUNS
LIKE A CLOCK TO RIFIC. OKAY MORE
IMPORTANTLY AND PROBABLY MOST
IMPORTANTLY. IF THERE WERE GOING
TO BE CHANGES IN THE HISTORY THE
CMT C. IS THAT THEY'VE MADE
TWEAKS TO IMPROVE. NOW'S NOT THE
TIME TO DO IT. THE BUSINESSES
THAT I REPRESENT AND SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT MIGHT CONCERN
REPRESENTS ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
REALLY HARD HIT DURING THE TWO
YEARS OF THE PANDEMIC MIKE'S MY
STORES WERE SHUT DOWN FOR TEN
MONTHS. OKAY THERECOVERY FROM
THIS IS GONNA TAKE AN EPICALLY
LONG PERIOD OF TIME. WE REQUEST
AND FULL THROATED WE ENDORSE A
FIVE YEAR EXTENSION IS C. N. T.
C. AND WE ALSO COMMIT TO BE A
WILLING PARTNER. IN TRYING TO
HELP IMPROVE ANY AREA OF CONCERN
THE C. MCC HAS- THE PEOPLE HAVE
A C. M. D. C. AND I KNOW FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. THE MEMBERS
OF THAT BOARD OR EQUALLY
COMMITTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON TO THE RIGHT AND OTHER
MEMBERS ON THE BOARD MY NAME IS
TIMOTHY DAVIS I'M THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF BURKE WILLIAMS DAY
SPA AND REPRESENT THEM HERE
TODAY I'M SIMPLY HERE TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT AT THE CENTER OF
ATTENTION FOR CFTC I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH THE C.
A. T. C. A. M. P. C. IN SOME
CAPACITY OVER OVER MY SIX PLUS
YOUR CAREER IN THE PHARMACY
INDUSTRY. THEIR EFORTS OVER THE
PAST FW YEARS NAVIGATING COAL
THAT HAD BEEN MONUMENTAL BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY THEIR
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT TO
SETTING AND ELEVATING INDUSTRY
STANDARDS AS WELL AS REGULATING
QUALITY MASSAGE THERAPY IN OUR
STATE HAVE SHOWN THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS AS IT RELATES TO
MASSAGE THERAPY SCHOOLING
PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE THERAPIST
AND THE OVERALL PUBLIC THE M. T.
V. AS PROVEN TO BE A LEADER AND
PIONEER IN SETTING STANDARDS IN
THE MASSAGE INDUSTRY SO A LITTLE
PUSHING FOR A LICENSING PROGRAM
THAT WOULD BE COSTLY DISRUPTED
AND TAKE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME TO IMPLEMENT IN HARMONY
WITH MANY OF MY PEERS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN THE INDUSTRY. I
STRONGLY URGE MAINTAINING THE
CURRENT C. A. M. P. C. MODEL AND
PROVIDING A FIVE YEAR INSPECTION
EXTENSION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU FOR THOSE OF YOU
IN THE GALLERY WHO WHO HAVE NOT
SPOKEN HOW MANY ARE LEFT TO
SPEAK RAISE YOUR HAND PLEASE.
OKAY THANKS PLEASE YOU KNOW THE
ADMONITION. SHORT GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ADRIAN KAPPA AND I
HAVE BEEN A MASSAGE THERAPIST
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS EIGHT OF THOSE
INCLUDING- BEING SUPPORTING AND
TRAINING OTHER THERAPISTS I AM
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF NATIONAL
HOLISTIC INSTITUTE WHICH IS THE
LARGEST AND FIRST ACCREDITED
MASSAGE SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE OVER TEN CAMPUSES OVER
CALIFORNIA AND WE- WE GRADUATE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
MASSAGE THERAPIST EVERY YEAR-
AND BECAUSE OF THAT BECAUSE THE
SEC'S RESPONSIBILITY TO US AND
THE RESPONSIVENESS THEIR
ATTENTION TO DETAIL EXCELLENT
STAFF AND THEIR HIGH STANDARDS
HAVE SET A HIGH BAR IN
REGULATING IMPORTANT PROMOTING
QUALITY MASSAGE THERAPY AND
QUALITY OF THEIR EDUCATION. THE
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE IS FAR
BETTER OFF IN THEIR EFFORTS
BECAUSE OF THIS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT BREAKTHROUGH THING TO
SEE ANOTHER FIVE YEARS THROUGH
THIS THAT THAT REVIEW THANK. YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. HI MY
NAME IS STACY REQUIRE A MASSAGE
THERAPIST WORKING IN PETALUMA
AND SAN FRANCISCO. I AM A PAST
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS CHAIR FOR
THE AMERICAN MASSAGE THERAPY
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
FULLY SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION
AND ASK FOR A FIVE YEAR
EXTENSION TO SEE A MTC. I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO LICENSURE
BILL. I'M VERY LEERY OF THE
SUNRISE SUBMITTED BY A BMP ABM
P. ADVOCATES FOR LICENSURE. ARE
TO OUT OF STATE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE INSURANCE TO
MASSAGE THERAPIST BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS ARE OUT OF TOUCH
WITH THE MASSAGE SITUATION AND
REGULATION IN CALIFORNIA. C.
CERTIFICATION IS BETTER THAN
LICENSURE FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS. C. M. C. DOES NOT COST
TAXPAYERS A DIME IT DOES NOT ADD
TO THE STATE BUDGET AND IT DOES
NOT ADD TO THE GROWING CALPERS
EXPENDITURES. SECONDLY THE FEES
FOR MASSAGE THERAPIST THAT WE
PAY ARE REASONABLE AND MANY
MASSAGE THERAPIST HERE. THAT
THEY WILL GO UP EXPONENTIALLY
WITH LICENSURE. CERTIFICATION
DOES PROVIDE A CLEARLY DEFINED
CRITERIA FOR MASSAGE
PROFESSIONALS. THE PUBLIC CAN
EASILY VERIFY THIS WE DON'T NEED
A SCOPE OF PRACTICE LAW BECAUSE
WE RARELY HARM OUR CLIENTS FOR
OVER TEN YEARS THE ATHLETIC
TRAINERS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
A SCOPE OF PRACTICE LAW. AND
THEY HAVE FAILED. AND THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE ISSUES OF
COMMERCIAL SEX THAT PLAGUE THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. MY SISTER
WILL NOT CHANGE PROSTITUTION
HUMAN TRAFFICKING OR SEXUAL
ASSAULT LICENSURE WILL NOT STOP
LOCALITIES FROM PLACING ONEROUS
EXPENSIVE AND EXCLUSIONARY LAND
USE RESTRICTIONS USUALLY IN THE
FORM OF CONDITIONAL USE PERMIT.
OR ZONING LIMITATIONS ON OUR
MASSAGE BUSINESSES. PANDEMIC IS
BECAUSE INCOME LOSS AND HARDSHIP
TO MASSAGE COMMUNITY WHAT WE
NEED NOW IS BILITY
EXTEND CMT C. CENTER FOR FIVE
YEARS AND STOP HAVING ITS RETURN
FOR HEARINGS EVERY ONE TO THREE
YEARS THANK YOU. I CAN ASSURE
YOU WE WON'T BE DOING THAT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. NEXT
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
BERMAN- CHAIRMAN RALPH- ANDREW
GARSTEN I'M THE REGIONAL
DEVELOPER FOR MASSAGE AND BE IN
THE LOS ANGELES AREA. AND ALSO
WITH MY WIFE HELEN THE OWNER OF
MISOGYNY IN GLENDALE. WE OPENED
THIRTY NINE LOCATIONS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FOR THE LAST
EIGHTEEN YEARS. A COUNTY WITH
EIGHTY SEVEN MUNICIPALITIES WE
NAVIGATED ALL KINDS OF MUNICIPAL
CODES WE CHANGED THE SPORT CODES
WENT THROUGH CONDITIONAL USE
PERMITS. WE SPONSORED LAW
ENFORCEMENT GOLF TOURNAMENTS WE
SPOKE WITH POLITICIANS. WE
TALKED TO SCHOOLS ALL THE TIME
WE EMPLOYED HUNDREDS OF MASSAGE
THERAPIST THOUSANDS OF CLIENTS
THAT ARE BOTH BUSINESSES WE ARE
THE NEXUS OF THE INDUSTRY SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE. AND NO WHERE AND
NONE OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AS
ANYBODY SAID THERE'S A PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE WITH C. M. D. C.
FOR THE VOLUNTARY CERTIFICATION
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE TODAY. SO I
WONDER WHY ARE WE GIVING THE
GENTLEMAN FROM ILLINOIS. AND
COLORADO SO MUCH TIME. TO TRY TO
MANIPULATE THE PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S PROFESSIONAL
MASSAGE INDUSTRY PLEASE LET'S
NOT HAVE THEM BACK AGAIN THEY'VE
ALREADY MADE US COME TWICE IN
ONE YEAR. THEY WERE ORIGINALLY
PARTLY SUPPORTING THIS
ORGANIZATION I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THEY'VE STOPPED BUT WE'RE
DONE WE NEED TO FOCUS ON OUR OWN
PROBLEMS WE HAVE. A LOT OF
ISSUES TO DEAL WITH HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BEFORE COMING OUT OF
COVERAGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. ANY
FURTHER. TWO MORE OKAY THANKS
PLEASE SHORT IS BETTER. MY NAME
IS VERONICA MACHADO AND I
SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL OPPOSE THE STATE
LICENSING. THANK YOU YOU GET THE
GOLD STAR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN ROBSON CHAIRMAN BERMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM MARK DIXON I'M A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT AND A MASSAGE
THERAPIST. I'VE BEEN A
PROFESSIONAL MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN MASSAGE THERAPY
ASSOCIATION FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AND HAVE SERVED ON THE
NATIONAL AND CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
BOARDS OF DIRECTORS OF THE
ASSOCIATION. MY POSITION IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT OF THE MTA
WHICH IS IN FAVOR OF MANDATORY
LICENSURE MASSAGE THERAPISTS.
THEY AIM T. REPRESENTS ROUGHLY
EIGHT THOUSAND FOR ABOUT 16% OF
THE FIFTY THOUSAND THERAPISTS
CURRENTLY CERTIFIED BY C. A. M.
P. C. THE AMC IS APPOINTED
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE SEA GAMES
IS HE BORED. A FORMER AMP
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER PRESIDENT HAS
VOTED MULTIPLE TIMES TO CONTINUE
C. A. M. P. C. AS A NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATION. I HOPE YOU'LL
AGREE WITH HIM AND WITH ME AND
ALLOW C. M. T. C. TO CONTINUE
ITS VITAL WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
PROFESSION. AND THE PUBLIC IT
SERVES IN CALIFORNIA. I'M IN
FAVOR OF CONTINUING SING ANTI C.
AS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPISTS AND
APPROVING MASSAGE TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA. FOR OVER
THIRTEEN YEARS IT HAS BEEN
WORKING. AND WORKING MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND LESS EXPENSIVELY
THAN FORTY FIVE STATE BOARDS
THANK YOU AND GOOD DAY THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER. CARPENTERS IN THE
GALLERY PERFECT LET ME JUST SAY
TO THOSE VIEWING THE GALLERY YOU
GET AN EIGHT TODAY YOU DID A
GREAT JOB. OKAY LET'S MOVE TO
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL. VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR WAS MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
INDIVIDUALS AND WE WILL CONTINUE
. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE
A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ABOUT
. FIFTEEN TO TWENTY M. Q. ONE
LINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERMAN LAW ENSURE
MEMBER AND MEMBERS I AM DOCTOR
STEPHANIE POWELL THE DIRECTOR OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING AND
SURVIVOR SERVICES BUT THE
NATIONAL CENTER ON SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION I AM ALSO A THIRTY
YEAR VETERAN THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT IN WHICH I
WOULD HAVE LIKED THANK YOU WE
ARE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING THE
VICTIMS OF SEX TRAFFICKING WE
WORK EVERY DAY TO BUILD A WORLD
THAT IS FREE FROM SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION. AS WELL AS SEXUAL
ABUSE AND C. M. T. C. IT'S TRULY
BEEN A PARTNER IN THE EFFORT
SAME TO YOU SHE IS A MODEL OF
HOW RELIABLE AND RESPONSIBLE
EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT ACTION IN
ASSOCIATION WITH LOCAL- PUBLIC
SAFETY AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE
LEGISLATURE HAD EVERY REASON TO
BE PROUD PC AND THE EXPECTED-
AND THERE THANK GOODNESS AS WELL
AS THE COST EFFECTIVENESS AND
COLLABORATIVE MANNER WITH WHICH
THEY HAVE HELP THOSE OF US ON
THE FRONT LINE OF COMBAT.
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA BUT MY
NATIONAL VANTAGE POINT WE HAVE
SEEN FIRST HAND HOW INSENSITIVE
OUR INEFFECTIVE STATEMENT SIDE
SCORED FIFTEEN IN ADDRESSING
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THE FACT THAT
HE PROTECTING VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND KEEPING BARBARA
PEOPLE FROM BECOMING EXPLOITED.
AND ANYTHING THAT YOU TAKE THEM
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
CONGRATULATED IN INNOVATIVE WORK
YOU HAVE DONE ON THE SITE THEY
COLLATION CALIFORNIA CMAC THE
ATM CC THE CALIFORNIA MODEL
REALLY DEMONSTRATE AN EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT WAY TO COMBAT
SEXUAL ABUSE AND EXPLOITATION
AND LASTLY I WILL LIK TO STATE
THAT WE BELIEVE SO STRONGLY IN
THEM AT THE SHINING EXAMPLE IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY REGULATE THE
MASSAGE INDUSTRY AND HOW IT CAN
BE DONE. THAT WE FEATURED THEM
AS A MODEL IN OUR ANNUAL GLOBAL
SUMMIT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHERE IT WAS BEGINNING TO MORE
THAN. TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
EIGHTY FROM A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWENTY WE SHOULD WITH MY THAT
ONLY NASH BUT- BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE REPLICA THE FUTURE BY
THE LIKE. OF THE FIVE THANK YOU
. OKAY NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINES NOW PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
LINE SEVEN NINE BUT YOU PROCEED
LET ME JUST MAKE A STATEMENT FOR
THOSE WAITING ON THE LINE IF WE
HAVE. FIFTEEN TO TWENTY OR
TWENTY FIVE CALLERS WAITING THIS
PROCESS WILL TAKE. AN HOUR TO AN
HOUR AND A HALF IF WE DON'T
KEEP. THE COMMENTS TO THE BARE
MINIMUM SO I WOULD ASK YOU TO
TRY TO STICK. TO A MINUTE OR TWO
WITH YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE CHERRY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL TRY TO BE BRIEF MY
NAME IS TRACY AVELAR AND THE
SECOND VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. AND CHAIR OF THE
CPC A LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING ALL
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
POLICE CHIEFS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CORN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL OR C. A. M. P.
C. C. M. D. C. HAS BEEN A
CRUCIAL STRATEGIC PARTNER TO THE
CLEAN. SHEET FOR MANY YEARS. AS
A NON PROFIT ORGANIZATION THE
AGENCY HAS DONE AMAZING WORK
ASSISTING CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IN OUR EFFORTS TO
BRING AN END TO A HORRIFIC
REALITY OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY CONTINUE TO
ASSIST US WITH THEIR STRUCTURE
THE COURT BY OFFERING VOLUNTARY
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR. MY
SON'S THIRTIETH. RUSSIAN
APPROVAL OF THE THERAPY DINNER
STATE PREVENTING MY HUMAN TRY.
ACT IN THE FIRST PLACE. THE PA
AND HE MODEL MASSAGE THIRTY. AND
THERE VEHICLE CREW WILL HAVE
GREATLY HELPED US IDENTIFY AND
ROOT OUT. ILLICIT ACTIVITY
ALLOWING FOR SWIFT ACTION TO BE
TAKEN ON ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES SUCH
AS HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THE
EXPEDIENCY WITH WHICH C. A. M.
P. C. CAN EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
IMPROPRIETIES IN THE MASSAGE
THERAPY PROFESSION. GREATLY
AUGMENTS WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN ACCOMPLISH ALONE AS PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
COMMITMENT TO RUN A KATE AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN OUR STATE
OUR BOARD OF DIRECTORS VOTED TO
FULLY SUPPORT THE NPCS
CONTINUANCE. OF THE NONPROFIT MY
DISK IMAGE WE HOPE THAT YOU'LL
JOIN US IN SUPPORT OF THE ANTI
C. AND OUR CONTINUED FOCUS ON
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. AND ILLICIT
ACTIVITY. IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU IN LET
ME TO ALL STILL WAITING ON THE
PHONE LINE WE DID GET AN
EXTENSION OF OUR PHONE LINES SO
I WON'T HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF TOO
MUCH BUT I WOULD ASK. IF YOU
HAVE YOUR COMMENTS REDUCED TO
WRITING. PLEASE CONSIDER SIMILAR
SUBMITTING THE LINK TO YOUR
COMMENTS TO OUR COMMITTEE
STAFFS. FOR INCLUSION IN THE
RECORD AND THAT WILL GIVE YOU A-
BETTER OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO
STICK TO THE MANAGER TO THAT
I'VE ASKED YOU TO DO- FOR THOSE.
ALSO WAITING ON THE LINE.
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
WHITE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I'M ALREADY RETIRED CHECK FROM
CREECH ADDED HE'S CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE MATTEO COUNTY IN
THE PORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL COUNCIL
EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE USE THE
BEST BUY STORE FRONT. AND
AVENUES FOR PROSTITUTION AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS WELL AS
OTHER RELATED ACTIVITIES. GIVEN
THE CHAIR TOWARDS I'LL KEEP IT
BRIEF BUT OUR COUNTY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF THE T. A. T. T.
AS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
IMPLEMENTING A STATEWIDE
VOLUNTARY CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
AND ANY ATTEMPT TO MAKE A THINK
LIKE EIGHTY PEOPLE HURT IN ROAD
TO COMBAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU PRECIADO
NEXT PLEASE MODERATOR. THANK YOU
BYE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS BROKE MINE AND THE
CLIENT ADVOCACY MANAGER FROM
ACCUSATION WOMAN COMING IN A DAY
ASIAN IMMIGRANT WOMEN TEND TO BE
THE TARGETED VICTIMS OF ILLICIT
MASSAGE BUSINESSES AND TO DO
THAT I SUPPORT THE MTC AT THE
NONPROFIT TO IMPLEMENT VOLUNTARY
CERTIFICATION. OF MASSAGE
THERAPISTS AND IMPROVEMENT BY
SCHOOL I MANAGE TORY LICENSED BY
NTCA BOARD WILL HARM EFFORTS TO
PREVENT AN ABATEMENT TRAFFICKING
UNDER THE GUISE OF MISSILES I
FEAR THAT REMOVAL OF THE COUNCIL
WILL RESULT IN HIGHER RATES OF
TEXTRON THINKING AN ASIAN
IMMIGRANT WOMEN UE TO A
REDUCTION OF BARRIERS FOR
TRAFFICKERS. ONLY COULD FURTHER
HARM I THINK THEM THROUGH LEGAL
ACTION REQUIRED BY A LICENSING
LAW BUT THERE ARE DEFECTS AND
OTHER FRAUDULENT MASSAGE SCHOOL
AND TRAFFICKERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS PLEASE MOTOR. THANK YOU
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS PAMELA. I'M THE SAME AS
YOUR COUNTY HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
PLEASE PROVIDE HABITAT COUNTY
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROGRAM
COORDINATOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PROGRAM WE DIED IN THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE IS THAT WE CAN'T COUNTY
IT TAKES QUALITY IN DIRECTION
FROM THE POLICE CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. I'M HERE
TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL THE
CURRENT MODEL WORKS WELL IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'M GONNA CLOSE
WITH SAYING I CONCUR WITH THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTS MADE IN
SUPPORT OF C. A. M. P. C. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR THE
BREVITY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK MY
NAME IS KITTY CALVERT AND I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE HANDSOME
TRADE ASSOCIATION AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE GONNA SAY SOME THAT'S
BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS WE ALSO REPRESENT CURRENT
THERAPIST IN CALIFORNIA
BELIEVE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL GREATLY
BENEFITS THE PUBLIC QUIT HIS
HIGH PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS WE
FULLY SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION
OF A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION ADMINISTERING
VOLUNTARY CERTIFICATION THERE.
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. I'VE
BEEN A MISSILE THERAPY FOR SO
YEAR ANIMUS FOLLOWED HISTORIAN
FOR THIRTY SEVEN YEARS. THROUGH
OUR LONG HISTORY I KNOW THAT
MASSAGE THERAPY NEEDS TO BE
CONSTANTLY ELEVATED AND SET AT A
HIGH STANDARD BECAUSE IT SHOULD
ALWAYS BE ABOUT POSSIBLE HEALTHY
PATCH I BELIEVE THAT THE CNPC
STRIVE TO KEEP CALM ELEVATORS.
AND WORKS TO HELP KEEP
SUPPORTING THE PUBLIC WITH THEIR
CONTINUED HARD WORK AND NOT SELF
INTEREST. BUT THE INTEREST OF
THE PUBLIC CAN THERAPIST WE ALL
NEED TO WORK TOGETHER AND FIND
WAYS TO HARMONIZE FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF THE PUBLIC AS IT
RELATES TO HOSPITALITY TOUCH AND
THEY HOPE THE MANY THERAPISTS
WHO CARRIED THE BANNER. FOR WORK
AND ADVANCE THE- I THANK YOU
AFTER LOG WORK. I'LL HELP THE-
YEAH WHAT IS THE FRONT PAGE OF
OUR CORPORATE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT MY- THANK YOU
MINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JACQUELINE DOUBLE AND I'M A
MASSAGE THERAPIST OF EIGHTEEN
YEARS I AM CURRENTLY WORKING IN
MOUNTAIN VIEW AND I AM IN FAVOR
OF THE PMPC FRIEND EITHER FIVE
YEARS AND UP CLOSE THE PUSH FOR
ME FIVE MY TEACHER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. CNBC HAS PROVEN
ITSELF EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
THE DATA AND A QUICK LOOK AT
HISTORY TELL US THAT WHILE
MOVING TO LIKE THE THING BODY
WILL BE CREEPY FIFTEEN HE
CHRISTIAN B. BY INCREASING THE
LAYERS OF BUREAUCRACY IT WILL
SIMULTANEOUSLY INCREASE COSTS.
WHICH WE PASS ON TO
PROFESSIONALS IN THE FIELD THE
RESULT WILL BE FEWER ETHICAL AND
LEGITIMATE MASSAGE PROFESSIONALS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHILE
INCREASING THE PERCENTAGE OF
ILLICIT MASSAGE PARLORS IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ESTABLISHMENT.
PUTTING CONSUMERS AND THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AT RISK I'VE
BEEN A MTA MEMBER IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THEY BE AWARE
THAT I LET YOU KNOW THAT THEY DO
NOT SPEAK FOR ME A REPRESENT MY
OPINION ON THE MATTER. I HAVE
BEEN A MASSAGE THERAPIST LOCALLY
LONG ENOUGH TO REMEMBER THE
INVASIVE HUMILIATING AN
INAPPROPRIATE ACT YEAH I THINK I
LOVE MY LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT
IF YOU I'M RESIGNED TO THE IDEA
THAT I WAS GOING TO OPERATE
ILLEGALLY AS A SEX WORKER. EVERY
COLLEGE BARGAINING COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OPERATING MY
MASSAGE BUSINESS CREEPY AMCC ANY
SPEAKER COLLECTED INDEPENDENTLY
IN EACH CITY AND WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
JURISDICTIONS I DO NOT WISH TO
RETURN TO THAT TIME LET US MOVE
FORWARD AND CONTINUE TO ELEVATE
THE PROFESSION AND CONTINUE TO
PROTECT AND SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES. BY SUPPORTING THE
T. A. M. PT AND REJECTING THE
MOVE TOWARDS MY TEACHER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR KIND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU I SIXTY NINE GO AHEAD.
YES JUSTIN GRAS I'M IN-
CALIFORNIA LICENSES THERAPIST AS
WELL AS SORT OF PART BUT DOING
IT SINCE TEN ONE AND KEEP IT
BRIEF I DO SUPPORT THE C. A. M.
P. C. IT'S BEEN A GREAT
ORGANIZATION AND WE WISH TO
CONTINUE IT FOR ANOTHER FIVE
YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A
GOOD DAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BREVITY THANKS YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS DR CAROLINE J. SAN
JOSE I'VE BEEN TO SEE EMPTY
SEATS CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST FOR THIRTEEN YEARS THE
MASSAGE THERAPIST FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS I WAS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE NPA BROKEN VALLEY UNIT
FOR FIVE YEARS. AS A MEMBER OF
THE EMPTY FOR THE PAST TWENTY
ONE YEARS I AND JACK TO THEIR
SUPPORT OF LICENSURE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE LICENSE
OR MODEL THREATEN PUBLIC HEALTH
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE INTEGRITY
OF THE MASSAGE PROFESSION AS
SENATOR REID MENTIONED WE HAVE
UNIQUE SANDBOX HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE REQUIRE NOVEL
APPROACHES LIKE THE A AND P. C.
TO KEEP UR PUBLIC SAFETY. AN
ARMED GUARD SERVICE CREDENTIALS
PLEASE CONTINUE. C. A. M. P. C.
FOR AT LEAST FIVE YEARS. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS BRENDA I'M A FOLDER FULL
OF PRACTITIONERS SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND A MEMBER OF AMPA
PRACTICING GROVER BEACH- I THINK
A LOT OF DISCRIMINATION FROM MY
CITY AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
CNBC HAS BEEN CENTRAL TO MY
BUSINESS I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
PRACTICE. WITHOUT THEIR SUPPORT
IN SEPTEMBER I WAS TOLD BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THAT HE
NEEDED TO QUOTE BE ABLE TO COME
INTO YOUR OFFICE AND CATCH YOU
TOUCHING YOUR CLIENT CHANNEL
CNBC REPORTED IMMEDIATELY TOOK
ACTION TO HELP RESOLVE THIS
ISSUE I FEEL THE ONLY REASON I
GET TREATED PROFESSIONALLY IN MY-CITIES WITH THEIR CONTINUED
AFTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
NINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES MY NAME IS LAUREN. I'M A
FIFTH GENERATION CALIFORNIAN
VERY FAMILIAR WITH HOW THE
MUNICIPALITIES AND LEGISLATURE
BOOKS I HAD. I AM AN- CERTIFYING
MASSAGE THERAPIST SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE NICE GRADUATED
SCHOOL TWO THOUSAND EIGHT- I
HAVE HELPED THE MUNICIPALITIES
IN WRITING THEIR LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS THE SITUATION WITH THE
TRASH THERE. I DO NOT SUPPORT C.
NG C. TO CONTINUE ONE MOMENT
LONGER THAN ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
. WE HAVE DONE A DISSERVICE TO
THE MASSAGE INDUSTRY THOSE OF US
THAT ARE SOLE PRACTITIONERS-
SUFFERED ABUSE DURING THE COLDER
THE ERROR BECAUSE THEY GAVE US
SUCH BAD MISINFORMATION. I DO
BELONG TO AT&T AND I FULLY
SUPPORT WHAT A BMP AND AMCA HOPE
SAID TODAY PLEASE HAVE A LICENSE
WE DESERVE IT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE MODERATE. NEXT PLEASE.
NINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU MY NAME IS MONICA
HEIN I ONLY TO MASSAGE
BUSINESSES IN THE BAY AREA AN
EMPLOYEE OVER THIRTY MASSAGE
THERAPIST MOST OF WHOM ARE WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR VIRTUALLY
ALL ARE MEMBERS OF AT AND T. OR
A. M. P. A. AND THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE NOT BOTHERED
TO ASK THEM WHETHER THEY SUPPORT
LAW LICENSING. THERE CLEARLY OUT
OF TOUCH WITH THE INDUSTRY
CALIFORNIA AND EVIDENCED BY
THEIR COMMON QUALITY ARE THERE
CAN'T AFFORD EXPENSIVE WHAT THE
PROFIT WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE
ERICA WE'VE ONLY JUST BARELY
RECOVERED THE GROUND A LOT
DURING THE CONVENTION DOWN YOU
CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE ANY
MOMENTUM OR WE WON'T SURVIVE.
OKAY THANKS COLLABORATING WITH
THE A. M. P. C. A WOULD BE TO
PRINT PROFESSION FROM WITH IN
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM AND EXTEND
THEIR AUTHORITY FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS THANK YOU THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH FEDERER NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M NINE PLEASE AHEAD
. HELLO MY NAME IS ADAM SHARON
I'M A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN
SAN DIEGO WE'VE BEEN SAUCE AND
SPONSORED OVER SIXTEEN YEARS AND
OVER SIXTY EMPLOYEES ONLY
SUPPORT CONTINUING THE MODEL
CREATED BY C. ANTES DE AND
CERTIFICATIONS. SUCH SERVICE BY
CNPC- VERY MUCH AGAIN CREATING
LICENSING FOR ALL THE REASONS
DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY BUT HE
CREATES MORE BUREAUCRACY AND
HAVING TO BE MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
THERAPISTS ARE INDUSTRY-
POSSIBLY THE WORST TIME AS WE
MENTIONED BEFORE TO MAKE ANY
MAJOR CHANGES IN OUR INDUSTRY
WE'RE JUST COMING OUT OF. THAT
MAKE. DEFINED PEOPLE TO WORK AND
WE'RE JUST CALLING BACK
CONSTRUCTOR YET. AND ANY
OBSTACLES TO THIS AT THIS POINT-
ONE OF THE NEAR FUTURE WE'LL
JUST- INTEREST EVEN FURTHER.
ADDITIONALLY I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT- DURING THE PANDEMIC OF
CNPC WAS VERY QUICK. TO UPDATE
OFTEN PLUS TAX CHANGING STATE
AND COUNTY POLICIES PROVIDING
SUGGESTIONS AND GUIDANCE WHICH
IS MUCH APPRECIATED. THIS IS A
STARK CONTRAST TO THE BOARD OF
COSMETOLOGY WE TOOK PART TO LOG
ONTO THE WEBSITE AT ALL. THE
DOCTOR BY ANY GUIDANCE
RESTITUTION LAWS. AND MANY
FINALLY WILL BE ABLE TO GET A
HOLD OF SOMEBODY BY EMAIL SINCE
THERE WAS NOBODY AVAILABLE ON-
ALL THEY SAID WAS SIMPLY TO-
CALL THE LOCAL. COUNTY. HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND THEY DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW ANYTHING. THIS IS NOT TIME
TO. THIS IS THE PRIMARY NEEDED
IN THE- SO I'M JUST SAY THAT.
YOU THE TYPE OF INCOME. YOUR
DEPARTMENT WE NEED TO REPLICATE
THE MASSAGE THERAPY INDUSTRY
THANK YOU THANKS FOR NEXT PLEASE
. THANK YOU LINE FORTY EIGHT
PEOPLE HAD. IF YOU. NEXT PLEASE
I AM FORTY EIGHT. ONE MEAL HELLO
MY NAME IS LINDA CURTIS AND I AM
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN SAN
FRANCISCO SECTION I JOIN WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORTING THE
CURRENT ROLE OF THE CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL IN
CERTIFYING THAT MASSAGE
THERAPISTS AND BEDDING
OCCUPATIONAL MASSAGE TRAINING
SCHOOLS. AMONG OTHER SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES MY ORGANIZATION
IS INVOLVED IN COMBATING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND IT'S INSIDIOUS
EFFECTS ON IMMIGRANTS AND OTHER
VULNERABLE- INDIVIDUALS- ALSO I
WORKED AS A VOCATIONAL REVISIT
BILLET PATIENT COUNSELOR FOR THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION FOR THIRTY YEARS
AND I SAW DAMAGE TO VULNERABLE
PEOPLE FROM. BOGUS PREDATORY. IN
QUOTE TRAINING SCHOOLS THE CA M.
P. C. HAS CONDUCTED ITS
OVERSIGHT ROLE EFFECTIVELY ON
BEHALF OF MASSAGE THERAPIST AND
IS A VALUED PARTNER WITH ALL OF
US ANTI HUMAN TRAFFICKING
GROUPS- TO PROMOTE SAFETY AND
INTEGRITY OF A WORK FORCE THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE SUBJECT TO
EXPLOITATION AND CRIMINALITY-
AND YET THE MOST IMPORTANT. THEY
SHOW UP RIGHT AWAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FEDERER NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I AM
WE ARE MANY- I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE CONTINUED EXISTENCE OF THIS
GAME TO SEE- I'M THROWING OUT
THE THROWING AWAY WHAT I HAD
PLANNED TO SAY AND JUST TO GIVE
YOU A DIFFERENT. PERSPECTIVE
FROM A DIFFERENT PERSON WITH A
PHD FROM STANFORD IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE I WOKED IN THAT
PROFESSION PROFESSION FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES I COULD
TRANSITION MY CAREER TO MASSAGE
THERAPY- I WORK PRIMARILY WITH
PATIENTS IN HOSPITALS INCLUDING
STANFORD HOSPITAL SINCE NINETY
FOUR. AFTER CHILDREN SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND THE POWER OF
THE VETERANS ADMINISTRATION
INPATIENT HOSPICE. FROM TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. I'VE BEEN A CERTIFIED
SINCE ITS INCEPTION BY THE C. M.
T. C. R. DURING THE BEFORE THE
CNPC I WORKED WITH THE CITY OF
PALO ALTO AND THE AND THE-
POLICE DEPARTMENT THEY'RE TRYING
TO DEAL WITH THE WILD WEST WEST.
OF ACTIVITIES OF PROSTITUTION
SEX TRAFFICKING AND MANY ILL
PREPARED TRACK PRACTITIONERS
FROM DIPLOMA MILL SCHOOLS THE C.
A. M. P. C. HAS TURNED THAT
AROUND. I WAS PREVIOUSLY A
MEMBER OF THE MTA I STRONGLY
OBJECT TO THEIR PUSH AND
LIKEWISE THE A. B. M. P. WHERE
I'M A MEMBER NOW IN ORDER TO GET
INSURANCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS KATIE MICKEY%
AND I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA BARBARA BODY THERAPY
INSTITUTE THREE THOUSAND
GRADUATES AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC
UTILIZES THE SERVICES OF OUR
INSTITUTE IN THE DOZENS OF SPOTS
THROUGHOUT THE TRI COUNTIES. AND
IS A MEMBER OF THE SCHOOL
ADVISORY BOARD AND PC I HAVE
BEEN IN SCHOOL OWNER FOR THE
LAST THIRTY TWO YEARS AND A
PRACTICING MASSAGE THERAPIST FOR
THE LAST THIRTY SEVEN YEARS. AND
I AM. SPEAKING HERE TO OPPOSE
STATE LICENSURE AND TO SUPPORT
THE CONTINUATION. OF THE AMP
THREE. AND I WAS QUITE THAT YOU
CAN PUT DISCUSSION OF LICENSURE
FOR AT LEAST ANOTHER FIVE YEARS
THE PAST YEAR LOCKDOWN HAS BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT FOR MASSAGE
SCHOOLS IN THE FASTER. THE
GENERAL PUBLIC ARE NOW- MAKING
MASSAGE THERAPIST MORE THAN EVER
WE HAVE DOZENS OF SPOTS WHO ARE
SEEKING- FORTY. THERAPIST COULD
BE HIRED IMMEDIATELY DUE TO THE
COLD IN NINETEEN LOCKDOWN WE DO
NOT HAVE GRADUATE IS STILL ALL
THESE POSITIONS. THAT HE
SUPPORTS THE CONTINUANCE OF THE
PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE
HEALTHCARE- TO CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST PLEASE SUPPORT THE
CONTINUANCE OF THE CITY AND
COUNTRY WE NEED STABILITY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BUT
RETURN NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE EIGHTY THREE PEOPLE HAD. HI
MY NAME IS DOCTOR BEEN DRILLING
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA METHODICAL
ASSOCIATION THEY'RE WILLING TO
PAY BOTH CONTINUATION OF THE MP
THREE OH FIVE MORE YEARS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE MARC METHOT OR ARE
DOING FOR THEIR YEAH IF YOU
CURRENTLY APPROVAL WHICH WILL BE
FOUR MORE YEARS APPROVAL TIME
YOU CREATE AN UNDUE HARDSHIP ON
SCHOOLS TO GO THROUGH THE
REGULAR PROCESS IF YOU COULD BE
THE ONLY REALTOR RIGHT ONE TWO
OR THREE YEARS. WHO CANNOT
PROPERLY FUNCTION WITH THE LEVEL
OF UNCERTAINTY MEMBER CALLED ME
TO FINALLY IN RHODE ISLAND AND
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE WE'LL DO IT
PEOPLE ONLY ONE TOOL THREE YEAR.
PUT METHODICAL IN LIMBO SUCH A
LEVEL OF REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY
WILL DAMAGE MALL COURT IN
MAKHACHKALA THINKING INDICATION
WE DO NOT SUPPORT LIKE THE THIRD
BUT WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT THE
DISCUSSION IN AN ATMOSPHERE
WHERE BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS ARE
NO DAMAGE TO THE POINT OF
CLOSURE. AT THE VERY LEAST LEAVE. GAVE HIM FIFTY FIVE MORE
YEARS. THANK VERY MUCH YOU AND I
PLEASE. THANK YOU NINE SIX ONE
PLEASE CALL. NEXT PLEASE NINE
SIX ONE. LET ME PLEASE PRETTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS-
WILL NORRIS- I'VE BEEN THEM
ACROSS THEIR DESKS FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS NOW AND I SUPPORT- THE CMT
C. FOR ANOTHER FIVE YEARS AND I
DO NOT SUPPORT LICENSING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU. OKAY HAVING HEARD ALL
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. HELLO MISTER
BERMAN ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNCIL I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
DURING THIS HEARING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU WHAT I LIKE
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF OUR
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE AND WITNESSES FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY TODAY. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC BOTH HERE
IN THE GALLERY AND ON THE PHONE
LINES FOR SHARING THEIR STORIES.
AND COMMENTING ON THE ISSUES
BEFORE US WITH RESPECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY FOR WHATEVER REASON VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
OR THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS. AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE OR FEEL
FREE TO VISIT OUR RESPECTIVE
WEBSITES. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE TRULY IMPORTANT
TO US WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY. IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD SO TO EVERYONE.
BOTH HERE. AND ON THE TELEPHONE
LINES. BOTH WITNESSES. ALEX
PARTICIPANTS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION.
WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
OF THIS JOINT HEARING THE JOINT
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARING
FOR TODAY IS ADJOURNED.